SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL
COME TO ORDER. THIS IS THE
MORNING VERSION OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. AS YOU KNOW, WE DO
ALLOW SIX MINUTES OF TESTIMONY
PER SIDE. SO WE'D LIKE TO MOVE
THROUGH THE AGENDA. SO IF YOU
DON'T NEED IT, DON'T USE IT. WE
HAVE 24 BILLS ON THE AGENDA. TEN
OF THEM ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. I WILL GO THROUGH IT
NOW AND HOPEFULLY I WON'T NEED
TO GO THROUGH IT AGAIN. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB 2058 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WEBER MEDICAL DEVICE
DISCLOSURES. ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
2072 ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WEBER
GROUP. HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 22 0707
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. ITEM
NUMBER 11 AB 2376 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, BAYNES CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCY RECOVERY. HOSPITALS
WITH AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 12
AB 2383 ASSEMBLY MEMBER WENDY
CARRILLO, STATE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES, ITEM
NUMBER 13, AB 2434. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. ITEM NUMBER 16 AB 2843
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, PETRIE-NORRIS
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. RAPE AND
SEXUAL ASSAULT. ITEM NUMBER 18
AB 2866 ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN
POOL SAFETY. ITEM NUMBER 19 AB
2871 ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
OVERDOSE FATALITY REVIEW TEAMS.
ITEM NUMBER 21 AB 2914 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, BONTA HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. THAT'S OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR WHEN WE GET TO IT.
LET'S START WITH OUR FIRST ITEM,
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB 347. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TANG HOUSEHOLD PRODUCT
SAFETY. WELCOME PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN READY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. FIRST, LET ME JUST THANK
THE COMMITTEE. YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR HELP ON THE BILL.
WE ARE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY, AB 347 WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL TO TEST,
ENFORCE AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH ALL EXISTING LAWS
REGULATING THE USE OF PFAS
CHEMICALS IN FOOD PACKAGING,
JUVENILE PRODUCTS AND TEXTILES.
IT ALSO ASKS CDPH TO REGULATE
THE COSMETICS, THE COSMETICS
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN THE LAWS
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED TO ALSO
REGULATE PFAS. AS YOU KNOW,
WE'VE ASKED A NUMBER OF
GROUNDBREAKING BILLS TO LOOK AT
PFAS AND TO MAKE SURE THAT PFAS
GETS OUT OF CERTAIN PRODUCTS.
THE PRODUCTS THAT I LISTED. YET
THERE WAS NO ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM OR NO REGULATORY
MECHANISM THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN
ANY OF THOSE BILLS. THIS BILL
WILL DEVELOP A REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THE INDUSTRY IS COMPLYING
WITH OUR STATE LAWS. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE DTSC DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS,
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS, AND WE
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. I KNOW WE ARE NOT
COMPLETELY QUITE THERE YET, AND
SO WE ARE COMMITTED TO DURING
RECESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL THOSE STAKEHOLDERS AND
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
AROUND, ESPECIALLY AROUND,
COSMETICS AND THE JURISDICTION
IN THAT AREA, WITH ME TODAY ARE
AVI CARR FROM NRDC AND BILL IYAD
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP. EXCUSE ME. WELCOME.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
AVI CARR, AND I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. AB 347 WOULD ADD
ENFORCEMENT FOR PREVIOUSLY
PASSED LAWS PHASING OUT FOREVER
TOXIC PFAS CHEMICALS IN MANY
CONSUMER PRODUCT CATEGORIES,
INCLUDING TEXTILES, FOOD
PACKAGING AND JUVENILE PRODUCTS.
PFAS ARE A CLASS OF MORE THAN
14,000 CHEMICALS USED FOR A WIDE
RANGE OF PURPOSES. THEY'RE
CALLED FOREVER CHEMICALS BECAUSE
THEY ARE HIGHLY PERSISTENT AND
MOBILE IN THE ENVIRONMENT,
MAKING THEM BOTH DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE TO REMEDIATE. PFAS
HAVE BEEN LINKED TO SEVERE
HEALTH PROBLEMS, INCLUDING
CANCER HORMONE DISRUPTION AND
IMMUNE SYSTEM DISRUPTION. AB 347
WILL ENHANCE ENFORCEMENT AND
HELP ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS GET
THE FULL BENEFIT OF THE LAWS
THAT HAVE PASSED PREVIOUSLY,
PHASING OUT PFAS IN PRODUCTS,
AND THAT BUSINESSES THAT COMPLY
WITH THE LAWS HAVE AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO AUTHORIZE THE DTSC TO
INTERPRET AND OTHERWISE
IMPLEMENT THE LAWS, INCLUDING
ADDRESSING SCOPE OF PRODUCTS,
AND THIS WILL PROVIDE CLARITY
AND CERTAINTY FOR BUSINESSES. AB
347 WILL HELP ENSURE THE
REQUIRED SUPPORT FOR REGULATED
BUSINESSES PROVIDE A CENTRAL
POINT OF ENGAGEMENT AND WILL
REDUCE THE RELIANCE ON THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND SPONSORS.
THE BILL ALSO PROVIDES A FUNDING
MECHANISM TO COVER THE AGENCY'S
REASONABLE COSTS FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE CHAPTER, AND SO
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 347.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT,
PLEASE. I'M BILL ALEO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE BILL,
SINCE THIS WILL BE THE LAST TIME
I EVER TESTIFY BEFORE THIS BODY
BECAUSE I'M RETIRING. OH
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU. AT
THE END OF THE YEAR, I THOUGHT,
WELL, WHAT COULD I SAY HERE? AND
I THOUGHT BACK TO WHEN GOVERNOR
DAVIS WAS RECALLED. WE HAD A
PARTY FOR HIM HERE, AND WE WERE
THANKING HIM FOR ALL THE BILLS
HE SIGNED INTO LAW. AND HE SAID,
THEY DON'T MEAN ANYTHING UNLESS
YOU ALL FOLLOW UP ON THEM AND
MAKE SURE THE AGENCIES ARE DOING
THEIR JOB. SO THAT'S WHY I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL. BY MR.
TING I WORKED ON THESE PFAS
BILLS, AND IF WE DON'T LOOK
AFTER THEM AND THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T, THEN THEY JUST SIT ON
THE BOOKS. SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES, IS IT MAKES SURE THAT
THERE IS IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
GOOD IDEAS WE HAD AND THE GOOD
MEETINGS WE HAVE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS HEALTH. THANK YOU.
I AGREE WITH YOU. WE DO PRECIOUS
LITTLE TO CHECK ON WHAT WE DO
AND MAKE SURE IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND CORRECT THAT
THAT NEEDS CORRECTION. SO THANKS
FOR POINTING THAT OUT. AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR CAREER.
THANK YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. TAKE YOUR TIME, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION,
PLEASE. HI ERICA PARKER WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I THINK YOU CAN JUST
MOVE OVER TO YOUR YOUR RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD. PROCEED WHEN READY AND
YOU ALL CAN FLIP A COIN. DECIDE
WHO GOES FIRST. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS. ROB SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF MY
ASSOCIATION, AS WELL AS A
COALITION OF OTHER BUSINESSES
AND INDUSTRIES, WE ARE
REGRETTABLY OPPOSED, UNLESS
AMENDED TO AB 347 AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. FIRST AND FOREMOST,
CMTA AND OUR COALITION
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF IN
DRAFTING THE AMENDMENTS AND
WORKING WITH US ON TRYING TO
HELP NARROW THE SCOPE OF AB 347
TO ACTIVELY ADDRESS PFAS
CONTAMINATION, AS WELL AS
ENFORCEMENT FOR THE STATE AND
FOR THOSE BILLS THAT ARE COVERED
UNDER AB 347. THAT BEING THE
TEXTILE PRODUCTS AB 1817, AB 652
JUVENILE PRODUCTS AB 1200
RELATED TO PLANT BASED FOOD
PACKAGING AND COOKWARE, AS WELL
AS EXCUSE ME AS WELL AS, 2771
RELATED TO COSMETICS. SO
FUNDAMENTALLY, WE STILL HAVE,
EVEN WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS. AND NOW, I THINK
GREATER UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING
THE COSMETICS PROVISION, WHICH
MY COLLEAGUE WILL, WILL FURTHER
ADDRESS. BUT ON A MUCH MORE
HOLISTIC OR BROADER SCALE OF
WHERE WE ARE ON THE BILL, WE
AGREE THAT THE BILLS AND THE
ORPHAN CODE ISSUES SURROUNDING
ALL THE PREVIOUS LEGISLATION IS
A CHALLENGE, NOT ONLY FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO COMPLY, BUT
ALSO TO PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY
AND CLARITY SURROUNDING WHAT ARE
THE RULES OF THE GAME. AND WITH
THAT, WE AT CMTA, AS WELL AS OUR
COALITION, DO BELIEVE THAT 347
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TO PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY OF
ENFORCEMENT AND PREDICTABILITY
FOR THE REGULATED COMMUNITY. THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE, THOUGH,
IS 347 WHILE IT MAY HAVE
PROVIDED THE SKELETON OR THE
BASE OF THAT ENFORCEMENT, IT
DOESN'T REALLY FULLY AMPLIFY OR
DISCUSS WHAT ARE THOSE RULES.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN 347 WE HAVE
SITUATIONS INVOLVING LIKE A SKU
OR A STOCK KEEPING UNIT FOR, FOR
EXAMPLE, THE STOCK KEEPING UNITS
AS PART OF THIS BILL. THESE ARE
UNIQUE TO EVERY INDIVIDUAL
RETAILER. SO EVEN IF YOU ARE
PURCHASING OR PROVIDING A WHITE
T SHIRT, SAME COMPANY, SAME
BRAND, SAME COLOR, THAT SKEW
WILL BE DIFFERENT BETWEEN, LET'S
SAY A TARGET RETAILER AND A
WALMART RETAILER. SO HOW DO WE
END UP CREATING A SITUATION IN
WHICH A VIOLATION CAN BE
ADEQUATELY DETERMINED ACROSS A
WHOLE SECTION OR A WHOLE SECTOR
OF THESE PRODUCTS? WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE WHAT WE WOULD CALL,
A, YOU KNOW, A THRESHOLD OR A
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT SAMPLE
OF A VIOLATION OCCURRED ON ONE T
SHIRT. DOES THAT AUTOMATICALLY
PRESUME, THEN, THAT EVERY OTHER
ELEMENT INVOLVING THAT T SHIRT
OR INVOLVING THAT PRODUCT IS
ALSO DEEMED IN VIOLATION? WITH
THAT, WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
REGARDING, THE REGISTRATION AND
TESTING ELEMENTS, THE NOTICE OF
VIOLATION. WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND
SPECIFICALLY WHERE THE VIOLATION
OCCURRED ON FROM THE
MANUFACTURER. DTSC IN THIS BILL
SHOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION INVOLVING
THE THRESHOLD INVOLVING THE
DETERMINATION, THE TESTING
METHODS AND ACCURACY SURROUNDING
THAT. WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS
STILL ON ENFORCEMENT AND
DISCLOSURE. WHAT IS AGAIN, WHAT
ARE THE RULES OF THE GAME AS
WELL AS WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS
OVER TESTING CAPACITY IN THE
STATE. AND FOR ALL OF THESE
BILLS, WE ARE QUITE LITERALLY
TALKING ABOUT TENS, IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF VARIOUS
CONSUMER PRODUCTS THAT AT SOME
POINT AND AT SOME POINT HAVE TO
BE TESTED AND CERTIFIED UNDER
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE STILL HAVE
SIGNIFICANT AMBIGUITY AND
CONCERNS WITH AB 347. WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK AND THE
DIALOG THAT WE'VE HAD THUS FAR,
BUT FOR THE REASONS TODAY AND
THE REASONS STATED, WE MUST
STILL REGRETTABLY ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE AS WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED ON THE BILL. SO LET ME
ASK A QUESTION. OBVIOUSLY,
TESTING CAPACITY IN THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO DO THE JOB AND
FUNDING FOR THE STATE TO DO
WHATEVER THE JOB IS. THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT ARE BEYOND YOU, AND
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT ARE IN THE
SANDBOX HERE AND THE SANDBOX
UPSTAIRS. OTHER THAN THOSE, HAVE
YOU SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO DEAL
WITH THE T SHIRT ISSUE, THE
REGISTRATION AND TESTING, THE
NOTICE OF VIOLATION, THE
ENFORCEMENT AND DISCLOSURE?
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT US. THAT'S
YOU. YEAH. SO DO YOU HAVE
LANGUAGE THAT SOMEBODY HAS THAT
I HAVEN'T SEEN? YES, SIR. SO
WHEN WE FIRST SAW THE LANGUAGE
IN JUNE OF WHAT WAS INTRODUCED
BY THE AUTHOR, THAT WAS REALLY
OUR FIRST OPPORTUNITY AS A
COALITION TO LOOK AT KIND OF THE
WORK PRODUCT. AND SO WE HAVE
PROVIDED AMENDMENTS TO THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND OTHERS TO
KIND OF PROVIDE, I WOULD CALL IT
THE MEAT OR THE SUBSTANCE TO
THAT REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE VERY CLOSE
IN SOME CAPACITY TO ADDRESSING
THOSE CONSIDERATIONS. AND
CONCERNS. AND WHAT WE ARE ASKING
AS AN INDUSTRY IS TO LET US
UNDERSTAND THE RULES, LET US
UNDER UNDERSTAND THE ENVIRONMENT
OF WHAT DTSC IS REQUIRED TO DO.
SO WE PROVIDED KEEPING WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ELEMENTS OF WHAT 347 PROVIDED
THE INDUSTRY ASKS OF. HERE'S THE
RULES OF THE GAME. HERE'S
TESTING CAPACITY. HERE'S HOW
CALIFORNIA SHOULD GO THROUGH AND
ESSENTIALLY ACCREDIT
LABORATORIES BEYOND JUST DTSC
BECAUSE CAPACITY IS A CHALLENGE.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT DTSC HAS
THE CAPACITY TO TEST EVERYTHING,
BUT WHATEVER TESTING METHODS OR
METHODOLOGIES ARE GOING TO BE
USED SHOULD BE COMPARABLE OR
IDENTICAL ACROSS EVERY OTHER
PRIVATE OR ACCREDITED LAB.
THAT'S GOING TO BE DOING A TEST
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DTSC FOR THESE
PRODUCTS. WELL, THE PHRASE I
THINK WE'RE GETTING CLOSE,
THAT'S MAGIC TO MY EARS AND TO
THE EARS OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
SIT IN THESE POSITIONS. SO I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO KEEP
WORKING ON THAT AND HOPEFULLY
COME TO A CONCLUSION THAT'S
THAT'S A SUCCESSFUL ONE, BOTH
FOR THE BUT
I WILL SAY THAT WHEN YOU MOVE
INTO TRYING TO SUGGEST LANGUAGE
ABOUT TESTING CAPACITY,
REMEMBER, THAT'S OUR SANDBOX.
AND IF IT DOESN'T EXIST, I GUESS
THIS WON'T WORK. BUT WHAT I
WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD CONCENTRATE
ON ARE THE ISSUES THAT ARE IN
YOUR SANDBOX. AS MANUFACTURERS
HAVING TO DO WITH THE REPORTS
AND THE NOTICES OF VIOLATION AND
ENFORCEMENT AND DISCLOSURE,
BECAUSE THOSE IMPACTS YOU AND
HOW YOU DEAL WITH VARIOUS
PRODUCTS THAT ARE IN VARIOUS
RETAILERS AND HOW THOSE ARE
HANDLED, I GUESS THAT'S YOUR T
SHIRT EXAMPLE. SO HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL I'M GOING TO GIVE MR.
TING A OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND,
BUT HOPEFULLY YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HIM AND SEE IF YOU CAN
COME TO SOME, SOME, SOME
RESOLUTION. AND MEM, I HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU. YOU'RE
NEXT. JUST A QUICK RESPONSE. I
MEAN, WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY ON THE
AMENDMENTS, EC HAD ASKED US NOT
TO DO AMENDMENTS UNTIL AFTER WE
GET THE BILL TO THE FLOOR, AND
SO THAT'S OUR INTENTION TO
INCORPORATE. WE'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED MANY OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE
INCORPORATING, ON THE FLOOR SO
THAT THAT WAS THE COMMITTEE'S
REQUEST. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HONOR THAT.
RIGHT. AND OF COURSE, THE OTHER
THING, WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THERE
ARE MULTIPLE REFERRALS OF BILLS,
WELL, IT'S SOMETIMES DIFFICULT
FOR ME. WE TRY TO STAY ON OUR
OWN JURISDICTIONAL SANDBOX
OURSELVES. SO THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK ON IT. WE'LL
SEE IF WE CAN COME TOGETHER.
YES, MA'AM. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
MANDY ISAACS LEE, HERE, ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL, I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. AND THE COMMITTEE AND
EVEN THE AUTHOR FOR COUNTLESS
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS. AS WE'RE
TRYING TO LAND THIS PLANE. BUT
REGRETTABLY, WE'RE STILL IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 347. OUR ISSUE
IS WHAT WHAT STARTED OFF AS A
SIMPLE ENFORCEMENT BILL HAS
TURNED INTO SOMETHING THAT IS
INTRODUCED VERY SIGNIFICANT
POLICY ISSUES IN THE SECOND
HOUSE, IN THE FINAL DAYS BEFORE
THE POLICY COMMITTEE DEADLINES
AND MY CLIENT PCPC WAS NOT A
PARTY TO THE YEAR LONG
CONVERSATIONS. THE AUTHOR HAS
HAD WITH DTSC AND VARIOUS
PARTIES. IN FACT, WE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT COSMETICS WAS
IMPLICATED UNTIL THIS BILL WENT
INTO PRINT A FEW WEEKS AGO. SO
WORKING WITHIN THE FRAMEWORK OF
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT, WHICH IS TO
MAKE THIS AN ENFORCEMENT BILL
FOR EXISTING AND FUTURE PFAS
BANS, WE REALLY PUSHED OUR
MEMBERS TO FIND A CAPABLE
REGULATOR, AND WE BELIEVE WE
FOUND THAT IN THE CDPH, THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
UNDER THE SHERMAN FOOD DRUG AND
COSMETICS ACT. AND WE'RE
THANKFUL TO THE COMMITTEE FOR,
YOU KNOW, SUGGESTING THAT
AMENDMENT, THE SHERMAN ACT FOR
WHAT IT'S WORTH, JUST TO BE ON
RECORD HAS VARIOUS PROVISIONS
THAT HOLD COSMETIC MANUFACTURERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ADULTERER
COSMETICS MANUFACTURERS ARE
SUBJECT TO FINES AND PENALTIES,
EVEN IMPRISONMENT PRODUCT
RECALLS FOR VIOLATIONS OF THE
ACT. SO IT'S NOT INSIGNIFICANT.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO GO BACK A
LITTLE BIT IN HISTORY, IN 2022,
WHEN WE FIRST NEGOTIATED THE
INTENTIONAL PFAS BAN FOR
COSMETICS, THE COSMETICS
INDUSTRY AGREED TO NOT
INTENTIONALLY ADD PFAS IN OUR
PRODUCTS. AND WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THAT. BUT THE
SUBTEXT OF THAT AGREEMENT WAS
THAT MANUFACTURERS WOULD NOT BE
HELD LIABLE FOR TRACE
CONTAMINANTS OF PFAS FOUND IN
THE ENVIRONMENT, FOUND IN THE
WATER. I KNOW, MR. CHAIR, WE HAD
A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THAT THROUGH THE MANUFACTURING
AND LOGISTICS PROCESS. THERE'S
POTENTIAL FOR CONTAMINATION AS
WELL. AND THIS LAW BECOMES
EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY 1ST, 2025.
AND YET HERE WE ARE AGAIN, SORT
OF SUBJECT TO A LAST MINUTE,
VERY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
DISCUSSION, THAT FRANKLY, WE
TALKED ABOUT IN 2022 AND DECIDED
TO NOT GO WITH THE THRESHOLD,
AND IT SORT OF REOPENS UP A VERY
CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED DEAL BACK
IN 2022. SO WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THREE, FOUR, SEVEN, AND,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THE, THE, THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
AUTHORIZES CDFW TO SET A
THRESHOLD FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS. NUMBER ONE IS, AS IT
PREVIOUSLY STATED, WE'RE
INTRODUCING SIGNIFICANT POLICY
BY MANDATING THE CDPH TO SET A
THRESHOLD THAT THAT, FRANKLY,
DESERVES MORE DAYLIGHT, THAN THE
FINAL DAYS BEFORE THE SECOND
HOUSE POLICY COMMITTEE DEADLINE.
THIS IS AN ENFORCEMENT BILL. WE
FOUND A VERY CAPABLE ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM THROUGH THE CDFW
SHERMAN ACT, AND I THINK WE
ACHIEVE THAT INTENT. NUMBER TWO
IS NONE OF THE OTHER PRODUCT
CATEGORIES ARE BEING
RELITIGATED, YOU KNOW, THEY ARE
SIMPLY BEING PLACED IN THREE,
FOUR, SEVEN ENFORCEMENT ARM,
UNDER THE ENFORCEMENT REGIME
THAT THREE, FOUR, SEVEN CREATES.
BUT WITH THE THRESHOLD, WE'RE
REINTRODUCING AN ISSUE THAT WAS
HIGHLY DEBATED IN 2022. AND WE
DECIDED IN 2022 NOT TO GO WITH
THE THRESHOLD UNDER THE
RECOGNITION THAT IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX POLICY
DISCUSSION. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, THERE WASN'T A
THRESHOLD IN AB 2771. AND NOW,
ARGUABLY, YOU KNOW, SOME OF THE
SUPPORTERS THAT SIT HERE THAT
WERE A PARTY TO THE DISCUSSIONS
IN 2022 ARE GETTING A SECOND
BITE AT THE APPLE NUMBER THREE,
COSMETIC MANUFACTURERS ARE ARE
COMMITTED TO NOT INTENTIONALLY
ADDING PFAS. AS STATED EARLIER,
BUT WE CANNOT BE HELD LIABLE FOR
TRACE CONTAMINANTS THAT EXIST
UBIQUITOUSLY IN THE ENVIRONMENT
THAT ARE BEYOND OUR CONTROL. AND
THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS IDEA OF
CDFW SETTING A THRESHOLD WOULD
DO JUST THAT AND CREATE SEVERE
AND UNTENABLE LIABILITY. AND THE
LAST THING THAT I'LL CLOSE WITH
IS, YOU KNOW, UNDER THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENT,
IF MANUFACTURERS WERE TO ADD
PFAS INTO COSMETICS, IT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED AN ADULTERATED
COSMETIC, YOU KNOW, WE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT PUTTING IT
DIRECTLY UNDER THE ADULTERATED
COSMETIC PROVISION. THE QUESTION
BECOMES, ONCE CDPH SETS A
THRESHOLD, WHATEVER THAT
THRESHOLD IS, AND LET'S SAY THE
THRESHOLD, THE PRODUCT IS TESTED
AND THE THRESHOLD IS HIGHER THAN
WHATEVER CDPH SETS. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN? IS IT IS THERE A
ANOTHER PROVISION THAT THAT
WOULD ENFORCE THAT? IS IT SUPER
ADULTERATED? HOW IS THAT GOING
TO BE ENFORCED? THERE'S NO
CLARITY IN THAT. AND WE FIND
PODS IN THAT, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
RIGHT NOW THAT BUT THE AUTHOR
HAS COMMITTED IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THE
COSMETICS ISSUE, BUT WE STILL
FIND OURSELVES AT AN IMPASSE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, WE'D ASK
FOR A NO VOTE TODAY. WELL, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. I IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT MY INTENTION. TO
PICK UP TRACE ELEMENTS OF PFAS
THAT ARE THAT ARE FOUND IN A
COSMETIC BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURER PLUGS INTO A WATER
SYSTEM OR THE MANUFACTURER HAS
AN INGREDIENT THAT HAS TRACE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE THERE BECAUSE
IT'S AN ORGANIC INGREDIENT THAT
PICKS PFAS UP FROM THE SOIL OR
THE WATER, AND THEN PERCHANCE
FINDS ITSELF INTO A COSMETIC
PRODUCT AND IN FACT, THE
LANGUAGE TALKS ABOUT
ADULTERATED, WHICH IS TRUE. AND
IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT IT'S
ADULTERATED IF IT CONTAINS AN
INTENTIONALLY ADDED PFAS, AND IT
DEFINES INTENTIONALLY ADDED AS
CHEMICALS THAT A MANUFACTURER
HAS INTENTIONALLY ADDED TO A
PRODUCT OR THAT ARE INTENTIONAL
BREAKDOWN PRODUCTS OF AN ADDED
CHEMICAL AND TALK ABOUT TRACE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE FOUND BECAUSE
YOU PLUGGED INTO SOME
COMMUNITY'S WATER SUPPLY THAT
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THE OTHER DAY
THAT THE THRESHOLD ACCEPTABLE
THRESHOLD FOR PFAS IS 0.02 PARTS
PER MILLION, WHICH IS PRETTY
LOW. SO WE SHOULDN'T FIND A LOT
IN THE WATER SUPPLY UNLESS WE'VE
GOT A LARGER PROBLEM. SO THAT'S
MY INTENT. I UNDERSTAND THE
DISAGREEMENT AS TO WHO REGULATES
IT AND THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
WORKED OUT, WITH THE AUTHOR, AND
MAYBE WE CAN HELP. I'M NOT GOING
AWAY YET. NOT DEAD YET. UNTIL A
LITTLE LATER IN THE FALL. AND
CERTAINLY WE'LL BE HERE IN
AUGUST WHEN WE REVISIT A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES. SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS, HE'S TIED UP OVER
AT THE RAIL RIGHT NOW, BUT I'M
GOING TO ASK THE AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG, TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU,
PARTICULARLY THE COSMETICS FOLKS
TO. YOU MAY HAVE I KNOW YOU CAN
MULTITASK ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. SO
I'M SURE YOU HEARD THIS, BUT I
WAS COMMENTING ON THE LANGUAGE,
AND IT'S CERTAINLY MY INTENT
THAT ADULTERATED AND INTENTIONAL
MEAN EXACTLY WHAT THEY SOUND
LIKE, WHICH IS YOU STICK
SOMETHING IN THAT THAT TO A
PRODUCT THAT DOESN'T ALREADY
ALREADY HAVE IT, AND YOU
INTENTIONALLY DO. SO, AND THAT'S
WHAT WE INTEND WITH RESPECT TO
THE AMENDMENT. I KNOW YOU'LL
WORK WITH THE COSMETICS INDUSTRY
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THEIR THEIR
CONCERNS, COLLECTIVE CONCERNS
OVER THE OVER THE BREAK AND COME
BACK AND WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN'T,
TIE THE RIBBON ON THIS WHEN WE
GET BACK. YES, MA'AM. THROUGH
THE CHAIR. IF I COULD JUST
RESPOND VERY QUICKLY TO THAT. WE
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR CLARIFYING,
HIS INTENT. AND, I THINK THAT
THE ISSUE IS THAT WE USE
INGREDIENTS BEYOND JUST WATER.
AND I KNOW WE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WATER, BUT
THERE ARE NATURAL BOTANICALS
THAT WE USE FOR AS DIFFERENT
INGREDIENTS THAT ALSO COULD BE
CONTAMINATED. BECAUSE PFAS IS
EVERYWHERE IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND SO THE CONSIDERATION IS THAT
WE HAVE VARIOUS POINTS AT WHICH
THE PRODUCT CAN GET CONTAMINATED.
WE ARE NOT INTENTIONALLY ADDING
THE PFAS, BUT THE MANUFACTURING
PROCESS, PACKAGING, LOGISTICS,
OTHER INGREDIENTS ASIDE FROM
WATER THAT COULD PRESENT
CONTAMINANTS INTO THE PRODUCT
THAT WE DON'T WANT TO BE HELD
LIABLE. AND WE MAY NEED TO
CLARIFY THAT. BUT IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, PFAS IS EVERYWHERE,
INCLUDING IN OUR BODIES. SO IF
THAT'S THE MEASURING STICK, THEN
THE WORD INTENTIONAL HAS NO
MEANING. BECAUSE ANYTHING YOU
ADD INTO YOUR COSMETIC PRODUCT
COULD HAVE PFAS IN IT. SO WE
NEED TO FIX WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THAT. YOU'VE GOT SOME
FOLKS TO YOUR RIGHT, MY LEFT TO
MAY HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THEY KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT, AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
DOES. SO WE'LL GO TO WORK ON
THIS, MA'AM. AND ALSO YOU'RE
GOING TO HELP WITH YOUR LANGUAGE
THAT IS IN YOUR SANDBOX AND NOT
OURS. AND WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN'T
GET A PRODUCT THAT EVERYBODY,
INCLUDING THE AUTHOR, CAN BE
PROUD OF. YEAH, WE ABSOLUTELY
PLAN ON SPENDING THE RECESS
WORKING THIS OUT. I FEEL PRETTY
CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO FIND A RESOLUTION PERFECT ANY
OTHER. I SEE THEM LINING UP ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. PLEASE GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ADAM WRIGLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING, NICOLE QUINONES,
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. LAUREN
VALENCIA, REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL SLEEP PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION. ALSO OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED. THANKS FAITH
FORGES ON BEHALF OF THE COOKWARE
SUSTAINABILITY ALLIANCE. WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL WORK ON THIS
BILL, AND EXPECT TO BE MOVING TO
NEUTRAL UPON SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS IN PRINT. THANK YOU.
KEVIN MESNER I'M WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF HOME APPLIANCE
MANUFACTURERS, AND WE OPPOSE,
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. TIM CIZEK
WITH THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. WELL, I
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS, BUT
THERE'S ONLY ME, SO ASSUME IT'S
YOUR LUCKY DAY. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE, YOU KNOW, ONE JUST
AGAIN? THANK THANKS FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT. YOUR COMMITTEE'S
ENGAGEMENT. YOU KNOW, WE WILL
SPEND THE NEXT FEW WEEKS, HAVING
FURTHER CONVERSATION, HOPING TO
LAND SOME RESOLUTION BEFORE WE
GET THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU. APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TIME WE SPENT ON THIS. BUT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM, DOCTOR,
WOULD ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 815
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE PROVIDER
CREDENTIALS. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. PROCEED WITH READY.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND I'D
SAY MEMBERS BUT I CAN'T SO ME
MYSELF AND I. YES SORRY ABOUT
THAT. I SO, FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS BILL. PHYSICIAN
CREDENTIALING PRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES, MUCH LIKE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS AND PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES, AS HEALTH CARE
PHYSICIANS OFTEN FACE VARYING
CRITERIA FROM DIFFERENT HEALTH
PLANS. AB 815 ADDRESSES THESE
CHALLENGES BY STREAMLINING THE
CREDENTIALING PROCESS FOR
PHYSICIANS AND HEALTH PLANS. AB
815 ESTABLISHES A CREDENTIALING
BOARD RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING
A STANDARD FORM TO BE USED BY
ALL PRIVATE HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS. THIS FORM SETS FORWARD
STANDARDS TO REDUCE REDUNDANCY
AND DELAYS IN THE CREDENTIALING
PROCESS, RATHER THAN WASTE TIME
AND OVERLY BURDENSOME
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESSES. AB 815
ALLOWS HEALTH PLANS TO FOCUS ON
ENSURING ENROLLEES HAVE ACCESS
TO AN ADEQUATE NETWORK OF
PHYSICIANS, AND ENABLES DOCTORS
TO CONCENTRATE ON DELIVERING
MEDICAL CARE. ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS HERE. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS BRANDON
MARSH, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WELCOME, SIR. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
MISTER CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE,
MY NAME IS BRANDON MARTIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE SPEAKER PRO TEM FOR
SPEARHEADING THIS EFFORT, AND
ALSO THANK YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS AND THEIR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION, THE STAFF I'M
SORRY I SAID I HAVE THE BEST
STAFF. YES, YOU DO, SIR, THE US
HEALTH CARE, US HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY, ADMINISTRATIVE
SPENDING HAS REACHED $1 TRILLION
IN 2023. THEREFORE, IT'S TIME TO
BRING OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES
INTO THE HEALTH CARE ARENA. AND
STARTING WITH THIS CREDENTIALING
PROCESS, AB 815815 BRINGS
TOGETHER INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS
TO CREATE AND MAINTAIN A
STANDARDIZED CREDENTIALING FORM
FOR ALL HEALTH PLANS AND
PHYSICIANS TO USE IN THEIR OWN
INTERNAL PROCESSES. THIS
STANDARDIZED FORM WILL HELP TO
AUTOMATE THE PROCESS BY ALLOWING
FOR AUTO POPULATION OF CONFIRMED
PHYSICIAN INFORMATION. FOR MORE
COMPLETE INITIAL APPLICATIONS,
AND MORE AND MORE TIMELY
CONSIDERATION OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS. AB 815 IS MODELED
AFTER AB 2581 FROM 2022, AND
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS
TO CONSIDER A PROVIDER'S
CREDENTIALING APPLICATION WITHIN
90 DAYS OF RECEIPT. THE
CREDENTIALING PROCESS IS
CONDUCTED CURRENTLY BY EACH
HEALTH PLAN AND INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALLY. EACH WITH ITS OWN
SET OF CRITERIA AND EXTENSIVE
APPLICATION PROCESS. AFTER THE
APPLICATION HAS BEEN SUBMITTED,
THERE IS TYPICALLY A LONG
WAITING PERIOD FOR HEALTH PLANS
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE PHYSICIAN
CREDENTIALING APPLICATION
CAUSING DELAYS IN GETTING
PHYSICIANS CONTRACTED AND INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES PROVIDING
CARE. WE HAVE RECENTLY RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS OF CREDENTIALING,
DELAYS OF UPWARDS OF SEVEN
MONTHS AFTER A PHYSICIAN HAS
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION. AB 815
CREATES AN IMPORTANT SETTING FOR
THE INDUSTRY TO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND SOLUTIONS WHICH REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE SPENDING AND
BURDEN AND GET PHYSICIANS INTO
PLAN NETWORKS FASTER TO DELIVER
CARE TO THEIR COMMUNITIES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE?
PLEASE RYAN SPENCER WITH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OB-GYN
DISTRICT NINE AND THE CALIFORNIA
PODIATRIC MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, CHRISTY
WEISS ON BEHALF OF THE PHYSICIAN
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, A
GROUP OF SMALL AND INDEPENDENT
PHYSICIANS WHO REALLY STRUGGLE
WITH THE LENGTH AND DELAY THAT
THE CREDENTIALING PROCESS TAKES.
AND WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE,
MR. CHAIR MEMBERS PAUL YODER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS A BIT OF A
TWEENER KATHY MOSSBERG WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH PLANS WITH THE
LATEST AMENDMENTS. WE ARE
NEUTRAL. WE'RE MOVING OUR
POSITION. THANK YOU. WE LIKE
THAT. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI, I WAS GOING TO BE VERY QUICK
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER, WE LIKE THAT TO. GOOD
MORNING. CHAIR. ROBERT BOYKIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS. THANK YOU TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF, AS WELL AS
TO THE SPONSOR AND TO THE AUTHOR
OF THE BILL, YOU KNOW, WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS CONVERSATION
MOVING FORWARD. SOME VERY NICE
STEPS, THE AMENDMENTS HAVE DONE
A LONG WAY. HAVE GONE A LONG WAY
TO ADDRESSING SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. YES MA'AM.
MR. CHAIR MEMBERS STEPHANIE
WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES,
WE TO HAVE AN OPPOSING LAST
AMENDED. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR, THE SPONSOR AND ALL
THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ON
THIS. WE DO HAVE SOME
OUTSTANDING ISSUES AND WOULD
LIKE TO DISCUSS THOSE OVER THE
JULY BREAK AND GOING FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIX THOSE. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, DOCTOR WOULD THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, AS I SAT HERE
LAST WEEK WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES, I STARTED
THINKING THAT, YOU KNOW, AS WITH
THIS, WITH THIS BILL, MAYBE THIS
COULD BE THE FRAMEWORK FOR HOW
WE ULTIMATELY CAN DEAL WITH
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES AS WELL. I
HOPE THAT'S TRUE. I HOPE THAT'S
TRUE. BUT WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM, AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
TAKE A MOTION. WE'LL DO EXACTLY
THAT. THANKS FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 1577. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW. GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN. BILL, THAT'S COMING UP
LATER. YOU GET A CHANCE TO READ
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1577,
WHICH, OF COURSE, YOU AND I HAVE
RESPECTIVELY, HAD A BREADTH OF
WORK ON THIS ISSUE WITH RESPECT
TO CLINICAL PLACEMENTS, THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR WORK AND YOUR
STAFF'S WORK FOR HELPING TO
ENSURE THAT ASSEMBLY BILL 1577
BEFORE YOU PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY
INTO WHY CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS ARE NOT BEING READILY MADE
AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND CSUS, AS YOU KNOW, WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO MEET A CRITICAL
NEED, AND THIS IS A CRITICAL
STEP IN ADDRESSING THE MASSIVE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE CRISIS AT
HAND WITH ME TODAY. SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL 1577 IS
LIZ HAWKINS FROM THE UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
THANK YOU, DO I NEED TO PRESS
ANYTHING OR. MIKE, I THINK
YOU'RE ON, I HEAR IT. OKAY. JUST
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH HAWKINS. I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE, AND I'M ALSO
AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
UNION OF HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. AND I'M A PROUD
SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLYMAN LEO'S
BILL AB 1577. FOR YEARS, HEALTH
CARE LEADERS HAVE WARNED OF AN
IMPENDING NURSING SHORTAGE. THE
RECENT PANDEMIC STARKLY
ILLUMINATED THE CRISIS,
EXACERBATED BY SHORT STAFFING,
POOR WORKING CONDITIONS,
WIDESPREAD BURNOUT AND
PROLIFERATION OF THE LUCRATIVE
NURSE TRAVEL INDUSTRY, ACCORDING
TO THE US BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS. AN ALARMING 193,100
REGISTERED NURSE JOB OPENINGS
ARE PROJECTED ANNUALLY THROUGH
2030, FUELED BY RETIREMENTS AND
DEPARTURES FROM THE PROFESSION
DURING THE PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA,
LIKE MANY OTHER REGIONS, BORE
THE BRUNT OF THIS SHORTAGE, WITH
HOSPITALS GRAPPLING AND PAYING
EXORBITANT FEES TO NURSE
REGISTRIES TO FILL CRITICAL
POSITIONS. TODAY, DESPITE
OFFERING SUBSTANTIAL RECRUITING
INCENTIVES, CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
STILL FACE THOUSANDS OF
VACANCIES. THIS SHORTFALL MAY
ESCALATE FURTHER AS HEALTH CARE
ACCESS EXPANDS TO MORE
INDIVIDUALS. THE ONGOING DIALOG
ABOUT THE NURSING SHORTAGE
DEMANDS URGENT ACTION FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S
IMPERATIVE TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO SAFEGUARD
THE NURSING WORKFORCE BY 2030.
DELAYING INTERVENTION IS NOT AN
OPTION. WE MUST ACT DECISIVELY
NOW TO PREVENT FURTHER STRAIN ON
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. ENSURE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR ALL. AB 1577
IS PART OF THE SOLUTION. ONE OF
THE MAIN HURDLES FACING NURSING
IS THE LACK OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT AVAILABLE TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CSU STUDENTS. THE
LACK OF PLACEMENT HAS LED TO
LONGER WAITING PERIODS,
ESPECIALLY AT THE JCCS WHERE
EDUCATION IS MORE AFFORDABLE.
THIS FORCES SOME STUDENTS TO
ENROLL AT EXPENSIVE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS, ACCEPTING A MORE COSTLY
EDUCATION. AB 1577 ENCOURAGES
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES TO EXPAND THEIR
PLACEMENTS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
DOING IT WITHOUT SUPPLANTING AND
ANY CURRENT OR FUTURE PLACEMENT
AGREEMENTS AND OPERATION. AB
1577 ALSO CREATES ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES TO SUBMIT
A DECLARATION OR LACK OF
CAPACITY TO FULFILL THE
REQUIREMENT. A VERY EASY TASK, A
DROP IN THE BUCKET FINE FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY. IT'S TIME TO
PRIORITIZE THE NURSING
INFRASTRUCTURE. CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY INVESTED $300 MILLION
OVER A FIVE YEAR PERIOD TO
EXPAND NURSING PROGRAMS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. NOW WE NEED
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS TO BE ABLE
TO GRADUATE THESE NEW NURSING
STUDENTS. AB 1577 IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT TO THE
SOLUTION TO SAVE NURSING. THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE? ONLY PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING. JANICE O'MALLEY
WITH ME. CALIFORNIA HERE IN IN
CO-SPONSORSHIP OF THE MEASURE
AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK
ON THIS AND YOUR WORK AS WELL IN
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FIRST LEAD
OPPOSITION. LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES MAY JOIN US AT THE
TABLE. WE'LL TAKE THE OTHERS
NEXT. WELCOME. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND
PROCEED WHEN READY, THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. SARAH BRIDGE, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
HERE, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB
1577, HD REPRESENTS THE STATE'S
77 PUBLIC HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
THAT SERVE THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE AND UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. DISTRICT HOSPITALS
ARE AT THE CENTER OF THE
DISCUSSION ON HOW TO GROW OUR
CLINICAL WORKFORCE, AND WE AGREE
WITH THE PREMISE THAT THE STAT
THAT THE STATE LACKS THE
NECESSARY CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS TO MEET THE OVERALL NEED.
HOWEVER, AB 1577 ARBITRARILY
PRIORITIZES SPECIFIED
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
PENALIZES HOSPITALS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS. CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS ARE COSTLY. THEY ALSO
REQUIRE THAT STAFF QUALIFIED TO
TEACH, BE PULLED OUT OF
ROTATION, AND OR USED MORE
INFREQUENTLY. OFTEN, OUR
DISTRICT HOSPITALS LACK THE
FUNDS AND OR STAFF TO OFFER
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS AT ALL.
WITH THESE LIMITED RESOURCES,
DISTRICTS WILL PARTNER WITH THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
CAN TRAIN THE WORKFORCE NEEDED
AT THAT PARTICULAR FACILITY,
OFTEN OFFERING CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS FOR ONLY THAT
TYPE OF CLINICIAN. USING THE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO STRATEGY OF
GROWING YOUR OWN WORKFORCE TO
MEET THE UNIQUE COMMUNITY NEEDS.
THIS OFTEN MEANS PARTNERING WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. HOWEVER,
IT CAN ALSO MEAN PARTNERING WITH
A VARIETY OF OTHER INSTITUTIONS,
MAKING ANY PRIORITIZATION
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
PROBLEMATIC. WE AGREE THAT WE
NEED MORE DATA AND BELIEVE THAT
THE COMMITTEE IS ALREADY
ADDRESSED. THIS ISSUE IN THE
CHAIR'S BILL, SENATE BILL 1042.
WITHOUT THE PROBLEMATIC
PRIORITIZATION REQUIREMENTS,
FINES AND COSTLY DATABASE, ACHD
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WERE
PLEASED TO WORK THROUGH SIMILAR
CONCERNS ON THE BILL AND ARE NOW
NEUTRAL ON THAT MEASURE. WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS THE FIRST AND
MOST APPROPRIATE STEP TO
ADDRESSING CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SHORTAGES. I WILL REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT OVER HALF OF THE
HOSPITALS THAT RECEIVE
DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOANS WERE
PUBLIC DISTRICT HOSPITALS. WE
ARE NOW BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
HIGHLIGHTING YET ANOTHER BILL
THAT WILL PUT FURTHER STRAIN ON
THESE ALREADY STRUGGLING
FACILITIES. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE, AUTHOR AND SPONSORS
FOR THEIR CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE. HOWEVER, FOR
THESE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU MA'AM. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. ALEX GRAVES,
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 1570 7IC REPRESENTS 89
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE,
INCLUDING ROUGHLY TWO DOZEN THAT
OFFER NURSING PROGRAMS IN
ACADEMIC YEAR 20 2122. OUR
INSTITUTIONS PRODUCED
APPROXIMATELY 46% OF THE NEW BSN
PREPARED NURSES IN THE STATE.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS, I THINK,
DOES AN EXCELLENT JOB OF
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
ISSUES THAT NURSING EDUCATION
PROGRAMS SEE, WHETHER IT'S
CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUES, NOT
ENOUGH NURSING FACULTY TO DO THE
SUPERVISION OF NURSING STUDENTS,
AS WELL AS THE LACK OF GOOD DATA
ON PLACEMENT NEEDS AND PLACEMENT
AVAILABILITY. WE TOO REMAIN
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT CONTINUES TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE
THAT PRIORITIZES RESOLUTION OF
PLACEMENT NEEDS BASED ON THE
SEGMENT OF HIGHER EDUCATION THAT
A NURSING PROGRAM RESIDES IN.
WE'VE CONSISTENTLY OPPOSED SUCH
APPROACHES BECAUSE, AGAIN,
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS ARE
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE TO ALL
NURSING PROGRAMS. AND WE WOULD
WELCOME SOLUTIONS THAT HELP
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
PLACEMENTS FOR ALL PROGRAMS, I
WOULD NOTE THAT WE TWO ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF EFFORTS TO TACKLE
THE CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUE.
AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED,
WE TOO HAVE BEEN VERY ENGAGED ON
SB 1042 AND ARE NEUTRAL ON ON
THAT LANGUAGE IN PRINT. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT PROVIDES
APPROPRIATE DATA TO TACKLE THIS
ISSUE WITHOUT AGAIN, CREATING
THAT PRIORITIZATION BASED ON THE
SEGMENT IN WHICH A PROGRAM
RESIDES. SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
WE MUST BE HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TODAY. BUT APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU, ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? IF ANY
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY PLEASE. SO I
MISSED THE SUPPORT. SO I'M
ACTUALLY A CLINICAL INSTRUCTOR
AND I'M THE SEIU 1 TO 1 RN VICE
PRESIDENT. AND I WILDLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU. OKAY. NOW LET'S TURN
TO OPPOSITION A LITTLE BIT OF A
TWEENER HERE. KRISTY WEISS, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WITH THE
POSITION OF CONCERNS, REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF'S WILLINGNESS TO KEEP
TALKING WITH US HOSPITALS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE PROVIDE
THOUSANDS OF PLACEMENTS FOR
NURSING STUDENTS. AND I THINK AS
EVERYONE IS AWARE OF, THERE ARE
MULTIPLE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE
PLACEMENT PROCESS. OUR CONCERN
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
COORDINATION AMONGST ALL OF
THOSE, AS WELL AS ACKNOWLEDGING
THE WORK THAT HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WITH THE NURSING
CONSORTIUMS. SO AS WE ENTER THE
FINAL 60 DAYS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS.
CHEN CHASE. ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF CONCERN
SIMILAR TO THE CONCERNS THAT AQ
OUTLINED AROUND THE
PRIORITIZATION OF CERTAIN
SEGMENTS OVER THE OTHERS, AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO BE
CREATING TWO DIFFERENT PROCESSES
AND WE'RE DOING A LOT OF WORK
CURRENTLY TO ALREADY TO HAVE AS
MANY CLINICAL SLOTS AS WE CAN AT
OUR HOSPITALS AND CLINICS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OF THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? WELL, I
DON'T KNOW IF MY COLLEAGUE WANTS
TO COMMENT ON THIS CLINICAL
PLACEMENT BILL. I'LL LET HER
RAISE HER HAND IF SHE DOES, BUT
I'LL COMMENT FIRST. SOME OF THEM
ARE LOW. I JUST WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR BEING A LEADER IN THIS
EFFORT AND MANY OTHERS IN THE
HEALTH CARE FIELD. I'VE FOR
MOST, IF NOT ALL OF MY TIME UP
HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. AND YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS EFFORT IN PARTICULAR, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE FOLKS
REFERENCED, OTHER BILLS, BUT,
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
APPROACHES TO SOLVING AN ISSUE.
AND I THINK ALL OF THEM HAVE
VALUE, AND ALL OF THEM SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED GENERALLY. AND
SPECIFICALLY. THAT APPLIES, I
THINK, TO THIS EFFORT AS WELL. I
SAID THIS YESTERDAY IN ANOTHER
HEARING, AND I DON'T, IT
DISAPPOINTS ME WHEN WE HAVE
COMPETITION INSIDE THE HEALTH
CARE ARENA, COMPETITION THAT
REALLY DOESN'T BELONG IN THE
HEALTH CARE ARENA. HEALTH CARE
IS A TEAM EFFORT, AND THAT
INCLUDES HEALTH CARE, WORKFORCE
EDUCATION. THERE'S NO I IN TEAM.
AND WHEN WE START COMPETING AND
WE START WORRYING ABOUT ONE
SECTOR OR THE OTHER WITHOUT
WORRYING ABOUT HOW THE TEAM
SUCCEEDS AND HOW MANY, HOW MANY
GOALS WE CAN PUT ON THE
SCOREBOARD AS A TEAM, THEN WE
REALLY AREN'T FUNCTIONING
EFFECTIVELY, AND THE EFFORT IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS IT COULD BE,
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT WE HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
CAPACITY IN OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE EFFORT, AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT SOLVING THIS
CLINICAL PLACEMENT ISSUE IS
CRITICAL TO DEALING WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE. HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE. AND SO WHILE
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
APPROACHES, WE'LL SORT THAT OUT,
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE GET A
HANDLE ON THIS CLINICAL
PLACEMENT ISSUE, THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT WE IDENTIFY EVERY
SINGLE POTENTIAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENT IN THE HEALTH CARE
SANDBOX, AND WE FULLY UTILIZE
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF THOSE
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS TO
EDUCATE, IN THIS CASE, THE
NURSING WORKFORCE THAT WE BADLY
NEED. SO THOSE ARE MY COMMENTS
ON THE ISSUE. I DON'T KNOW, I'LL
LET SENATOR NGUYEN AND SHE JUST
ARRIVED TO ASK A QUESTION IF SHE
CARES TO DO SO OR MAKE A
COMMENT. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. I ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTION. MORE OF A COMMENT.
I MOST OF WHAT THE CHAIRMAN
STATED. I'M IN AGREEMENT. THIS
IS AND YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN DOING FOR MANY
YEARS NOW, TRYING TO GET US TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE, I JUST
DON'T THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION BECAUSE NOW WE'RE
PITTING A GROUP OF STUDENTS
AGAINST ANOTHER GROUP OF
STUDENTS GETTING THESE SLOTS. I
JUST THINK IN THE END, WE NEED
TO CREATE MORE SLOTS. THESE
CLINICAL, YOU KNOW, FACILITIES
NEED WE NEED MORE CLINICAL
FACILITIES FOR MORE SLOTS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN TEN STUDENTS FROM THE
PRIVATE SCHOOL TO TEN STUDENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC SCHOOL. WE
ACTUALLY WANT ALL 20 STUDENTS.
WE DON'T WANT TEN ONLY FROM
EITHER SCHOOLS, AND SO I THINK,
YOU KNOW, THIS I DON'T THINK IS
THE SOLUTION, Y I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING. I JUST THINK
WE HERE AS A LEGISLATOR, WE GOT
TO COME UP WITH A SOLUTION. AND
IT MIGHT HAVE TO BE WHERE, WE
HAVE TO PAY FOR THESE CLINICS.
CLINICAL. FACILITIES TO OPEN,
FROM THE STATE SIDE, WE HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE MORE OF THESE
HOSPITALS TO MAYBE HIRE NURSES.
THAT WILL THEN JUST ALL THEY'RE
GOING TO DO IS HELP TEACH AND
HAVE THESE CLINICAL, HOURS TO BE
OPEN. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SOLUTION IS, I THINK WE'VE ALL
TRIED, BUT LIKE I SAID, IT'S,
YOU KNOW, AS AS MUCH AS I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR EFFORTS AND
I STILL DO, I JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE RIGHT SOLUTION. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO PIT ONE GROUP OF
STUDENTS AGAINST ANOTHER, I
THINK WE NEED ALL OF THEM AT
THIS POINT. SO I WOULD BE
OPPOSING IT TODAY AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, TO SENATOR NGUYEN,
SENATOR NGUYEN, I KNOW THAT YOU
HAVE ALSO TRADITIONALLY GIVEN
GREAT RESPECT TO FELLOW
COLLEAGUES AND AUTHORS WHO HAVE
PUT A DEEP AMOUNT OF WORK AND
EFFORT IN THIS CAPACITY. AS
PREVIOUSLY WAS STATED. CHAIR
ROTH AND I HAVE WORKED AT QUITE
A BIT OUTSIDE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES AS
YOU ALSO SIMILARLY KNOW,
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS ARE NOT
PERFECT IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT ISSUES, BUT
STATUS QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE. AND
WE HAVE BEFORE US IS A PRODUCT
TO HELP ADDRESS THESE ISSUES, TO
ADDRESS THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY
AND ALSO ACCESS POINTS. OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS ALSO HAVE
LOWER COSTS. AND WHEN WE ADDRESS
THE BARRIERS TO ENTRY, THAT IS
THE ENDEAVOR THAT WE HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS. AND SO THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE BEFORE YOU AND I
JUST WANT TO REAFFIRM THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE HARD WORK THAT
IS HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. AND
CHAIR ROTH AND I AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES TO BEST HELP ON THE
ACCESS ISSUE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO I HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR, BUT I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS AGAIN OF THE CHAIR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE'LL DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, FOR
JOINING US. OKAY. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 1895.
DOCTOR WEBER, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. SO WE'RE HEARING 12
BILLS.
READY. PROCEED. WHEN READY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I RISE HERE
TO PRESENT AB 19, 1895. A BILL
TO PROVIDE THE STATE WITH MORE
ADVANCED NOTIFICATION WHEN A
HOSPITAL EXPECTS CHALLENGES IN
THEIR PERINATAL UNIT. WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY, FACING A MATERNAL
CRISIS IN OUR STATE AND AROUND
THE COUNTRY. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT CAL MATTER ARTICLE,
NEARLY 50 MATERNITY WARDS HAVE
CLOSED ACROSS CALIFORNIA, WITH
MORE THAN HALF SHUTTING DOWN IN
THE LAST FOUR YEARS. THIS
IMPACTS EVERY DISTRICT UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. EARLIER THIS
YEAR, SCRIPPS HEALTH IN SAN
DIEGO ANNOUNCED THAT IT WOULD BE
CLOSING A MATERNITY WARD IN ITS
CHULA VISTA LOCATION, AND THOSE
PATIENTS WOULD NOW HAVE TO DRIVE
ALL THE WAY TO THE HILLCREST
LOCATION. LOW BIRTH VOLUMES,
FINANCIAL DISTRESS, WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AND INSUFFICIENT
MEDI-CAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES MAY
ALL BE REASONS WHY MATERNITY
WARDS NEED TO SHUT DOWN. CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES A HOSPITAL TO
NOTIFY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH, AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC, 90 DAYS PRIOR TO A
PROPOSED CLOSURE OF MATERNITY
SERVICES. UNFORTUNATELY, THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR THE STATE TO
INTERVENE FOR THESE REASONS. AB
1895 REQUIRES A HOSPITAL WITH A
PERINATAL UNIT THAT EXPECTS
CHALLENGES IN THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS THAT MAY RESULT IN A
REDUCTION OR LOSS OF PERINATAL
SERVICES TO REPORT SEVERAL DATA
POINTS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH ACCESS AND INFORMATION.
THIS REPORT WILL OUTLINE THE
THREE CLOSEST HOSPITALS OFFERING
PERINATAL SERVICES AND THE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA, THEIR DISTANCE
FROM THE CHALLENGE FACILITY, AND
WHETHER THESE HOSPITALS HAVE ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
FINALLY, WHEN A HOSPITAL
ANNOUNCES AN OFFICIAL CLOSURE OF
THE UNIT AS MANDATED BY THE
CURRENT LAW, AB 1895 REQUIRES A
60 DAY PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
THAT INCLUDES AT LEAST ONE
PUBLIC HEARING. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS. BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS, REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
FOR ALL, AND THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION. HERE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS
DOCTOR GIULIANA MELLO, BOARD
CERTIFIED OB GYN AND FACULTY AND
FAMILY PLANNING SPECIALIST. AND
SHERRI WILBURN PERINATAL EQUITY
INITIATIVE COMMITTEE ADVISORY
MEMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD, BEFORE YOU SPEAK AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. OKAY GOOD
MORNING, AND THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME
IS SHEREE WILBURN. I AM A
PROGRAM AND HEALTH AND EQUITY
PROGRAM MANAGER IN STOCKTON, AS
WELL AS A PERINATAL EQUITY
INITIATIVE. ORIGINAL BOARD
MEMBER. I'M ALSO AN ANGEL,
MOTHER. I'M HERE TODAY, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
MATTER, AND IT'S OF A PROFOUND
IMPORTANCE. I'M SORRY. THE
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF BLACK
BIRTHING WOMEN. THIS IS NOT JUST
A TOPIC OF DISCUSSION, BUT A
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND A DEMAND
OF OUR IMMEDIATE ATTENTION AND
ACTION. IMAGINE THE JOY OF
ANTICIPATING THE OUTCOME OF
EXPECTING A CHILD. NOW IMAGINE
THAT SAME JOY OVERSHADOWED BY
THE FEAR OF UNCERTAINTIES,
BECAUSE YOUR COMMUNITY LACKS
ACCESS TO THE CARE THAT SUPPORTS
POSITIVE BIRTHING OUTCOMES, THIS
IS A REALITY. FAR TOO MANY FOR
FAR TOO MANY BLACK BIRTHING
WOMEN TODAY, ESPECIALLY FOR THE
COMMUNITY THAT I SERVE IN SOUTH
STOCKTON. IT IS A REALITY THAT
HAS BEEN THAT HAS LED TO
PREVENTABLE TRAGEDIES, ROBBING
FAMILIES OF THEIR LOVED ONES AND
LEAVING COMMUNITIES HEARTBROKEN.
CONSIDER THIS TRAGIC CASE OF
SELENA M, A MOTHER WHO PASSED
AWAY THIS YEAR FROM
COMPLICATIONS OF CHILDBIRTH DUE
TO PRE-ECLAMPSIA. HER BLOOD
PRESSURE WAS SO HIGH THAT HER
HEART EXPLODED. SELENA WAS ONE
OF MY PARTICIPANTS WHO WAS
CONSTANTLY DISMISSED. HER CRIES
FOR HELP FELL ON DEAF EARS UNTIL
IT WAS TOO LATE. HER DEATH WAS
PREVENTABLE, YET SHE IS NO
LONGER HERE BECAUSE HER VOICE
WAS IGNORED. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPACT OF THE LACK OF ACCESS
FOR MATERNITY WARDS AND NICUS ON
OUR BIRTHING EXPERIENCES AS
BLACK MAMAS OR THE BLACK THE
MAMAS THAT YOU HAVE WORKED WITH.
YOU CANNOT STAND. WE CANNOT
STAND BY AS ANOTHER BLACK
MOTHER. LIFE IS CUT SHORT
BECAUSE HER PLEAS ARE IGNORED.
WE MUST MOVE BEYOND THE BALLOON
RELEASES AND THE MOURNING
CEREMONIES OF PREVENTABLE
DEATHS. WE OWE IT TO OUR OUR
WOMEN, THEIR CHILDREN, THEIR
FAMILIES AND ENSURE THAT THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD AND RESPECTED
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. LET US
COMMIT TODAY TO ELIMINATE THE
BARRIERS THAT STAND IN THE WAY
OF HEALTH EQUITY FOR ALL, NOT
JUST OUR BLACK MAMAS, BUT WE
WILL SPEAK SELENA'S NAME BECAUSE
THIS WAS PREVENTABLE. SO I URGE
AND I VOTE FOR THE LEGISLATION
AS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS ADDRESSING CRISIS
MATERNITY WARD CLOSURES. THAT WE
ARE FACING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, DOCTOR. GOOD MORNING,
MISTER CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. I AM
DOCTOR JULIANA MELO. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1895.
I'M AN OB GYN PHYSICIAN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY, DISTRICT NINE. PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL, AND AS
HAS BEEN STATED, WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF A CRISIS WHEN IT COMES
TO LABOR AND DELIVERY CARE. AS
THE CAL MATTER ANALYSIS AND
OTHER INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS HAVE
SHOWN, MORE THAN 40 MATERNITY
WARDS HAVE CLOSED ACROSS THE
STATE SINCE 2012. AND THIS IS
SIMULTANEOUSLY HAPPENING AT A
TIME WHERE NATIONALLY, WE HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH MATERNAL
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY, HIGHER
ACUITY BIRTHS AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES. BUT THIS IS THE
REALITY OF MODERN DAY LABOR AND
DELIVERY ON ANY GIVEN DAY, A
PHYSICIAN LIKE MYSELF CAN
ENCOUNTER MANY SITUATIONS, SUCH
AS PATIENTS WITH PREECLAMPSIA,
LIFE THREATENING BLEEDING, FETUS
WITH HEART RATE DISTRESS OR BABY
SHOULDER GETTING STUCK DURING
CHILDBIRTH. SOMETIMES THESE
SITUATIONS REQUIRE EMERGENCY
DELIVERY, WHERE EVERY MINUTE CAN
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE
AND DEATH. AND WHAT IF YOU'RE A
PATIENT LIKE THIS AND LITERALLY
HAD NOWHERE TO GO, OR HAD TO
DRIVE HOURS UPON HOURS TO GET
CARE? WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY TO
END THIS CRISIS, AND WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS A STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION, AS IT PROVIDES A WAY
TO FORMALIZE THE COLLECTION OF
DATA, ASSISTS, IN THE COMMUNITY
IN FINDING OTHER SERVICES IN THE
EVENT OF CLOSURE AND HOPE.
HOPEFULLY INFORMING POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS, AND PREVENT FUTURE
HOSPITAL CLOSURE, IN THE END,
LABOR AND DELIVERY NOT ONLY
PROVIDES CRUCIAL MEDICAL SUPPORT,
BUT IT ENSURES CHILDBIRTH IS NOT
JUST A MOMENT OF JOY, BUT ALSO
ONE OF SAFETY AND SECURITY.
FINDING A WAY TO STOP CLOSURES
WILL BE A WAY TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBLE AND INCLUSIVE CARE SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS, REGARDLESS OF
BACKGROUND OR CIRCUMSTANCE OR
ZIP CODE, HAVE ACCESS TO THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED DURING THIS
PIVOTAL MOMENT IN THEIR LIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY FOR AB 1895. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY.
PLEASE CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY
MOSSBERG REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH PLANS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT ESSENTIAL ACCESS, HEALTH
AND FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. KIM ROBINSON WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT AS CO-SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
VANESSA CAJINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK, BOTH HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. SYMPHONY BARBIE. ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT, ALSO NOTING SUPPORT FOR
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BRANDON
MAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. RYAN
SPENCER ALSO WITH THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYNS DISTRICT NINE,
SPONSORED BILL IN SUPPORT. I'VE
ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER THE
SUPPORT OF THE OTHER SPONSORS,
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIFE
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. LANGLEY,
ON BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT KRISTY
WEISS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
AGAIN, A BIT OF A TWEENER TODAY.
CHA DOESN'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BILL, BUT JUST WANTS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
RELATED TO CONFIDENTIALITY.
OBVIOUSLY, IF A HOSPITAL IS
STRUGGLING AND THE STAFF FIND
OUT THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, IS THE
HOSPITAL MAY CLOSE OR IS AT
RISK, THE STAFF START LEAVING.
AND SO IT'S AND THAT EXACERBATES
THE SITUATION THAT THE HOSPITAL
IS STRUGGLING WITH. SO IT'S A
VERY FINE LINE FOR HOSPITALS TO
BALANCE. AND WE JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHORS WORK ON
THAT. AND THANK HER. BRIANNA
NELSON, ON BEHALF OF TEACH IN
STRONG SUPPORT, SUZANNE GOODMAN,
DOCTOR FROM BIXBY CENTER FOR
GLOBAL REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH, ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND SUPPORT,
GOOD MORNING, MATT LAZAR. WITH
SEIU. WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL, AND I'VE ENJOYED
REALLY GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE. WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THE SORT OF
CONFIDENTIALITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT INFORMATION IS CURRENTLY
PUBLIC, MAINTAINS PUBLIC, AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THEM ON THAT. AND THEN
ALSO JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WORKERS ARE CONSIDERED AS PART
OF THIS PROCESS. I KNOW THERE'S
CONCERNS ABOUT PEOPLE LEAVING
AND THERE'S WAYS THAT WE'VE
OFFERED AND WOULD LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON TRY TO REFRAMING THAT
REALLY AROUND HOW DO WE GET HELP
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE KEEPING THESE
OPEN AND APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
WORK ON THIS? THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ANY
SEEING? NONE DOCTOR WEBER, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
OVER THE BREAK. I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WORK ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS, AS
YOU KNOW, BOTH HOW IT WORKS
HERE. ONCE REPORTS GET TO THE
LEGISLATURE, HOW IT HOW IT
RELATES TO THE TRANSPARENCY
RULES THAT ARE ON THE BOOKS IN
TERMS OF STATUTES AND WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO TO COMPLY. AND, AND
THE OTHER CONSIDERATIONS, THAT
SOME OF THE SPEAKERS MENTIONED,
OBVIOUSLY, IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
EFFORT. THIS IS A CRITICAL
ISSUE. AND PROBABLY ALL REGIONS
OF THE STATE, BUT CERTAINLY IN
OUR UNDERSERVED REGIONS, THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED. AND THIS
SEEMS TO BE A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO GET SOME DATA. I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW, GIVEN THE DECLINING
BIRTH RATE AND THE DIFFICULTY AT
THE STATE LEVEL IN FEDERAL LEVEL
TWO, I SUPPOSE IN PUSHING ENOUGH
FUNDING TO HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO MAINTAIN CRITICAL
SERVICES IN MANY AREAS OF THE
STATE IN PARTICULAR IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOME AREAS OF
EASTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTY,
PROBABLY SOME IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND OTHER AREAS IN THE
NORTH CENTRAL AND SOUTH OF THE
STATE. IS THERE AN EFFORT BY,
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT ADDITIONAL STEPS NEED TO BE
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
SOME LEVEL OF, OB GYN SERVICES
IN THESE UNDERSERVED AREAS.
OTHER THAN MAINTAINING A FULLY
STAFFED, MATERNITY WARD IN
HOSPITALS THAT ARE AROUND THE
CORNER, OR AT LEAST WITHIN
REASONABLE COMMUTING DISTANCE.
RIGHT? THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING,
SENATOR ROTH AND I DEFINITELY
LOOK FORWARD TO SITTING DOWN AND
TALKING WITH YOU AND PICKING
YOUR BRAIN ON HOW WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE CONFIDENTIALITY ISSUE.
I WE'LL WE'LL HANDLE THAT. YEAH,
YEAH. AND I WAS LIKE, THAT'S YOU
KNOW, SENATOR ROTH IS THE PERSON
I NEED TO SIT DOWN AND REALLY
TALK WITH BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND
THE HOSPITAL'S CONCERN. WE
DEFINITELY DON'T WANT TO CREATE
A SELF-FULFILLING PROPHECY. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS SO THAT
NO MATERNITY WARDS CLOSE. I
DON'T WANT ANY. I MEAN, THIS IS
BEEN A HUGE PROBLEM. AND EVERY
TIME YOU TURN AROUND, THE
CORNER, YOU HEAR ABOUT ANOTHER
MATERNITY WARD CLOSING AND SO
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
REALLY SO THAT THE STATE CAN ACT
AS A PARTNER WITH THESE
HOSPITALS, THESE LABOR AND
DELIVERY UNITS TO SEE WHAT, IF
ANYTHING, BECAUSE IF IT'S IF
IT'S AN ISSUE OF LOW DECLINING
BIRTH RATES AND THAT'S THE ONLY
THING THERE, WE CAN'T FORCE MORE
PEOPLE TO HAVE BABIES. BUT
OFTENTIMES WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT,
THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS THAT
THAT GO INTO PLAY. AND SO THIS
BILL IS TO REALLY SEE HOW WE AS
A STATE CAN SUPPORT AND HELP
THAT UNIT TO STAY OPEN, NOT TO
DO SOMETHING THAT WOULD CREATE
PEOPLE TO LEAVE OR CREATE PANIC
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY SO THAT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO HAVE NOT
HAPPEN DOES ULTIMATELY HAPPEN.
NOW TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT OTHER
OPTIONS, OTHER MODELS OUT THERE,
THERE HAVE BEEN CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT, YOU KNOW, I WANT TO
ECHO MY, MY FELLOW COLLEAGUE AS
AN OB GYN MYSELF, ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH SOME
OF THOSE MODELS IS THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE AN OBSTETRIC EMERGENCY, YOU
NEED TO HAVE THE EXPERTISE
THERE. AND, YOU KNOW, FOR ANY
MEDICAL STUDENT THAT'S ROTATED
ON A LABOR AND DELIVERY, WARD OR
THEIR OB GYN ROTATION, ANY
RESIDENT, ANY OB GYN OR EVEN
FAMILY MEDICINE, RIGHT. YOU KNOW
THAT, PREGNANCY IS A WONDERFUL
THING. HOWEVER, AS A, AS A
RESIDENT AT COOK COUNTY IN
CHICAGO, I REALIZED THAT THAT IS
PROBABLY THE MOST DANGEROUS
STATE THAT ANYONE COULD POSSIBLY
BE IN, THINGS TAKE A TURN VERY,
VERY QUICKLY. YOU CAN HAVE A
PERFECTLY NORMAL PREGNANCY.
EVERYTHING'S GOING GREAT DURING
THE DELIVERY. AND THEN BOOM, AN
ABRUPTION HAPPENS AND YOU NEED
TO HAVE THAT SPECIALIZED OB GYN
CARE. THE OB ANESTHESIOLOGIST,
THE O.R. ROOM READY TO SAVE THE
LIFE OF NOT ONLY THE MOTHER, BUT
THE BABY. AND SO I THINK WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HAVING
DIFFERENT MODELS TO KIND OF COME
IN AND FILL IN THE GAP, WE ALSO
HAVE TO BE VERY MINDFUL THAT YOU
STILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THAT URGENT, EMERGENT OBSTETRIC
CARE WHEN NECESSARY, AND ALSO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT FILLING IN
THE GAP IN THESE RURAL AND, AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY, WHO ALREADY
ARE AT RISK BECAUSE OF OTHER
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
SO THEY'RE ALREADY HIGH RISK FOR
PREECLAMPSIA. ARE ALREADY AT
HIGH RISK FOR SHOULDER BECAUSE
OF THE SIZE OF THE BABY, MAY
ALREADY HAVE DECREASED VISITS TO
THEIR MATERNAL WARD. SO, THERE
ARE CONVERSATIONS. BUT WE AGAIN,
THAT IS ALSO A BALANCING ACT SO
THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING CERTAIN
PEOPLE MORE AT RISK IF, WHEN, IF
AND WHEN THOSE OBSTETRIC
EMERGENCIES HAPPEN. I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU. THE GOOD NEWS IS
YOU'LL BE HERE. AND THE BAD NEWS
FOR ME IS I WON'T BE HERE. BUT
WE KNOW HOW TO GET IN TOUCH WITH
YOU. PARTICIPATE IN
CONVERSATION, BUT I CLEARLY
AGREE THAT, YOU KNOW, BIRTHING
CENTERS ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE
SOLUTION BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
SITUATIONS WHERE, IT ABSOLUTELY
REQUIRES THE SKILLS OF A OF A,
YOU KNOW, BOARD CERTIFIED OB GYN
PHYSICIAN TO HANDLE THE
EMERGENCY SITUATION. AND WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR SOMEONE TO FLY IN
AND DROP IN OR WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO BE ON, ON THE SITE. AND
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO EXPLORE
WHAT OUR REGULATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE IN TERMS OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES, HOW
THEY'RE STAFFED, WHAT WHAT
CHANGES WE COULD MAKE, HOW WE IN
SOME CASES SUBSIDIZE BECAUSE
THAT'S IF WE HAVE LOW BIRTH
RATES, YOU KNOW, IF YOU WANT AN
OB GYN TO PRACTICE, TO LOCATE
SOMEWHERE TO PRACTICE, THE OB
GYN HAS TO BE ABLE TO EARN A
LIVING. AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT AS A STATE.
IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE YOUR
TALENTS, DOCTOR WEBER, AND THE
TALENTS OF MANY OTHERS LIKE YOU,
TO PUT PUT THE PLAN TOGETHER, TO
PROPOSE THE RULE CHANGES AND
PUSH THEM THROUGH. AND I'LL BE
ROOTING FROM THE SIDELINES FOR
YOU, BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS ONE
OF THE CRITICAL ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE IN HEALTH CARE TODAY, AND
IT NEEDS THE FULL TIME AND
ATTENTION OF ALL THOSE WITH
BRAINS. AND I'M NOT SURE THAT'S
ME, BUT ALL THOSE WITH BRAINS
APPLYING THEIR FULL EFFORT TO
GET THIS THING SOLVED. IT'S A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY. AND
THANK YOU. I SHOULD LET YOU
CLOSE. IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE
YOU WANT TO SAY, JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND ALSO
YOUR STAFF'S SUPPORT ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE CAN TWEAK
IT TO MAKE IT THE BEST POSSIBLE.
THIS YEAR. WE'VE GOT THE BEST
STAFF. YES, WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
WE'LL DO JUST THAT. THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
WELL, LET'S TAKE ITEM NUMBER 24.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. PROCEED WHEN
READY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING. THANK YOU
FOR BEING MORE THAN TIMELY.
WE'VE GOT THE FULL COMPLEMENT
TODAY. OKAY. SO MEMBER. GOOD TO
SEE YOU AGAIN. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY, SIR. GREAT. THANK
YOU. SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
3156, THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON SINCE I'VE BEEN
ELECTED, WHEN, IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING BEING ELECTED, I SAT
IN A LIVING ROOM WITH A GROUP OF
MOMS IN MY DISTRICT WHO HAVE A
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AND ESSENTIALLY,
WHAT'S HAPPENING. TO MAKE A VERY
LONG STORY SHORT, IS THAT, AS
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS TO
MANAGED, MANAGE MEDI-CAL MANAGED
CARE, THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT
UTILIZE REGIONAL CENTERS AS WELL
ULTIMATELY ARE BEING FORCED TO
BE PUT ON TO MEDI-CAL IS THEIR
PRIMARY INSURANCE COVERAGE. AND
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
SPECIALISTS THAT THEY HAVE, THEY
DON'T ACCEPT MEDI-CAL. AND SO
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS, BECAUSE I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL SORT OF AS A IS A
PLACEHOLDER AS WE TRY TO WORK
THIS OUT WITH DHCS OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS, AND DHCS HAS
INDICATED TO US THAT IT IS NOT
THEIR INTENT FOR THEM TO
OBVIOUSLY LOSE ACCESS TO THEIR
PRIMARY INSURANCE OR THEIR
PRIMARY PROVIDERS, AND SO OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS, WE'VE MET
WITH DHCS MULTIPLE TIMES,
INCLUDING THE DIRECTOR, AND
WE'VE HAD SOME VERY GOOD AND
FRANK CONVERSATIONS. AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT, MY STAFF HAS
PROBABLY SPENT 100 PLUS HOURS
WORKING ON INDIVIDUAL CASES FOR
CONSTITUENTS, NOT ONLY IN MY
DISTRICT, BUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ACTUALLY, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THE DOWNSIDE IS
I'M NOT AWARE OF A SINGLE
SUCCESS STORY OF ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY WHO UTILIZES A
REGIONAL CENTER ACTUALLY BEING
ABLE TO KEEP THEIR PRIMARY
COVERAGE. AND SO THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY VERY PROBLEMATIC WITH
ME. NOW, OUR ORIGINAL INTENT WAS
TO BASICALLY, OKAY, WE'RE KIND
OF TIRED OF DEALING WITH THIS.
LET'S JUST EXEMPT THEM FROM THIS
MANAGED CARE PROGRAM. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT'S NOT THE
DESIRE. AND THAT WOULD ADD SOME
COMPLEXITIES. BUT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS JUST SAY, HEY,
LOOK, DCS, CAN YOU PLEASE WORK
THIS OUT AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO KEEP THEIR
PRIMARY CARE BECAUSE THESE ARE
THESE ARE SPECIALISTS. THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRAINED ON THE
DISABILITIES THAT THEY HAVE. AND
IT'S A VERY UNIQUE AND SPECIFIC,
KIND OF DOCTOR THAT THEY NEED
THAT UNFORTUNATELY, THEY DON'T
TAKE MEDI-CAL FOR A LOT OF
REASONS WHERE WE'RE AWARE OF.
BUT, SO, LIKE I SAID, THE ONE
THING, THE REASON WHY I THINK
THAT THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT,
AND MY MOST RECENT DISCUSSION
WITH DCS AND AGAIN, THE DIRECTOR
HAS BEEN VERY GREAT AND GRACIOUS
WITH ME, IS THAT IT SEEMED THAT
THERE WAS SOME BLAME PUT ON THE
PROVIDERS. AND THIS IS VERY
COMPLEX SYSTEM. BUT WHAT I ALL
OF THESE CASES THAT COME TO ME,
THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS, THEY ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT HEALTH PLANS. SO IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY IT CANNOT POSSIBLY
BE ALL OF THEIR FAULTS
COLLECTIVELY. THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH THE WAY THAT THE BILLING
HAPPENS. AND SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD, IF WE CAN
GET DCS TO FIX IT ON THEIR OWN,
AND ESPECIALLY THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION, THAT IS MY GOAL. AT
THE END OF THE DAY, I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE WITH THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE. AND, AND CONTINUE TO
GET THE SERVICES THAT THEY'VE
HAD FOREVER, WITH THAT, I DO
HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE, TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE,
NATALIE COOPER, WHO'S A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE. SHE'S
JOINED WITH SUE SAMUEL, ALSO A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE, AND ALSO
JIM FRAZIER OF ARC OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I ASSUME YOU
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS? YES, I DO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY, THANK YOU FOR THE
WORK AND THE COMMUNICATIONS WITH
THE STAFF AND THE CONSULTANTS.
IT'S BEEN A REALLY GOOD
EXPERIENCE. I APPRECIATE THAT,
OKAY. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES. FOR THE RECORD
BEFORE YOU SPEAK. I'LL LET YOU
DETERMINE THE ORDER. I GUESS
IT'S YOU, MA'AM. SO YOU'RE ON.
MY NAME IS NATALIE COOPER, AND
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 3156, A BILL
DESIGNED TO SAFEGUARD THE
MEDICAL CARE RIGHTS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS BY
ALLOWING THEM TO USE THEIR
PRIMARY INSURANCE INSTEAD OF
BEING RESTRICTED TO MANAGED
CARE. MEDI-CAL PROVIDERS. THE
CURRENT LAW UNDER THE EXISTING
LEGISLATION DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE CLIENTS OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND HAVE OTHER PRIMARY
INSURANCE, SO THAT'S INSURANCE
FUNDED BY THEIR PARENTS. MOST
LIKELY, MUST STILL USE MANAGED
MEDI-CAL TO ACCESS OTHER
SERVICES SUCH AS IHSS, WHICH IS
A GENERIC SERVICE THAT WE ARE
MANDATED TO USE AND OTHERS. THIS
HAS LED TO NUMEROUS CHALLENGES
FOR FAMILIES WITH MEDICALLY
COMPLEX INDIVIDUALS WHO QUALIFY
FOR REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES, AS
THEY ARE FORCED INTO A LIMITED
POOL OF MANAGED CARE PROVIDERS,
OFTEN RESULTING IN THE LOSS OF
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND ACCESS TO
NECESSARY SPECIALISTS. MY FRIEND
DYLAN BIG D, WHO HAS AUTISM, IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THIS
CURRENT LAW. DYLAN IS FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
THROUGH TRICARE FOR LIFE THANKS
TO HIS DAD, GRANDAD AND GREAT
GRANDAD WHO WERE ALL COMBAT
COMBAT FIGHTER PILOTS. WITH OVER
80 YEARS OF MILITARY EXPERIENCE
AND MORE THAN 300 COMBAT
MISSIONS, THEIR DEDICATION AND
SERVICE PROVIDE DYLAN WITH
EXCELLENT INSURANCE COVERAGE,
COVERAGE AND AS AN. AND THAT
COVERAGE CONTINUES AS AN
INCAPACITY, SORRY. INCAPACITATED
ADULT. HOWEVER, DUE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CAL AIM AND
MANAGED MEDI-CAL, DYLAN CANNOT
USE HIS TRICARE AND IS FORCED
OUT OF HIS SUPERIOR COVERAGE. MY
SON COLIN SUFFERS FROM AN
EXCEEDINGLY RARE AND COMPLEX
GENETIC DISORDER, WITH ONLY FOUR
DOCUMENTED CASES KNOWN AT THIS
TIME. THIS DISORDER INCLUDES
TWISTING OF HIS UPPER SPINE,
JOINT CONTRACTURES, LIMITED
FUNCTIONAL USE OF HIS HANDS,
SEIZURES, CORTICAL VISUAL
IMPAIRMENT, AND EXTREME ANXIETY.
THE UNCERTAINTY AND SEVERITY OF
HIS CONDITION AND NECESSITY ACT
IS, SORRY SEVERITY OF HIS
CONDITION NECESSITATE ACCESS TO
TOP TIER MEDICAL SPECIALISTS.
PREVIOUSLY, OUR FAMILY MANAGED
TO BUDGET FOR HIGH DEDUCTIBLE
PPO PLAN TO ENSURE COLIN COULD
SEE THE BEST DOCTORS FOR HIS
CONDITION. HOWEVER, THE ROLLOUT
OF CALAIM DRASTICALLY ALTERED
OUR SITUATION. DESPITE OBTAINING
LETTERS FROM SPECIALISTS UNDER
UNDERSCORING THE CRITICAL NEED
FOR CONTINUITY OF CARE AND THE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT OF LOSING
PROVIDERS UNDER MANAGED
MEDI-CAL, OUR EXEMPTION WAS
DENIED. WITHIN FOUR WEEKS, WE
LOST ACCESS TO SPECIALISTS WHO
HAD BEEN CRUCIAL IN MANAGING
COLIN'S DEBILITATING ANXIETY, A
PROVIDER WITH WHOM HE HAD
FINALLY CONNECTED AFTER TRYING
AT LEAST A DOZEN OTHERS. THE
MANAGED MEDI-CAL SYSTEM HAS
PROVEN TO BE INSUFFICIENT. THERE
ARE LITTLE TO NO PROVIDERS
ENROLLED IN THE MANAGED MEDICAL
CARE PLAN IN OUR COUNTY, LEAVING
US WITHOUT TIMELY QUALITY CARE.
CONTINUITY OF CARE BECAME
IMPOSSIBLE AS MANY PROVIDERS ARE
UNWILLING TO ACCEPT THE LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES OFFERED BY
MANAGED MEDICARE PLANS. OUR
PRIMARY INSURANCE PLANS, ONCE A
LIFELINE, ARE NOW USELESS AS WE
ARE FORCED TO USE ONLY PROVIDERS
WHO ARE ALSO ENROLLED IN MANAGED
MEDI-CAL PLANS. THE REALITY IS
THAT DIFFERENT INSURANCE PLANS
DO NOT WORK TOGETHER, AS
PROMISED BY DHCS. DYLAN WAS
TURNED AWAY AND DENIED CARE FROM
A TEAM OF PROVIDERS THAT TOOK
OVER A DECADE TO ASSEMBLE. THE
UC DAVIS MIND INSTITUTE,
ARGUABLY THE LEADER IN AUTISM
RESEARCH AND CARE, WILL NOT TAKE
ANYONE WITH MANAGED MEDI-CAL AS
A SECONDARY INSURANCE,
REGARDLESS OF PRIMARY COVERAGE
OR OTHER HEALTH INSURANCE. BUT
THEY DID ACCEPT FEE FOR SERVICE
MEDI-CAL AS A SECONDARY AB 3156
OFFERS A LOW COST SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM. THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW DISABLED INDIVIDUALS LIKE
DYLAN, COLIN, AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS TO CONTINUE TO USE THEIR
PRIMARY INSURANCE. IT WILL
REQUIRE DHS TO FOCUS MORE ON THE
NEEDS OF THE POPULATION BY
SOLICITING STAKEHOLDER INPUT
THROUGH EXISTING MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLAN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE, AND TAKE ANY
NECESSARY, ANY NECESSARY STEPS
THROUGH ADDITIONAL PLAN OR
PROVIDER GUIDANCE, ENFORCEMENT
OR CONSUMER OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION WHERE NECESSARY, TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED. THIS
SIMPLE YET EFFECTIVE CHANGE
WOULD RESTORE ACCESS TO THE
ESSENTIAL, HIGH QUALITY CARE
THAT IS CRITICAL FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS. PASSING AB 3156
WILL PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS, INCLUDING
MY FRIEND DYLAN, MY SON COLIN,
AND COUNTLESS OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHO HAVE PRIMARY HEALTH
COVERAGE. BUT ARE THE VICTIMS OF
THE CURRENT SYSTEM. SHORTCOMING
LET'S FIX THIS ISSUE TO ENSURE
THAT NO MORE FAMILIES HAVE TO
ENDURE WHAT WE HAVE FACED.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB 3156 AND HELP
SAFEGUARD THE MEDICAL CARE OF
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION AND YOUR YES VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
VERY NICE JOB ON THAT. OKAY. WHO
WANTS TO TRY TO TOP THAT. GO
AHEAD. CHEN THAT'S YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO
BE HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT THESE.
MAMA BEARS IN THEIR EFFORTS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. WHAT I WOULD SAY
AND ALSO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND HIS STAFF FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS CAUSE. ALSO,
AFTER READING THE STAFF ANALYSIS
ON THIS, I CAN'T ADD TO IT YOUR
STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE GETS IT.
I MEAN, IT'S AN ABSOLUTE
NECESSITY THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THESE FAMILIES IN A
MANNER THAT THEY USED TO HAVE.
AND THEN WHEN CAL AME CAME IN
FRONT OF US, THEY GOT THE RUG
PULLED OUT FROM UNDERNEATH THEM,
I DON'T KNOW THE SITUATION, WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK IN A
MANNER, BUT WE NEED TO HAVE A
LIVING DOCUMENT WHEN WE HAVE CAL
AIM AND FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE
TO ADJUST TO THIS PREDICAMENT.
WHEN KELLYANNE WAS PUT TOGETHER,
IT REALLY, IN MY OPINION,
FOCUSED ON THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESS. AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE
JUST KIND OF GATHERED UP THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY AND BROUGHT IT FORWARD
WITH IT, AND IT KIND OF SEEMS TO
ME THAT WE'RE STEPPING OVER A
DOLLAR TO PICK UP A DIME WHEN
PRIVATE INSURANCE WILL PICK UP
THESE SPECIALISTS AT NO
QUESTION. AND SAVING THE STATE
MONEY. BUT WHEN WE DO THIS,
MANAGED CARE COMPONENT, WE'RE
LEAVING OUT THE HEALTH OF THE
INDIVIDUAL THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE PROVIDING FOR THROUGH THE
LANTERMAN ACT. AND SO IN ONE
CASE, I WOULD THINK THAT WE ARE
VIOLATING THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHEN WE DON'T
GIVE THEM THE EQUAL ACCESS TO
CARE THAT THEY DESERVE. AND THAT
OTHERS HAVE. AND SO WITH THAT, I
JUST ASK FOR, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I VOTE. AND I'M PROUD TO SIT
HERE WITH THESE MAMA BEARS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. YES,
MA'AM. I'M SUE, NATALIE, AND I
COMBINED THE SPEECH. SO WHEN SHE
WAS SPEAKING ABOUT DYLAN, WHO
LOST ALL HIS DOCTORS ON MAY 2ND.
THAT'S MY SON. SO HE'S JUST THE
FIRST EXAMPLE OF. I THINK THAT
WE KNOW ABOUT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THAT LOST ALL THE
HEALTH COVERAGE BECAUSE OF CAL
AIM. WELL THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO JOIN US. THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT JOB. THANKS FOR HAVING
US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE, PLEASE.
VANESSA CAJINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HI, I'M SUSAN HOLDEN.
I HAVE A LOVED ONE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY. ALSO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT ABOUT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DESK. COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. NICE
JOB. YOU MAY CLOSE. GREAT. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I WOULD
GLADLY NOT SEND THIS BILL TO THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD IT GET OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS. IF DC'S, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN RESOLVE THESE
INTERNALLY. THIS IS, I THINK,
JUST A BACKSTOP AND, KIND OF
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST TO, YOU
KNOW, PUT TOGETHER A WORK GROUP
AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT WE'LL TAKE THAT
UP IN APPROPRIATIONS. BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION.
AND I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO IDEAS OR
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THIS FOR OUR, OUR
DISABLED COMMUNITY. WELL, AS YOU
KNOW, PERFECTION IS A WORD
THAT'S NOT OFTEN FOUND IN OUR
DICTIONARY HERE. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE INDIVIDUALS
SUCH AS YOURSELF TO BRING BILLS
FORWARD TO FIX WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN THE PAST AND MAKE IT MAKE IT
AS PERFECT AS WE POSSIBLY CAN.
SO THANK YOU. AND AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE'LL TAKE IT UP AND
GREAT. THANK YOU. VOTE IT OUT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. THANKS
OKAY, I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER KHN HERE. SO LET'S CALL
UP ITEM NUMBER 14. AB 2467 UP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, MAY I
GO FORWARD? I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
SEEING YOU. OKAY? YOU WOULD HAVE
LET ME GO FIRST. I'M SURE HE
WOULD. HE'S THE CONSUMMATE
GENTLEMAN. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. MR. CHAIR AND SENATOR.
GOOD. SENATORS I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK ON
THIS AND THEIR DEDICATION TO
MAKING THE BILL STRONGER FOR
EVERY WOMAN IN CALIFORNIA, I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2467. IT IS
A FIRST OF ITS KIND BILL WITH
EXPANSIVE MANDATED HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
PERIMENOPAUSE AND MENOPAUSE
RELATED SYMPTOMS. THE BILL WAS
CREATED IN PART DUE TO
CONVERSATIONS WE AS A
LEGISLATURE, HAD DURING HEARINGS
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH, INCLUDING A
JOINT HEARING WITH YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND HOSTING THAT
HEARING, WE'RE IN THE YEAR 2024
AND WOMEN'S HEALTH IN RELATION
TO MENOPAUSE IS BOTH
UNDERSTUDIED AND UNDERFUNDED. IT
IS UNACCEPTABLE. IN A STUDY BY
BONAFIDE ON THE STATE OF
MENOPAUSE, ONLY ONE THIRD OF
WOMEN BETWEEN THE AGES OF 40 AND
64 SAID THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER HAS EVER TALKED TO THEM
ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT WHILE GOING
THROUGH MENOPAUSE. IN
COMPARISON, ISSUES AFFECTING MEN
OF THE SAME AGE ARE WIDELY
CONSIDERED MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAPPEN EVERY
SINGLE DAY. DOCTORS ARE WORKING
HASTILY TO MAKE SURE THAT MEN'S
SYMPTOMS ARE GIVEN THE RIGHT
TREATMENT, AND WOMEN ARE TRAINED
TO TOUGH OUT THE SYMPTOMS OF
MENOPAUSE. AS ONE OF THE LEADING
STATES IN THE NATION FOR HEALTH
CARE, WE'RE LETTING HALF OF OUR
CONSTITUENCY DOWN EVERY WOMAN
WHO LIVES LONG ENOUGH WILL
EXPERIENCE MENOPAUSE AND
DESERVES THE TREATMENT THAT THAT
WILL HELP THEM ALLEVIATE THEIR
SYMPTOMS AND LIVE LONGER AND
HEALTHIER LIVES. THERE ARE
PROVEN TREATMENT OPTIONS OUT
THERE THAT WOMEN SIMPLY DON'T
KNOW EXIST, OR ARE NOT COVERED
BY THEIR HEALTHCARE, BY THEIR
INSURANCE PLAN. THE STIGMA NEEDS
TO BE BROKEN, AND THESE
TREATMENTS NEED TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF WOMEN'S MENOPAUSE.
HEALTHCARE JOURNEY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS RYAN SPENCER,
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICIANS AND
GYNECOLOGISTS, AND WE HAVE A
STATEMENT FROM LARA. OUR OTHER
WITNESS THAT MY AMAZING STAFFER,
HANNAH, WILL READ. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD BEFORE SPEAKING. SURE.
BOARD. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYNS
DISTRICT NINE, A SUPPORTERS OF
AB 2467. FIRST, WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE OF
MENOPAUSE. SHE'S BEEN A STRONG
VOICE IN COMENZÓ FOR MAKING IT A
POLICY PRIORITY. NEARLY 6000
WOMEN IN THE UNITED STATES REACH
MENOPAUSE EVERY DAY,
CONSTITUTING UP TO 40% OF THEIR
LIVES, WITH APPROXIMATELY 8,080%
OF THOSE EXPERIENCING SYMPTOMS
THAT DISRUPT THEIR DAILY LIVES.
DESPITE THE AVAILABILITY OF
EFFECTIVE TREATMENTS FOR THESE
SYMPTOMS, INDIVIDUALS MAY
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS TREATMENTS
DUE TO LACK OF INSURANCE
COVERAGE, HORMONE THERAPY, NON
HORMONAL THERAPY, AND OTHER
MEDICAL INTERVENTIONS CAN
PROHIBITIVELY BE EXPENSIVE
WITHOUT INSURANCE SUPPORT. AB
2467 IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
THAT ENSURE COVERAGE OF
TREATMENTS DEEMED MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR PERIMENOPAUSE AND
MENOPAUSE SYMPTOMS. IT
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH CHALLENGES FACED BY
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING
MENOPAUSE AND SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THEIR ACCESS TO NECESSARY
MEDICAL CARE. IT ADDRESSES THIS
CRITICAL GAP BY MANDATING
COVERAGE FOR THESE TREATMENTS,
ENSURING THAT ALL CAN RECEIVE
THE CARE THEY NEED AND THEY
DESERVE. ENSURING COMPREHENSIVE
AND FLEXIBLE INSURANCE COVERAGE
FOR MENOPAUSE TREATMENTS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT IMPROVING INDIVIDUALS
QUALITY OF LIFE. IT IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPERATIVE AS UNTREATED
MENOPAUSAL SYMPTOMS CAN LEAD TO
LONG TERM HEALTH COMPLICATIONS
AND IS ESSENTIAL TO ACCOMMODATE
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
UNDERGOING MENOPAUSE AND REDUCE
ASSOCIATED HEALTH RISKS. HB 2467
ALIGNS WITH ACO'S COMMITMENT TO
GENDER EQUALITY AND HEALTH CARE
EQUITY, AND ACKNOWLEDGES THE
UNIQUE HEALTH CHALLENGES FACED
BY WOMEN ENSURES THEY RECEIVE
THE CARE THEY NEED. AND LIKE I
SAID BEFORE, THEY DESERVE. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS, ACOG IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB 2467 AND
URGES YOUR VOTE AS WELL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. YES MA'AM. HELLO.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. HANNAH LEE, ON BEHALF
OF LORDS IRON AND I WILL BE
READING HER TESTIMONY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, AND THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS ISSUE. MY NAME
IS LORDS IRON AS THE
GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS MANAGER AND
HOUSE LOBBYIST FOR SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC, I'M A LONG TERM
MEMBER OF THIS AMAZING CAPITOL
COMMUNITY. IN THE 1900S 1997 AS
A COLLEGE GRADUATE, I STARTED MY
FIRST JOB IN THE ASSEMBLY AS A
RECEPTIONIST FOR THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND BUDGET CHAIR DENISE
MORENO DUCHENY. IN FACT, SORRY,
MENOPAUSE IS A NATURAL PROCESS,
BUT IT FEELS AWFUL. IT'S A
MENTAL AND EMOTIONAL ROLLER
COASTER WITH WILD SWINGS. I'M
IRRITABLE. I'M SAD WITH NO
WARNING OR REASON. PHYSICALLY
IT'S DRAINING. I'M LOSING SLEEP,
MUSCLE MASS, ENERGY, HAIR AND
STAMINA. I SOMETIMES DON'T FEEL
LIKE MYSELF ANYMORE. IT'S THE
MOST UNNATURAL WAY TO GO THROUGH
A NATURAL PROCESS. THEN I LEARN
ABOUT HORMONAL TREATMENT FOR
MENOPAUSAL WOMEN, PROGESTERONE
FOR SLEEP, ESTROGEN TO EASE
MENOPAUSAL SYMPTOMS,
TESTOSTERONE TO MAINTAIN MUSCLE
ENERGY, AND STAMINA. YAY!
SCIENCE AND MEDICINE. SAVE THE
DAY. BOO! INSURANCE POLICIES
OBSTRUCT MY WAY. YES, OBSTRUCT
MY INSURANCE COMPANY WILL NOT
COVER TESTOSTERONE COST. REASON
ONE NOT MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
THEIR DOCTOR SAID I APPEAL AND
THEY DENY ME AGAIN. REASON TWO I
AM NOT MALE. THEIR DOCTOR SAID I
AM CONFUSED BY THEIR DOCTORS
SINCE THEY ARE NOT MY DOCTORS,
AND I AM NOW FORCED TO PAY $450
PER MONTH TO USE TESTOSTERONE AS
PART OF MY MENOPAUSAL CARE.
WOMEN PRODUCE ESTROGEN,
PROGESTERONE, AND TESTOSTERONE.
TESTOSTERONE IS PRODUCED IN
SIMILAR QUANTITIES IN WOMEN THAN
IN MEN, OF COURSE, BUT IT'S
THERE AND IT'S NECESSARY. I'M
NOT WINNING. I'M NOT LOOKING TO
WIN A BODYBUILDING COMPETITION.
I'M JUST HOPING TO HAVE THE
ENERGY TO GET UP AND COME TO
WORK IN THE MORNING WITHOUT
WANTING TO YELL AT PEOPLE. AND I
WANT TO FEEL LIKE MYSELF AGAIN
SO THAT I MAY CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS INCREDIBLE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2467. THANK YOU. NICE
JOB. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE? PLEASE
STEP UP. SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. YES, MA'AM. SUZANNE
GOODMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE TEACH
PROGRAM AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? I
THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO IS, WELL, YOU MAY BE ALSO
BE ABLE TO STAY THERE. WE NEED A
COUPLE OF MIKES, THOUGH, JOE.
OH, HE'S GOING TO DO IT FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW THE RULES. WE NEED YOU
TO IDENTIFY YOURSELVES AND FLIP
A COIN. YES, MA'AM. MR. CHAIR
MEMBER STEPHANIE WATKINS, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES.
REGRETTABLY, HERE IN OPPOSITION,
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR. I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF WORK WITH COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL. UNFORTUNATELY, WHILE
WE WERE MINUTES AWAY FROM
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION ON AN
EARLIER ITERATION OF THE BILL
COMING OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY, THE
BILL IN PRINT TODAY GIVES US
GREAT PAUSE. I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES, AS YOU'LL LOOK
IN REFERENCE TO Ã, IS, IS THE
BILL REQUIRES AN INCLUSIVE BUT
NOT LIMITED TO OPENS THE DOOR
FOR TO GO FAR BEYOND. I THINK
WHAT WE SAW IN THE BILL COMING
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY, I THINK OUR
CONCERNS ARE AND IT'S BEEN NOTED
BY BARB THAT THIS SORT OF OPENS
THE DOOR TO A MUCH GREATER
POTENTIAL COST THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY ANALYZED. I THINK
WE'D ALSO HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT REMOVING
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT RELATED
TO EACH FORMULATION AND
ASSOCIATED METHOD, IN ADDITION
TO GRANTING MEDICAL NECESSITY
STANDARD TO BE DETERMINED SOLELY
BY THE PROVIDERS, THAT GIVES US
SOME PAUSE. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL REMOVES ANY ABILITY
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO PLACE
QUANTITATIVE LIMITS ON THE BILL
ON ANY SORT OF DISEASE OR
DIAGNOSIS. I THINK I WOULD POINT
OUT INTO AT LEAST ONE OPTION
EACH FORMULATION OF AN
ASSOCIATED MEMBER METHOD OF
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
NON-HORMONAL MEDICATION FOR EACH
MENOPAUSE SYMPTOM, AS IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY STATED, THE SYMPTOMS
FOR MENOPAUSE CAN BE QUITE BROAD,
WE'RE SORT OF UNCERTAIN ABOUT
HOW THAT WOULD BE INTERPRETED
AND HOW WE WOULD HAVE ON OUR
FORMULARIES, COVERAGE FOR EVERY
SINGLE SOLITARY SYMPTOM. WE
THINK THAT THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE A GREAT
SIGNIFICANT COST AND ONE THAT
HASN'T BEEN PREVIOUSLY ANALYZED.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TODAY,
WE'D ALSO SUGGEST THAT MAYBE
KBRP LOOK AT THIS ITERATION OF
THE BILL TO CONSIDER WHAT THOSE
POTENTIAL COSTS WOULD BE TO THE
HEALTH CARE SECTOR. THANK YOU.
YES, SIR. ROBERT BOYKIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS. GOOD MORNING AGAIN, IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND I'D
JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF EARLIER. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE SOME OPPOSITION.
OTHER OPPOSITION? IS THERE ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION NAME?
AFFILIATION POSITION WAS SEEING
NONE, SOME MEMBERS, THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS YOU
DID, WHICH ARE IN PRINT. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE ARE SOME
OTHER AMENDMENTS UNDER
CONVERSATION. I APPRECIATE YOU
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION. I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS ON THE
PLANS THEY NEED TO. THEY NEED TO
KNOW SORT OF WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT IN ORDER TO DECIDE,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT PREMIUMS
INVOLVED. AND, MY UNDERSTANDING
IS ALREADY TAKING A LOOK AT THE
AT THE, THE AMENDMENTS THAT
AREN'T IN PRINT. IT'S FIGURING
OUT THE BILL IN PRINT, I GUESS
CORRECTING MYSELF. ACTUALLY, THE
BRAINS ARE CORRECTING ME, BUT
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THIS AND SEE IF WE
CAN'T COME TO, A RESOLUTION.
IT'S A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AS I MENTIONED DURING THE
HEARING, IT AFFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDING REGARDLESS OF OUR
GENDER, THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
SPOUSES OR LOVED ONES OR
DAUGHTERS, IT'S A IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT WE REALLY NEED TO GRAPPLE
WITH AND GET A HANDLE ON. SO
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS, CONCERNS? I DON'T SEE
HANDS FLYING UP. SO I GUESS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S IT'S YOUR LUCKY
DAY. YOU GET TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND I DO CONTINUE TO
APPRECIATE YOUR ALLYSHIP AND
STRONG SUPPORT ON THE ISSUE OF
MENOPAUSAL CARE. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. ONE OF THE
ISSUES JUST TO ADDRESS THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IS THAT OFTEN WOMEN,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN WHO HAVE RISK
OF BREAST CANCER, CAN'T HAVE
SYSTEMIC ESTROGEN. AND WHAT IS
CURRENTLY HAPPENING IS LOCALIZED
ESTROGEN, WHICH IS SAFE FOR
THEM, WHICH IS DONE THROUGH
CREAMS AND GELS IS DENIED. AND
SO PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO WITH THE FORMULATION IS
ENSURE THAT WOMEN CAN GET THE
SPECIFIC CARE THEY NEED, BUT ARE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE, THE POISE THAT
THE PLANTS HAVE TAKEN ALONG THE
WAY OF BEING SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EFFORT. AND I KNOW THAT THEY
HAVE A LOT OF WOMEN IN THEIR
RANKS WHO WILL NEED THIS CARE AS
WELL. SO I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
GET A QUORUM. WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE WILL VOTE. SO,
MEMBER HANEY, I NEED TO ASK YOUR
PATIENCE BECAUSE I JUMPED OVER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL, WHO WAS
HERE BEFORE YOU GOT HERE, AND HE
WAS KIND ENOUGH TO DEFER TO SOME
MEMBER OF OUR KHN. SO MR.
GABRIEL, STEP UP. PROCEED. WHEN
READY. THIS IS, FOR THOSE
KEEPING TRACK. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER TEN, AB 2316. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL PUPIL NUTRITION.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB 2316.
AND THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY, FOR YOUR GRACIOUSNESS. I
WILL BE ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO STRIKE TITANIUM
DIOXIDE FROM THE BILL. AB 2316
IS A BIPARTISAN BILL THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT SCHOOLS FROM SERVING
FOODS CONTAINING ADDITIVE LINKS
TO HYPERACTIVITY AND
NEUROBEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS IN
CHILDREN. GIVEN THESE LONG
STANDING CONCERNS, IN 2019, THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT, KNOWN AS OHA, TO
CONDUCT AN INDEPENDENT AND
THOROUGH SCIENTIFIC EXAMINATION
INTO THE IMPACT OF SYNTHETIC
FOOD DYES ON CHILDREN IN 2021,
AFTER AN EXHAUSTIVE REVIEW, OHA
ISSUED A REPORT WITH CLEAR
FINDINGS. MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONCLUDED
THAT, QUOTE, CONSUMPTION OF
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES CAN RESULT
IN HYPERACTIVITY AND OTHER
NEUROBEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS IN SOME
CHILDREN. THE REPORT ALSO FOUND
THAT CURRENT FDA APPROVAL OF
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES IS BASED ON
35 TO 70 YEAR OLD STUDIES THAT
WERE NOT DESIGNED TO DETECT THE
TYPE OF BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN OBSERVED IN CHILDREN,
AND THAT NEWER STUDIES INDICATE
THAT CURRENT FDA GUIDELINES MAY
NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT CHILDREN.
THE CONCLUSIONS REACHED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE
HARM CAUSED BY THESE CHEMICALS
IS CONSISTENT WITH THAT OF MANY
OTHER NATIONS AROUND THE WORLD,
MANY OF WHICH HAVE BANNED
RESTRICTED OR REQUIRED THESE
COLORING AGENTS TO INCLUDE
STRICT WARNING, LABELING
REQUIREMENTS. TO BE CLEAR, THIS
BILL WILL NOT RESULT IN A BAN ON
ANY FOODS IN CALIFORNIA, NOR
WILL IT RESULT IN ANY PRODUCTS
COMING OFF THE SHELF. ON THE
CONTRARY, IT WILL SIMPLY
ENCOURAGE COMPANIES TO MAKE VERY
MINOR MODIFICATIONS TO FOOD SOLD
IN OUR SCHOOLS TO REMOVE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS AND REPLACE THEM WITH
SAFER ALTERNATIVE INGREDIENTS
THEY ALREADY USE IN EUROPE AND
SO MANY OTHER NATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD, THIS SIMPLE CHANGE CAN
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE,
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR STUDENTS
WHO STRUGGLE WITH ADHD AND OTHER
LEARNING ISSUES. AS ANYONE WHO
HAS WATCHED A CHILD STRUGGLE
KNOWS, IT MAKES NO SENSE TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH THERAPIES AND
INTERVENTIONS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND THEN EXPOSE THEM TO
CHEMICALS AT LUNCH THAT WILL
FURTHER EXACERBATE THEIR
CHALLENGE. FINALLY, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
MORE THAN 95% OF THE PRODUCTS
SERVED IN SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY
FREE FROM THESE CHEMICALS, AND
THAT ARE A NUMBER OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE,
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
AND TAHOE-TRUCKEE, HAVE ALREADY
STOPPED SERVING FOODS THAT
INCLUDE THESE HARMFUL ADDITIVES.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH STAKEHOLDERS
IN OPPOSITION AND HAVE
PREVIOUSLY ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION TO GIVE
INDUSTRY AND DISTRICTS TIME TO
COMPLY AND RENEGOTIATE
CONTRACTS. TODAY, WE ARE
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
TITANIUM DIOXIDE, WHICH WOULD
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
DAIRY INSTITUTE. THE AG COUNCIL
AND THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL. THIS COMMON SENSE
MEASURE IS SUPPORTED BY DOCTORS,
NURSES, TEACHERS, SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND CANCER
PREVENTION ORGANIZATIONS. IT IS
SPONSORED BY THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND, AND
SUPPORTED BY THE LA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, CTA, CFT,
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS, AND MORE
THAN 70 OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. I'M
VERY PLEASED TODAY TO HAVE WITH
ME HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. DOCTOR JULIANNA MELLO,
A BOARD CERTIFIED OB-GYN AND CAT
SULTAN MURAD, A REGISTERED
DIETITIAN NUTRITIONIST AND THE
FOOD SERVICE DIRECTOR FOR
TAHOE-TRUCKEE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, WHICH HAS ALREADY
REMOVED ARTIFICIAL DYES FROM
THEIR SCHOOL FOOD. THANK YOU AND
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME, WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, DOCTOR. YOU MUST
HAVE ENJOYED IT SO MUCH LAST
TIME YOU CAME BACK. YEAH PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD BEFORE YOU SPEAK AND FIRE
WHEN READY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2316. MY NAME
IS DOCTOR JULIANA MELO. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF. I
AM BOTH A PHYSICIAN AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, A MOTHER. I HAVE
TWO YOUNG SONS, ONE WHO JUST
FINISHED FIRST GRADE RIGHT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED AND
ONE WHO'S A PRESCHOOLER. AS A
MOTHER, I TAKE GREAT CARE TO
ENSURE MY KIDS HAVE ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS FOODS THAT SUPPORT
THEIR WELLBEING AND DEVELOPMENT,
BOTH PHYSICALLY AND MENTALLY. IN
OUR HOME, WE WORK HARD TO AVOID
FOODS THAT DON'T OFFER
NUTRITIOUS VALUE AND HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO CAUSE HARM. THIS IS WHY
I'M SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY. THE
OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES ARE MAKING
IT HARDER FOR SOME OF OUR KIDS
TO LEARN. OAN HAS UNPRECEDENTED
SYSTEMATIC, PEER REVIEWED
ASSESSMENT, LOOKED AT HUMAN
EVIDENCE OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
KIDS EAT DYES, ANIMAL STUDIES OF
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEIR BRAINS AND
BEHAVIOR, AND ALL AVAILABLE
EVIDENCE, INCLUDING HOW DYES
INTERACT WITH THE BRAIN AND
BRAIN, SIGNALS THAT AFFECT
BEHAVIOR. CALIFORNIA STATE
SCIENTISTS CONCLUSIVELY
DETERMINED THAT SOME KIDS SUFFER
FROM BEHAVIORAL EFFECTS AFTER
CONSUMING SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES.
THE TOXICOLOGICAL STUDIES THAT
THE FDA RELIED UPON TO REVIEW
THESE DYES AND ESTABLISH
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS IN THE 1960S,
70S, AND 80S WERE NOT CAPABLE OF
DETECTING THEIR EFFECTS ON
BEHAVIOR. IN OUR KIDS BRAINS.
HOWEVER, COMBINED CLINICAL
STUDIES OF KIDS BEHAVIOR AND
MODERN ANIMAL STUDIES TO
CONCLUDE THAT THESE DYES CAN
CAUSE NEURAL BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS
IN SOME CHILDREN. DESPITE HIS
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT THAT
FDA HAS NO PLANS TO RECONSIDER
THE SAFETY OF SYNTHETIC FOOD
DYES AND IS NOT REQUIRED TO DO
SO, THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA TO ACT.
NOW, LET'S DO WHAT CALIFORNIA
STATE SCIENTISTS SAY IS BEST FOR
OUR KIDS, PARENTS, AND TEACHERS
AND END THE USE OF UNNECESSARY
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN FOODS OFFERED
AT SCHOOL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AGAIN. YES, MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION FOR THIS
BILL, I AM A REGISTERED
DIETITIAN AND SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE DIRECTOR WITH 22 YEARS
IN SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS,
WITH THE LAST 13 YEARS AT TAHOE
TRUCKEE UNIFIED. WE ARE, WE
SERVE 4100 STUDENTS ACROSS 12
SCHOOLS AND ACROSS 723 MILES
COVERING PLACER, NEVADA AND EL
DORADO COUNTIES, AT TAHOE
TRUCKEE SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE 13
YEARS AGO, WE RID OUR SCHOOL
MEAL PROGRAMS AND ANY
COMPETITIVE FOODS OF DYES AND
COLORS AND OTHER ARTIFICIAL
INGREDIENTS THAT WE KNOW ARE
HARMFUL TO CHILDREN. WE HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED ANY NEGATIVE FISCAL
IMPACT ON OUR PROGRAMS.
PARTICIPATION HAS NOT DECLINED
TO THE CONTRARY, AND VERY
THANKFUL TO FREE MEALS FOR ALL
STUDENTS. WE SEE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION ALMOST RISE
THREEFOLD IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
FOR OUR DISTRICT, IN TERMS OF
SCHOOL NUTRITION LEADERS, WE ARE
TASKED WITH PROVIDING NUTRITIOUS
MEALS WITH WHOLESOME, FRESH
MEALS FOR STUDENTS, THAT STRIVE
TO ACHIEVE ACADEMIC LEARNING
FOCUS AND ATTENDANCE FOR
STUDENTS EVERY DAY THROUGHOUT A
CHILD'S K-12 JOURNEY, THEY LEARN
ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF EATING A
WHOLESOME DIET THROUGHOUT THE
DAY, HOW TO READ NUTRITION
LABELS, HOW TO LOOK WITHIN
INGREDIENTS, AND HOW IT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IMPACTS THEIR
HEALTH, NOT JUST NOW AND IN THE
FUTURE. MODELING AND OFFERING
WHAT'S BEST FOR CHILDREN ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY IS IMPORTANT FOR
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT. WHAT WE
OFFER IN THE CAFETERIA IS AN
EXTENSION OF THE CLASSROOM. WE
ARE DEFINITELY A LEARNING LAB.
THOSE 12 15 MINUTES THAT
STUDENTS COME IN, WE OFFER THEM
HEALTHY CHOICES AND THEY WALK
AWAY READY TO LEARN.
COMPARATIVELY, ONLY 3% OF US
MEALS. INGREDIENTS FOUND IN
SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS CONTAIN
THESE DYES. ONLY 4% OF 11,000
INGREDIENTS PROVIDED ON THE
TRAY. OUTSIDE OF THE COMPETITIVE
MEAL PROGRAM HAD THESE DYES.
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVES
AVAILABLE. WE PROVIDE THAT AT
TAHOE TRUCKEE UNIFIED. THERE ARE
MANY OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS,
BOTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE NATION THAT HAVE BEEN
DYE FREE. NEW YORK PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE EXAMPLES SINCE THE
60S HAVE BEEN DYE FREE WITH
ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS REMOVED FROM
ALL OF THEIR MEAL PROGRAMS. THEY
SERVE ABOUT A MILLION CHILDREN
EVERY DAY. I'M ALSO A MOTHER TO
A WONDERFUL EIGHT YEAR OLD
AUTISTIC BOY WHO HAS
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS AND
STRUGGLES INTELLECTUALLY, HE WAS
NONVERBAL UNTIL AGE FIVE, AND
WITH HIS INTELLECTUAL DELAYS, HE
DEFINITELY HAS BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES. WE AVOID THESE DYES
AT HOME. WE I SEE A DIRECT
IMPACT WHEN HE GETS HIS HAND ON
CERTAIN FOOD ITEMS THAT DO HAVE
THESE DYES IN THEM, ESPECIALLY
HE HAS A VERY LIMITED DIET DUE
TO FOOD. INSENSITIVITIES, IN
ADDITION TO OUR WELLNESS POLICY
AT TUSD, WE SUPPORT NOT USING
ANY OF THESE FOODS FOR REWARDS,
ESPECIALLY DURING THE SCHOOL DAY
AND FOR ANY TYPE OF FUNDRAISING.
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND YOUR EFFORTS TO HEAR OUR
TESTIMONY, AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT AB 2316. THANK YOU.
WELL, WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND THE FACT THAT YOU CAME TO
TESTIFY. SO THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY PLEASE. MR. CHAIR.
BRANDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BRIAN
SPENCER WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP CO-SPONSORS
MEASURE AND SUPPORT. IF YOU
DON'T MIND A COUPLE
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ASKED ME TO
ALSO REGISTER SUPPORT AS WELL.
CLEAN, CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS.
ORG, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE. EQUAL ACCESS TO
SUSTAINABILITY, PEEPS NORTH
COUNTY CLIMATE CHANGE ALLIANCE,
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH TRUST
FACTS, FAMILY ADVOCATING FOR
CHEMICAL AND TOXIC SAFETY, CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. YES, SIR. GOOD MORNING
MATT LAZIO WITH SEIU IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR. NEXT. HELLO SAM.
NATIONAL, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, CHRIS AND
ZEALOT. I'M WITH EAT REAL AND
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
CHRIS MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD TO SEE
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS KAI COOPER, ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MA'AM. NOW LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU
FEEL FREE TO COME DOWN TO THE
TABLE. THANK YOU SIR. JUST
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
AND PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU, CHAIRMAN ROTH, I'M HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE CONSUMER
BRANDS ASSOCIATION. I'M DOCTOR
JAMES COUGHLIN, A PHD IN
NUTRITIONAL TOXICOLOGY, I
RECEIVED MY MASTER'S IN FOOD
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY, MY PHD
IN AGRICULTURAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CHEMISTRY, AND
POST-DOCTORAL TRAINING IN
ENVIRONMENTAL TOXICOLOGY, RIGHT
DOWN THE INTERSTATE THERE AT UC
DAVIS IN THE 70S. I'M ALSO A
RESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY. FOR
THE PAST 33 YEARS, I'VE BEEN
ENGAGED SPECIFICALLY IN THESE
COLOR RELATED ACTIVITIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SINCE THE
LEGISLATURE FIRST FUNDED THE
RISK ASSESSMENT AND REVIEW, I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW THE
SEPTEMBER 2019, TWO DAY
SYMPOSIUM, AND I'VE ALSO
REVIEWED THE REPORT FROM 2021
AND THE SUBSEQUENT REVIEW PAPER
THAT MILLER PUBLISHED IN 2022,
WITH MY EXPERIENCE AROUND THE
WORLD, I'M ALSO VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE EVALUATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN PERFORMED OVER MANY DECADES
BY VARIOUS NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL BODIES. US FDA,
JECFA, THE EUROPEAN FOOD SAFETY
AUTHORITY HAVE DONE EVALUATIONS
OVER MANY YEARS, AND THEY HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THERE IS NO
CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP. AND I WANT
TO MAKE A STRONG POINT OF THAT.
THERE IS NO CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP
THAT'S BEEN ESTABLISHED BETWEEN
DIETARY EXPOSURE TO THESE COLORS
AND ANY HEALTH CONCERNS FOR
CHILDREN AND OTHER AGE GROUPS.
IN ADDITION, THESE OTHER
AGENCIES I'M TALKING ABOUT HAVE
DECIDED NOT TO INSTITUTE RISK
MANAGEMENT POLICIES. THEY DIDN'T
THINK THEY WERE WARRANTED, I DO
DISAGREE WITH HIS REPORT AND THE
MILLER SUBSEQUENT REPORT THAT
WAS PUBLISHED IN 2022. THEIR
CONCLUSIONS THAT THESE
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE BEEN OBSERVED
IN STUDIES THAT THEY REVIEWED, I
DON'T BELIEVE THEY ARE EVIDENCE
OF A CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE COLORS AND ADVERSE
NEUROBEHAVIORAL EFFECTS. THE
CONCLUSIONS OF BOTH REPORTS, SAY
THAT AN ASSOCIATION NOT
CAUSALITY, MAY EXIST, BUT I
BELIEVE THIS IS BASED ON
INSUFFICIENT SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE. EVEN THE TITLES OF
BOTH REPORTS, THE MILLER REPORT
AND THE OHIO REPORT, THE FIRST
WORD IN THE TITLES OF THE
REPORTS ARE POTENTIAL EFFECTS.
AND WE DON'T USUALLY IN THE IN
MY WORLD OF FOOD SAFETY, TAKE
STRONG ACTIONS AGAINST CHEMICALS
WHERE WE ONLY BELIEVE THERE ARE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS. SO THE
DISCREPANCIES THAT I'VE LOOKED
AT IN OHA'S REPORT AND IN
MILLER'S CONCLUSIONS, AND THOSE
OF EXPERT FOOD SAFETY BODIES
AROUND THE WORLD, RAISE SERIOUS
QUESTIONS TO ME ABOUT THE
VALIDITY AND MERIT OF OHA
INVESTIGATIONS, ASSESSMENT AND
CONCLUSIONS. LET ME MENTION JUST
A COUPLE OF THESE, SEVERE
LIMITATIONS THAT I CONSIDER THAT
ARE SEVERE LIMITATIONS. MILLER,
REVIEWED, 25 RANDOMIZED
CONTROLLED TRIALS THAT EXAMINED
THE EFFECTS OF COLORS ON VARIOUS
NEUROBEHAVIORAL OUTCOMES. AGAIN,
THESE STUDIES PROVIDED NO
CONCLUSIVE EVIDENCE THAT ANY OF
THE COLORS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
CAUSE THESE ADVERSE
NEUROBEHAVIORAL EFFECTS. IN
ADDITION, THE STUDIES PROVIDED
NO SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE THAT
ELIMINATING THESE COLORS FROM
THE DIETS OF CHILDREN WOULD HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL MEANS OF REDUCING
OR ELIMINATED THE OBSERVED
EFFECTS, AND IN FACT, THE MILLER
REVIEW PAPER, WHICH WAS SEVEN OF
THE AUTHORS WHO WERE SEVEN OF
THE 15 AUTHORS OF THE OHIO
REPORT, THEY DID NOT CONCLUDE
THAT THESE SYNTHETIC COLORS
SHOULD BE BANNED, FOR
CONSUMPTION BY CHILDREN. AND,
THE LAST SENTENCE IN THEIR
ABSTRACT, A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF EVERY PUBLISHED PAPER IS THE
ABSTRACT QUOTE. THERE IS A NEED
TO REEVALUATE EXPOSURE IN
CHILDREN, AND FOR ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH TO PROVIDE A MORE
COMPLETE DATABASE FOR
ESTABLISHING ADIS PROTECTIVE OF
NEUROBEHAVIORAL EFFECTS. END
QUOTE. SO THE RESULTS SUMMARIZED
IN THESE TWO REPORTS, I'VE
LOOKED AT ALL OF THEM. THEY DO
NOT DEMONSTRATE ANY LARGE
MAGNITUDE EFFECTS. THE STUDIES,
MOST OF THEM WERE SMALL IN
NATURE. THERE WAS INCONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STUDIES AND VERY
IMPORTANT TO US IN IN THE WORLD
OF TOXICOLOGY IS THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A DOSE RESPONSE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
CHEMICALS INCREASING THE DOSE
AND INCREASING THE EFFECTS. SO
FINALLY, CONSIDERING THE MANY
LIMITATIONS THAT AND THE
INFLUENCE OF MANY CONFOUNDING
FACTORS ON THE HEALTH OUTCOMES
THAT WERE REVIEWED IN BOTH
REPORTS, I BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
SCIENTIFICALLY UNFOUNDED. AND
UNNECESSARY TO CONSIDER BANNING
THESE SYNTHETIC COLORS IN FOODS
AND BEVERAGES DESTINED FOR,
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL KIDS, MAINLY
BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO BE BASED ON
INSUFFICIENT SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
OF A CAUSATIVE RELATIONSHIP.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. IT'S
IMPORTANT ISSUE. YES SIR. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM
WRIGLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. WE'RE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2316. WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT AND THE AUTHOR FOR,
STRIKING TITANIUM DIOXIDE FROM
THE BILL. REGRETTABLY, WE STILL
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL, WE, AS NOTED BY DOCTOR
COUGHLIN, WE DON'T AGREE WITH
THE SCIENCE THAT SUPPORTS
CIRCUMVENTING FDA TO PASS BANS
ON THESE COLORS, OUR MEMBERS
TAKE VERY STRONG PRIDE IN MAKING
SURE OUR PRODUCTS TASTE GOOD,
LOOK GOOD, AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
MEET CALIFORNIA'S STRINGENT
NUTRITIONAL STANDARDS. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS, OUR FOOD
PRODUCERS SPEND A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME AND RESOURCES
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE TO DICTATE HOW
PRODUCTS ARE MADE. THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS TROUBLING FOR US,
BECAUSE, AS CITED, THE OHA
RELIES ON 27 STUDIES, 24 OF
WHICH ARE NOW 30 YEARS OR OLDER,
TO COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
CERTAIN DYES MAY BE EXACERBATING
HYPERACTIVITY IN YOUNG CHILDREN.
THE FDA, FOR EXAMPLE, CONTRASTS
THAT BY REVIEWING 33 STUDIES,
SOME OF WHICH ARE NOTABLY
OVERLAPPED WITH THE OHA REPORT,
AND THEY CONCLUDE THE EXACT
OPPOSITE THAT THERE IS NO CAUSAL
RELATIONSHIP AS DOCTOR COUGHLIN
ARTICULATED, BETWEEN ARTIFICIAL
FOOD COLORS AND ADVERSE
NEUROBEHAVIORAL EFFECTS IN
CHILDREN. FURTHER, THE 2021
GENTRY STUDY FOUND THAT
AVAILABLE ANIMAL AND MECHANISTIC
STUDIES THAT OHA RELY UPON LACK
CONSISTENT EVIDENCE OF
NEUROLOGIC NEUROBEHAVIORAL
EFFECTS, AND THEY CONCLUDE,
QUOTE, THE EVIDENCE IS
INSUFFICIENT FOR A
NEUROBEHAVIORAL QUANTITATIVE
RISK ASSESSMENT. IN OTHER WORDS,
THE EVIDENCE LACKS THE STRENGTH
TO BE RELIED UPON FOR
NEUROBEHAVIORAL QUANTITATIVE
RISK ASSESSMENT. END QUOTE.
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL
DISAGREEMENT AMONG SCIENTIFIC
OPINIONS ON WHETHER THESE COLORS
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON HYPERACTIVITY
IN CHILDREN. NEVERTHELESS EVEN
IF YOU TAKE A PRECAUTIONARY
PRINCIPLE AND ADOPT A DÍAS
PERSPECTIVE, THIS BILL STILL
EXCEEDS THE OWNS THE SCIENCE
THAT OHA RELIES UPON. FOR
EXAMPLE, NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THE
STUDIES OHA RELIES UPON TESTS
CHILDREN OVER THE AGE OF 15. AND
YET THIS BILL APPLIES ALL THE
WAY THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL. THE
HARLEY STUDY FROM 1978. THEY
LOOK AT THREE THROUGH 12 YEAR
OLDS, POLLOCK AND WARNER, 1992
THROUGH 15 YEAR OLDS. MCCANN,
2007 THROUGH ONLY THREE YEAR
OLDS AND EIGHT AND NINE YEAR
OLDS WERE STUDIED. ROW AND ROW.
1994. GOYETTE 1978 STEVENSON
2010. ALL ONLY LOOKED AT YOUNG
CHILDREN, SO WHILE WE STRONGLY
DISAGREE WITH ANY POLICY BANNING
THESE FDA APPROVED COLORS AND
URGE A NO VOTE TODAY, WE MUST
EMPHASIZE THAT AB 2316 SHOULD AT
THE VERY LEAST, BE FURTHER
AMENDED TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE VERY SCIENCE THAT OHA AND
THE SPONSORS AND THE AUTHORS ARE
RELYING UPON. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS, I'M COMING IN
OUT OF ORDER. I'M ACTUALLY IN
THE SUPPORT CATEGORY OFFICE OF
CAT TAYLOR AND FOOD SAFE, LLC. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
INDULGENCE. THANK YOU. NO
PROBLEM. NEXT, PLEASE. THANK
YOU. DENNIS ALBIANI WITH THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION.
WE CONTINUE TO OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. PETER KELLY, ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL CONFECTIONERS
ASSOCIATION, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, MARGIE LEE, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, ROB
SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, WE BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES, ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS?
THEN I'LL SAY SOMETHING. YOU
KNOW, I'M I APPRECIATE ALL THE
TESTIMONY, PARTICULARLY THOSE OF
YOU AT THE TABLE HERE. I'M AWARE
OF THE STATE OF THE SCIENCE AND
THE SCIENTIFIC STUDIES AND THE
FACT THAT WE SEEM TO BE ON THE
SIDELINES WATCHING A BATTLE OF
THE SCIENTIFIC STUDIES. I AM
CONCERNED, AND WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE, HAVE APPRECIATED
HAVING MORE CERTAINTY IN THE
SCIENTIFIC RESULTS, YOU KNOW,
PRESENTED, BUT I'M ALSO ACUTELY
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HAPPENS AT
HOME UNDER PARENTAL SUPERVISION
OR WHAT HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL SETTING. WE'RE TALKING
HERE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS INSIDE
OF OUR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS, WHERE
WE REQUIRE GENERALLY IN ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER, KIDS TO ATTEND AND
WHERE WE PROVIDE FOOD PRODUCTS
TO KIDS WHILE THEY ARE IN THIS
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT,
GENERALLY OUTSIDE THE
SUPERVISION OF THEIR PARENTS OR
ANY OF THE REST OF US, OTHER
THAN THE TEACHERS AND THE
HARDWORKING AIDES AND OTHER
PROFESSIONAL STAFF THAT WORK IN
THE SCHOOL SETTINGS. AND I THINK
IN THAT, IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE, I
THINK AS LEGISLATORS, WE NEED TO
PAY PARTICULAR ATTENTION AND
EVEN BE MORE CAREFUL THAN WE
WOULD NORMALLY BE WHERE THERE IS
ANY SUGGESTION THAT FOOD
PRODUCTS PROVIDED TO YOUNG
PEOPLE IN SCHOOL SETTINGS MAY
HAVE AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON THEM.
AND SO WHILE I HAD THERE BEEN A
LITTLE BIT MORE CERTAINTY, I
MIGHT HAVE BEEN INCLINED TO TAKE
A DIFFERENT POSITION. I'M JUST
NOT IN A POSITION TO GUESS WRONG.
AND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE TODAY AND WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE GET A QUORUM AND
WE TAKE A MOTION. BUT WITH ALL
OF THAT, ASSEMBLYMEMBER, I
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW, WHAT I
THINK OF YOUR HARD WORK AND YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM. SO I'LL LET YOU
CLOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR AND I TOO HAVE,
REALLY ENJOYED THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS AND THE THOUGHT
PROVOKING CONVERSATIONS AND
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT IN WHICH
YOU'VE APPROACHED THIS. IF YOU
MIGHT INDULGE ME, I JUST WANT TO
SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT THE OHA
REPORT SINCE, SINCE THE
OPPOSITION TALKED ABOUT THAT,
AND THEN MAYBE JUST MAKE A
BROADER POINT THAT I THINK IS
WORTH WORTH NOTING. SO HERE'S
WHAT THE OHA REPORT SAID. THIS
IS WHAT OHA SAYS ABOUT ITS OWN
REPORT, SAYS THIS REPORT IS THE
PRODUCT OF A TWO YEAR,
MULTIFACETED EVALUATION OF SEVEN
SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE FDA. OHA
EXTENSIVELY REVIEWED EXISTING
STUDIES ON THE EFFECTS OF THESE
DYES IN BOTH HUMANS AND
LABORATORY ANIMALS. IT GOES ON
TO TALK ABOUT ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY COLLECTED
FROM THE HUMAN STUDIES. AND IT
SAYS THESE STUDIES DEMONSTRATE
CLEARLY THAT SOME CHILDREN ARE
LIKELY TO BE MORE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES
THAN OTHERS. ANIMAL STUDIES
INDICATE SYNTHETIC FOOD DYES
AFFECT ACTIVITY, MEMORY, AND
LEARNING, CAUSE CHANGES IN THE
NEUROTRANSMITTERS IN THE BRAIN,
AND CAUSE MICROSCOPIC CHANGES IN
BRAIN STRUCTURE. THEN THEN GO ON
TO TALK ABOUT HOW, IN PREPARING
THIS, THEY COLLABORATED WITH
SCIENTISTS AT UC BERKELEY AND UC
DAVIS THAT THEY ACTUALLY INVITED
THE PUBLIC TO SUBMIT INFORMATION
ON THIS, THAT THEY CONDUCTED A
SYMPOSIUM TO HAVE DISCUSSION
FROM RESEARCHERS, ACADEMIA AND
INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT. SO THEY
ACTUALLY INVITED INDUSTRY TO BE
COLLABORATORS THERE. AND THEN
THEY TOOK A DRAFT VERSION OF THE
REPORT, AND THEY RELEASED IT FOR
COMMENT BY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. AND THEY ALSO HAD
EXTERNAL PEER REVIEW BY EXPERTS
IDENTIFIED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. SO WHAT I WHAT I SEE
FROM OHA HERE IS A VERY
THOROUGH, VERY PATIENT, VERY
EXTENSIVE, VERY COMPREHENSIVE
SURVEY OF THE SCIENTIFIC
LITERATURE AND THE SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH. IT'S NOT SURPRISING TO
ME THAT THE OPPOSITION COULD
FIND MAYBE 1 OR 2 PEOPLE THAT
WOULD COME UP HERE AND CONTEST
THAT SCIENCE, BUT I THINK WHAT
YOU SEE FROM OHA IS FOR THEM,
IT'S A SETTLED QUESTION. THEY
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE AND VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE RESEARCH
AND THE EVIDENCE DEMONSTRATES TO
US HERE TODAY. THE ADDITIONAL
DATA POINTED OUT TO THAT IS THAT
OTHER, OTHER JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ALREADY REACHED THE SAME RESULT.
THIS IS A LIGHTER TOUCH APPROACH
THAN THEY HAVE IN EUROPE. IN
EUROPE, THEY HAVE EITHER BANNED
THESE FOOD DYES ENTIRELY FROM
ANY FOODS THAT ARE ALLOWED TO BE
SOLD IN COMMERCE, OR THEY HAVE
REQUIRED MANUFACTURERS TO PUT A
LABEL ON THE PRODUCT THAT SAYS
WARNING THIS CAN HARM YOUR KIDS.
THAT'S LITERALLY WHAT IS
REQUIRED FROM THAT. SO I THINK
TO ME, THIS IS A VERY, VERY
LIGHT TOUCH APPROACH. I THINK
THE BURDEN ON INDUSTRY AT THIS
POINT IS I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE BURDEN MIGHT BE. WE'RE
GIVING THEM MORE THAN THREE
YEARS TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
HERE. THERE'S NO DISPUTE HERE
THAT THERE IS LESS THAN 5% OF
THE FOOD SERVED IN OUR SCHOOLS.
HAVE ANY OF THESE DYES? THEY ARE
NONESSENTIAL INGREDIENTS. THEY
ARE NOT REQUIRED FOR ANY
PRODUCTS. YOU'VE HEARD THAT
MAJOR URBAN DISTRICTS LIKE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED HAVE DONE THIS.
RURAL DISTRICTS LIKE TAHOE
TRUCKEE HAVE DONE THIS. SO I
THINK THIS IS WELL WITHIN OUR
ABILITY TO DO. AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU SAID HERE, SENATOR,
THAT, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE'RE FACED
WITH SOME, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE'RE
FACED WITH SOME CHOICES TO COME
DOWN ON THE SIDE OF PROTECTING
KIDS IS THE RIGHT WAY TO GO. IF
IT MAKES YOU FEEL BETTER. LAST
YEAR, AS YOU REMEMBER, WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD SAFETY ACT,
WHERE CALIFORNIA BECAME THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO BAN
FOUR CHEMICALS TO GET AHEAD OF
THE FDA. AND WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION WITH WITH A LOT OF
THE SAME OPPOSITION WHO CAME IN
AND MADE THE SAME ARGUMENTS. THE
SCIENCE IS MIXED. THE EVIDENCE
IS MIXED. MAYBE, MAYBE WE
SHOULDN'T BE DOING THIS. WE
SHOULD RELY ON THE FDA. I'M
PROUD TO REPORT THAT SINCE WE
PASSED THAT BILL AND ACTUALLY
JUST EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE FDA
ANNOUNCED THAT BROMINATED
VEGETABLE OIL BVO, ONE OF THE
CHEMICALS IN THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
SAFETY ACT, WILL NO LONGER BE
ALLOWED TO BE USED IN FOODS SOLD
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND I'M VERY CONFIDENT, AND I
UNDERSTAND FROM PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. IT IS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA TOOK THAT ACTION THAT
THE FDA FELT COMPELLED TO STEP
UP. BUT LET ME SHARE WITH YOU
HOW FAR WE ARE BEHIND THE REST
OF THE WORLD. THE UK BANNED BVO
IN 1970, MORE THAN 50 YEARS AGO.
INDIA BANDED IN 1990. THE EU
BANNED IT IN 20, IN 2008 AND
JAPAN IN 2010. AND YET, DESPITE
ALL OF THIS, THESE VERY SAME
OPPOSITION WITNESSES CAME IN AND
REALLY MADE EXACTLY THE SAME
ARGUMENT TO US. THE SCIENCES
MAKE THE DATA IS MIXED. LET THE
FDA DO ITS THING, AND IT'S ONLY
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE AND DID THAT, THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO PUT THAT PRESSURE
ON THE FDA TO ULTIMATELY REACH
THE CONCLUSION AND BRING US INTO
LINE WITH THE REST OF THE WORLD
AS AS YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT, FOR REASONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHOCKING TO ME, THE UNITED
STATES IS REALLY A GLOBAL
OUTLIER. AND I WILL I WILL
CONCLUDE BY BY SORT OF, YOU
KNOW, THINKING ABOUT THE
TESTIMONY OF THESE TWO
WITNESSES, I APPROACHED THIS
FIRST AND FOREMOST AS A PARENT,
AS THE FATHER OF THREE YOUNG
KIDS, OF A FOUR YEAR OLD, A SIX
YEAR OLD, AND AN EIGHT YEAR OLD,
I HAD ALWAYS ASSUMED THAT THERE
WAS SOMEONE IN WASHINGTON, D.C,
WATCHING OUR BACK THAT WAS
PROTECTING MY KIDS, AND IT WAS
FRANKLY SHOCKING FOR ME TO
UNCOVER HOW FAR BEHIND THE REST
OF THE WORLD THE UNITED STATES
IS WHEN IT COMES TO FOOD SAFETY.
AND FOR ME, THIS IS A SETTLED
QUESTION. THERE'S BEEN BACK AND
FORTH, AND THAT'S THE REASON THE
LEGISLATURE PUT MONEY IN THE
BUDGET AND SAID, LET'S ASK
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE AN
ECONOMIC INTEREST IN THIS, WHO
DON'T HAVE A DOG IN THE FIGHT.
YOU GUYS TAKE A LOOK AT IT. AND
THAT'S WHAT THE EXPERTS AT THE
èC DID. THAT'S WHAT THE FOLKS
AT OHA DID. AND I THINK THEY
LEFT US WITH A VERY, VERY CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HARMS HERE
TO OUR KIDS AND SO ON BEHALF OF
OUR KIDS WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, AS SOON AS WE
GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE WILL TAKE A VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING. THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US AND FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. EXCELLENT JOB. NEXT
ITEM, ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB
2115. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY.
THANK YOU, SIR, FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, AS WE KNOW, WE. OPIOID
OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC. OVER 11,000
PEOPLE A YEAR TO DRUG OVERDOSE,
THANKFULLY, THERE'S A TREATMENT
FOR ADDICTION TO OPIOIDS, WHICH
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING MOST
OF THOSE LIVES. A METHADONE IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE, PROVEN
TREATMENT FOR PEOPLE WITH OPIOID
ADDICTION. IT HELPS THEM CHANGE
THEIR LIVES AND TRANSITION TO
SOBRIETY AND NORMALCY. IT WORKS
BY EASING THE DEBILITATING
SYMPTOMS OF OPIOID WITHDRAWAL
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE WHO WANT TO
QUIT DRUGS LIKE HEROIN AND
FENTANYL. IT ALSO REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF DYING OF AN OPIOID
OVERDOSE BY MORE THAN 50. YET
FEWER THAN 1 IN 10 PEOPLE IN THE
U.S. WHO, WITH OPIOID ADDICTION
ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN THE
TREATMENT. AND AS I SAID,
THOUSANDS ARE DYING EACH YEAR
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RELAXED
MANY METHADONE RESTRICTIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD GET MORE
PEOPLE ONTO METHADONE AND OFF OF
THESE DEADLY DRUGS AND INCREASE
PATIENT ACCESS. IN APRIL OF
2024, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
RECOGNIZING THAT REDUCING
TREATMENT BARRIERS SAVES LIVES,
ADOPTED THE COVID 19 RULES AND
MADE THEM PERMANENT. HOWEVER,
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HAVE
OUTDATED METHADONE POLICIES THAT
ARE MORE RESTRICTIVE THAN
FEDERAL REGULATIONS AND ARE
ACTUALLY MORE RESTRICTED
RESTRICTIVE THAN MOST STATES IN
THE COUNTRY. AS A RESULT, MANY
PEOPLE CANNOT ACCESS METHADONE
WHO NEED TO THESE INTENSE
REQUIREMENTS, LIKE STANDING IN
LINE EVERY DAY TO RECEIVE A
SINGLE DOSE OF METHADONE OFTEN
DISSUADE PATIENTS FROM PURSUING
CARE. THEY HAVE TO SPEND FAR TOO
MUCH TIME GETTING ENROLLED AND
STAYING ENROLLED THAT THAT OTHER
ASPECTS OF THEIR RECOVERY, LIKE
FINDING A JOB AND STABLE
HOUSING, IS INTERRUPTED. I'LL
ALSO SAY THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN URBAN
AREAS, PARTICULARLY IN MY CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO, IS PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TO LINE UP EVERY DAY FOR
METHADONE AND THE RESULT IS THAT
DRUG DEALERS OFTEN PREY ON THEM
BY SURROUNDING THOSE CLINICS AND
TRYING TO GET THEM BACK ONTO
THESE ILLEGAL DRUGS IN ORDER TO
CONFRONT THIS OPIOID EPIDEMIC,
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE ONTO
MEDICATIONS THAT CAN SAVE THEIR
LIVES. THAT CAN HELP THEM.
METHADONE IS THE BEST WAY TO DO
THAT. AND BY MAKING SURE THAT
PATIENTS CAN EASILY ACCESS
TREATMENT AND REMOVE AMBIGUITY,
WE WILL PREVENT UNNECESSARY
DEATHS AND WE WILL HELP MANY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS DOCTOR
JEFFREY HARM FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND DOCTOR LESLIE SWAIN,
AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD BEFORE PROCEEDING.
PROCEED WHEN READY. ALL RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR ROTH. VICE
CHAIR NGUYEN, MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE, THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2115. MY NAME IS
JEFFREY HARM, AND I'M A SENIOR
PHYSICIAN IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH, WHERE I HELP
LEAD OUR OVERDOSE PREVENTION
EFFORTS. AS YOU KNOW, OVERDOSES
REMAIN A PROFOUND PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS NATIONALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA. DURING THE FIRST
FOUR HOURS OF THIS HEARING
ALONE, FIVE MORE CALIFORNIANS
WILL DIE OF AN OVERDOSE, WHILE
DEATHS ARE OFTEN THE MOST
HIGHLIGHTED MANIFESTATION OF OUR
OVERDOSE CRISIS, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE
WITH AND OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH,
OPIOID USE DISORDER.
FORTUNATELY, LIKE OTHER CHRONIC
ILLNESSES, OPIOID USE DISORDER
CAN BE EFFECTIVELY TREATED WITH
MEDICATIONS. METHADONE IS THE
MOST WELL-STUDIED OF THESE AND
REDUCES THE RISK OF DYING BY 50.
DESPITE THIS, FEWER THAN 5% OF
THE NEARLY 1 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH OPIOID USE
DISORDER RECEIVE TREATMENT WITH
METHADONE. WE MUST INCREASE
ACCESS IF WE TO TURN THIS CRISIS
AROUND AND SAVE LIVES. AB 2115
WILL HELP DO THIS. THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW FOR CLINICIANS TO
PROVIDE 72 HOURS OF METHADONE TO
PATIENTS TO TREAT ACUTE
WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS, WHILE
REFERRING THEM TO AN OPIOID
TREATMENT PROGRAM. AB 2115
SIMPLY ALIGNS OUTDATED
CALIFORNIA LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW,
WHICH WAS RECENTLY UPDATED TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH
OPIOID USE DISORDER. OTHER
JURISDICTIONS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED THIS FEDERAL LAW. IT
IS NOT UNTESTED, BUT INSTEAD HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE AN EFFECTIVE
WAY TO GET PATIENTS. THIS LIFE
SAVING MEDICATION AS A BRIDGE TO
AN OPIOID TREATMENT PROGRAM.
THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO.
AS A PHYSICIAN, I HAVE SEEN THE
TRAGIC HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF
SEVERE OPIOID USE DISORDER, BUT
I'VE ALSO SEEN HOW WELL PEOPLE
DO WHEN GIVEN THE RIGHT
SUPPORTS. RECOVERY IS POSSIBLE,
BUT WE MUST ENSURE PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO START THIS
MEDICATION. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
AB 2115. THANK YOU. AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
LATER. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
ESTEEMED CHAIR ROTH, VICE CHAIR
NGUYEN AND ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS DOCTOR LESLIE
SWEN. I'M AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR
OF MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO. I AM
AN ADDICTION MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
AND PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR
PROVIDING SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT IN SAN FRANCISCO. AND
I ALSO WORK AS A HEALTH SERVICES
RESEARCHER AND POLICY IN
ADDICTION POLICY AT UCSF. I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2115.
METHADONE IS OUR NATION'S OLDEST
MEDICATION FOR OPIOID USE
DISORDER, WITH OVER FIVE DECADES
OF EVIDENCE SHOWING REDUCTION IN
DEATHS, DRUG USE, CRIME AND
IMPROVING RATES OF RECOVERY.
METHADONE IS ALSO THE MOST
HIGHLY REGULATED MEDICATION IN
OUR COUNTRY. IN FACT, CALIFORNIA
IS THE MOST RESTRICTIVE STATE,
ONE OF THE MOST RESTRICTIVE
STATES WHEN IT COMES TO
METHADONE REGULATION. MANY
PATIENTS HAVE ACTUALLY NICKNAMED
METHADONE LIQUID HANDCUFFS
BECAUSE OF HOW DISRUPTIVE BEING
ON METHADONE IS TO THEIR DAILY
LIVES. FOR EXAMPLE, UNDER
CURRENT STATE CALIFORNIA
REGULATIONS, PATIENTS ENROLLED
IN METHADONE ARE REQUIRED TO
VISIT THE CLINIC EVERY DAY FOR
MONTHS TO BE OBSERVED WHILE
TAKING THEIR MEDICATION, OFTEN
COMMUTING SEVERAL HOURS EACH
WAY. DURING THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
LOOSENED RESTRICTIONS TO ALLOW
PATIENTS TO SHELTER IN PLACE AT
HOME. THIS INCLUDED PATIENTS
ALLOWING THEM TO RECEIVE DOSES
OF METHADONE THAT THEY COULD
TAKE HOME, INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
COME TO THE CLINIC EVERY DAY.
RESEARCH FROM OUR TOP NATIONAL
AGENCIES, INCLUDING THE CDC AND
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF
HEALTH, HAVE REVEALED THAT WITH
LOOSENING RESTRICTIONS, PATIENTS
WERE MORE LIKELY TO BE RETAINED
IN TREATMENT AND REPORTED
IMPROVED QUALITY OF CARE WITHOUT
INCREASES OF CONCERNS AROUND
DIVERSION OR INCREASES IN
OVERDOSE FROM METHADONE. BASED
ON THESE DATA, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CODIFIED THESE
EXEMPTIONS INTO LAW EARLIER THIS
YEAR. HOWEVER, WE AS PHYSICIANS
IN CALIFORNIA STILL MUST ABIDE
BY THESE STATE RESTRICTIONS FROM
THE PRE-COVID ERA, PREVENTING
OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE UP TO
DATE CARE. IF PASSED, 2115 WOULD
CODIFY THESE NEW FEDERAL
REGULATIONS INTO CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW ALLOWING SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT PROVIDERS LIKE MYSELF
TO FOLLOW FEDERAL GUIDELINES ON
METHADONE TREATMENT AND REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING CARE.
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE MORE DOSES OF METHADONE
TO TAKE HOME WHEN THEY ENTER
TREATMENT AND OBTAIN STABILITY,
AVOIDING DISRUPTION TO OTHER
PARTS OF THE RECOVERY, LIKE
OBTAINING A JOB OR GETTING INTO
HOUSING. FURTHER, INDIVIDUALS
WILL NOT BE KICKED OUT OF
TREATMENT FOR DECLINING TO
PARTICIPATE IN COUNSELING AND AB
2115 WOULD ALSO EASE PATHWAYS
INTO ENROLLING INTO METHADONE
TREATMENT AND REDUCING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON
METHADONE CLINIC STAFF BY
UPDATING OUR STATE LAWS TO
FOLLOW FEDERAL GUIDANCE, OUR AB
2115 WOULD ALLOW US TO ADD
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT
PROVIDERS TO FOLLOW THE
EVIDENCE, REDUCE BARRIERS TO
TREATMENT, AND THEREBY ABILITY
IMPROVING OUR ABILITY TO ADDRESS
OVERDOSE DEATHS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IN OUR STATE. THANK YOU.
INVITING FOR ME TO TESTIFY. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR YES VOTE.
WELL, GOOD. LET ME DEVIATE FROM
MY NORMAL PRACTICE AND JUST ASK
A QUESTION AT THIS POINT. AND
THEN WE CAN TAKE THE OTHER
SUPPORTERS AND IN ANY
OPPOSITION, HOW WELL DO YOU
THINK WE'RE DOING IN TERMS OF
TRACKING PROCESS, IN OTHER
WORDS, MONITORING THOSE WHO
ACTUALLY CROSS THE BRIDGE TO
TREATMENT? AND WHERE WOULD I GO
TO FIND THAT TRACKING? OKAY, SO
IN OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AS
ME, AS A PHYSICIAN, EVERY TIME I
PRESCRIBE A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE, I HAVE TO I AM
REQUIRED TO CHECK OUR
PRESCRIPTION DATA MONITORING
DATABASE, ALSO KNOWN AS CURES,
CURES DATABASE KEEPS TRACK OF
ALL PRESCRIPTIONS FOR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES FROM CLINICS,
HOSPITALS, EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS, AND AS A PHYSICIAN,
I HAVE TO CHECK IT EVERY SINGLE
TIME. AND SO THE POINT OF CURES
IS TO PREVENT DIVERSION, IMPROVE
SAFETY, PREVENT ADVERSE EVENTS
FOR PATIENTS. SO THAT I AM NOT
PRESCRIBING A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE FOR SOMEONE WHO MAY
NOT, MAY NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR.
AND SO THERE ARE DATA TRACKING
SYSTEMS. I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
OUR CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENTS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ALSO TRACK DATA
STATEWIDE, ESPECIALLY AROUND
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES. SO THERE
ARE MANY LAYERS OF PROTECTION.
AND IN ADDITION, AROUND THE 72
HOUR RULE, SPECIFICALLY IN
SECTION ONE, AB 2115, THERE ARE
SPECIFIC REGULATIONS AND
HANDRAILS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE CM THE
LOT OF THE SAFETY AND THE
GUARDRAILS HAVE ALREADY BEEN PUT
IN PLACE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
SO WHEN YOU DISPENSE BECAUSE
IT'S DISPENSING RIGHT,
METHADONE, IS THAT DISPENSING
ACT ENTERED INTO CURES. YES. SO
IT WOULD BE IN, UNDER THIS BILL,
72 HOUR METHADONE BECAUSE IT'S
DISPENSED FROM HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS OR SORRY, IN CLINICS
SPECIFICALLY, IT WOULD BE
ENTERED INTO CURES. AND MY
QUESTION THEN POINTS TO WHAT
SOME WOULD CALL A WARM HANDOFF
FROM THE POINT WHERE AS A
CLINICIAN, YOU'RE DISPENSING A
72 HOUR, DOSE OR DOSES OF
METHADONE. WHAT TRACKING SHOWS
THAT YOU'VE PROVIDED, WHICH I
ASSUME IS A REQUIREMENT, A WARM
HANDOFF TO A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROVIDER. AND WHERE
WOULD I GO TO FIND THAT? AND HOW
SUCCESSFUL ARE WE DOING? THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE IN THIS BUSINESS,
HOW SUCCESSFUL ARE YOU IN
PROVIDING THE WARM HANDOFF AND
WHAT TRACKING IS THERE THAT
EXTENDS AFTER THAT TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
ACTUALLY MAKES IT TO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT, THAT THESE ARE
WONDERFUL QUESTIONS. SO THANK
YOU, CHAIR. I WILL DEFER THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION TO
DOCTOR HOM AS, ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. BUT TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION, IF I UNDERSTAND THE
QUESTION IS AROUND HOW WELL DO
WE DO WARM HANDOFFS TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT CLINICS? IS THAT
CORRECT? AND WHERE IS THAT
REPORTED? GOTCHA. SO IT IS
DOCUMENTED IN OUR MEDICAL
RECORD. WE HAVE TO DOCUMENT
FIRST THAT WE CHECK CURES. IT
ALSO IS RECORDED IN OUR MEDICAL
RECORDS OFTEN, YOU KNOW WHAT THE
RESULT OF OUR CHECK WAS? WE ALSO
DOCUMENT, OUR HANDOFFS TO OTHER
PROVIDERS. OFTENTIMES HOWEVER,
AS PEOPLE WHO WORK IN CLINICS OR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
HOSPITALS, WE WORK DURING MANY
HOURS OF THE DAY WELL INTO THE
NIGHT, AND MANY SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT CLINICS, INCLUDING
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAMS, ARE
ONLY OPEN DURING MORNINGS AND
OFTEN CLOSED BY 2 P.M. AND SO IF
WE ARE TAKING CARE OF A PATIENT
FROM THE HOURS OF 2 TO 5 P.M,
WHICH WE OFTEN DO AS REGULAR
BUSINESS HOURS, WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ACTIVELY DO A WARM
HANDOFF AND CALL THE CLINIC,
JUST DUE TO THE BUSINESS OF
NATURE OF BUSINESS HOURS, AND SO
AS YOU CAN SEE, THERE ARE MANY,
MANY BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE EVEN
ACCESSING TREATMENT, EVEN FOR
PEOPLE, FOR PROVIDERS OF MYSELF
TO EVEN DO THOSE WARM HANDOFFS.
BUT EVERYTHING THAT WE DO DO IS
REQUIRED TO BE DOCUMENTED IN THE
MEDICAL RECORD. AND IT WOULDN'T
IT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY NEED TO
BE THE ACTUAL PHYSICIAN WHO'S
DOING THE DISPENSING TO PROVIDE
THE WARM HANDOFF. IT COULD BE
SOMEONE INSIDE YOUR ORGANIZATION
WITH PERMITTED ACCESS TO THE
MEDICAL RECORD TO DO THAT,
CORRECT? THAT IS CORRECT. DOES
THAT OCCUR? YES. I MEAN, AS
DOCTOR SWAN MENTIONED HERE, THAT
AS AS REFERRALS ARE MADE AND AS
WARM HANDOFFS DO OCCUR, THAT
DOCUMENTATION DOES EXIST WITHIN
THE REFERRING PROVIDERS CHART.
SO WHERE SO. BUT THE MEDICAL
RECORDS ARE OBVIOUSLY PROTECTED
BY HIPAA. AND WE WOULDN'T NEED
TO HAVE SPECIFIC PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIED DATA TO DETERMINE THE
SUCCESS OR FAILURE OF THIS
PROGRAM. THERE OUGHT TO BE A WAY
TO TRACK FROM THE POINT OF
DISPENSING TO THE POINT OF LINK
UP WITH THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROVIDER, THE SUCCESS
OR FAILURE OF THIS PROGRAM
BECAUSE THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
STOP, START AND STOP WITH THE
DISPENSING OF THE METHADONE.
RIGHT? CORRECT SO HOW DO WE YOU
KNOW, I HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THIS, AND I WASN'T ABLE TO
ACHIEVE ANY AGREEMENT ON
LANGUAGE, BUT HOW WOULD WE DO
THIS TO DETERMINE THE SUCCESS OR
FAILURE OF THIS PROGRAM?
SHOULDN'T THERE BE SOME
REPORTING REQUIREMENT SOMEWHERE,
HOWEVER, CLEANSED OF PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE DATA, TO DETERMINE
WHEN A PHYSICIAN HAS AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO NEEDS METHADONE
FOR PURPOSES OF BREAKING THE,
YOU KNOW, LINK AND MOVING
TOWARDS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT, HOW SHOULDN'T WE HAVE
A REPORTING PROCESS THAT SHOWS
US THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY MAKING
CONNECTION WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS? ABSOLUTELY. SO
THANK YOU, CHAIR. I APPRECIATE
THESE QUESTIONS. AND I THINK
SOMETHING THAT DOCTOR SWAN AND I
HAVE SORT OF THOUGHT A LOT
ABOUT, I WILL SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT THIS IDEA OF A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US BOTH AS
PHYSICIANS AND AS SORT OF HEALTH
SERVICES RESEARCHERS. AS YOU
HEARD MENTIONED, WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CORRECT PLACE TO STORE THESE
DATA IS THE CURES DATABASE,
UNDER AB 2115, SECTION ONE C,
WHICH DOES REFER TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE 1161 1165, DOES
REQUIRE THAT PHYSICIANS WHO ARE
PHYSICIANS AND OTHER CLINICIANS
WHO ARE PROVIDING THESE DOSES OF
METHADONE, JUST AS WITH OTHER
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES, WOULD BE
REPORTING INTO THE STATE'S
PRESCRIPTION DRUG MONITORING
PROGRAM, KNOWN AS CURES, WHICH
HAS EXISTED SINCE 2003 AND
MANAGED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, AND MADE
PERMANENT AS A PERMANENT PROGRAM
IN IN 2003. AND THE DATA THAT
ARE CAPTURED HERE INCLUDE THE
NUMBER OF UNIQUE PATIENTS WHO
ARE RECEIVING MEDICATION THROUGH
A PROGRAM, THE NUMBER OF REPEAT
VISITS, THE NUMBER OF DOSES
DISPENSED IN TOTAL. AND SO AS OF
RIGHT NOW, WE CAN SORT OF LOOK
AND SAY THE NUMBER OF AND THE
NUMBER REFERRED TO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT PROVIDERS
BECAUSE THERE'S A THERE'S AN
END. YOU DON'T PROVIDE THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
GENERALLY. ABSOLUTELY. SO THE
WAY THAT TO 2115 IS SORT OF
WRITTEN IS THAT BY PROVIDERS
PROVIDING 72 HOURS WORTH OF
METHADONE, THOSE THAT DATA CAN
BE PULLED FROM CURES TO SORT OF
SEE, OH, THESE WERE THE NUMBER
OF IN AGGREGATE. TO YOUR POINT,
THESE ARE THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE WHO
RECEIVED A PRESCRIPTION FOR 72
HOUR METHADONE, WHICH CAN THEN
BE SORT OF FOLLOWED TO SORT OF
SEE WHICH PERCENT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS DID
FOLLOW UP AT AN OPIOID TREATMENT
PROGRAM IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE
USE CURES DATA AS WELL AS OTHER
LOOKING AT OTHER CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES TO FOLLOW TREATMENT,
FOR EXAMPLE, WITH BUPRENORPHINE,
WE CAN TELL YOU RIGHT AWAY THAT
IN SAN FRANCISCO COUNTY, FOR
EXAMPLE, IN 2023, 2529
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVED
BUPRENORPHINE. WE CAN THEN SORT
OF LOOK TO SEE WHAT INDIVIDUALS
WERE RETAINED IN CARE OVER TIME.
AND CURES IS THE DATABASE THAT
WE BELIEVE IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE ONE, BECAUSE IT'S
AVAILABLE TO SPECIALTY PROVIDERS
AS WELL AS NON SPECIALTY
PROVIDERS, FOR WHOM 2115 IS MOST
APPLICABLE IN PROVIDING
TREATMENT. AND HOW DO WE FIND
OUT THE LAST PIECE? IS IT
BECAUSE IF THERE IF SOMEONE IS
TRANSITIONED TO A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT PROVIDER,
THEY'LL BE PRESCRIPTIONS THAT
ARE ENTERED INTO CURES THAT YOU
CAN TRACK BY NAME. SO CURES
CURES AS AS IT EXISTS IS THE ONE
DATA SYSTEM THAT ALL PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA WHO WORK WITH ANY
DEGREE OF SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
PRESCRIBING OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES DO HAVE ACCESS TO. SO
SOMEONE COULD TRACK A PERSON BY
NAME THROUGH CURES TO FIND OUT
THAT THEY WERE AT A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT FACILITY AND
RECEIVED PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
SOMETHING THERE. I'M JUST TRYING
TO HOW DO I IF I COME TO YOU AS
A WITH AN ADDICTION AND YOU
DISPENSE 72 HOURS OF METHADONE
TO ME AND YOU ENTER THAT IN
CURES AND YOU REFER ME TO X, Y,
Z SUBSTANCE ABUSE, I APOLOGIZE,
FOLKS, BUT REFER ME TO X, Y, Z
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY. HOW CAN ANYBODY TELL
THAT ASSUMING THEY'RE AUTHORIZED
TO ACCESS CURES, SO AM I ASKING?
I'M NOT A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
SO NO, THIS IS A WONDERFUL
QUESTION. SO I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT, THE BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO MANY PROTECTIONS AROUND
METHADONE TREATMENT IN GENERAL,
ESPECIALLY, ESPECIALLY AROUND 42
CFR PART TWO, THAT IN ORDER FOR
SOMEONE TO EVEN ACCESS, WHETHER
SOMEONE IS ACTUALLY LINKED TO A
NARCOTIC TREATMENT PROGRAM,
THERE ARE MANY, MANY, MANY
LAYERS OF PROTECTION. SO MUCH SO
THAT, MANY NARCOTIC TREATMENT
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY DON'T EVEN
REPORT TO CURES BECAUSE CURES
DOES NOT, WOULD NOT FULFILL OR
IS BLOCKED BY 42 CFR PART TWO.
AND SO THE ONLY WAY THAT WE AS
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS CAN
ACTUALLY TRACK SOMEONE'S LINKAGE
IS A VERY THROUGH MULTIPLE
ONEROUS WAYS OF GETTING MULTIPLE
CONSENTS FROM THE PATIENT IN THE
MOMENT THAT ONLY LASTS FOR THREE
MONTHS AT A TIME. AND SO IN
ORDER TO TRACK PEOPLE ACTUALLY
ENTERING INTO A NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAM, THAT WOULD
REQUIRE A LOT OF REVAMPING AND A
LOT OF ADDITIONAL RESTRUCTURING
OF HOW WE TRACK OUR SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE. THAT'S VERY HELPFUL.
WHAT IT TELLS ME IS THAT THIS
WOULD REQUIRE A DIFFERENT SYSTEM
SOMEHOW TO BE UTILIZED THAT DOES
NOT INVOLVE THE PERSONAL
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION, BECAUSE
I'M NOT NECESSARILY INTERESTED
IN WHETHER I I'M INTERESTED, BUT
IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
SIGNIFICANT POLICY PERSPECTIVE
TO KNOW WHETHER I WAS REFERRED,
WHETHER I SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED. BUT IN THE AGGREGATE,
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT IF WE'RE
DISPENSING METHADONE, HOW
EFFECTIVE ARE WE IN GETTING
PEOPLE TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND GETTING THEM
THROUGH TREATMENT SUCCESSFULLY?
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE? DOCTOR,
YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS AS A
POLICY MAKER. HOW WOULD I DECIDE
WHETHER THIS PROGRAM IS
EFFECTIVE UNDER THE CURRENT
CIRCUMSTANCES, BY THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE STILL ON THE
STREET? SO ONE THING I SORT OF
ALSO WANT TO SORT OF CLARIFY. SO
THANK YOU FOR THESE POINTS, THAT
IT IS A REALLY IMPORTANT THING.
AND I WOULD SORT OF AGAIN
REITERATE THAT WE DO BELIEVE IN
THE IMPORTANCE OF A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. BOTH OF US HAVE
SPENT TIME IN ONE OF AT LEAST
ONE OF OUR METHADONE CLINICS IN
SAN FRANCISCO, AND AS PART OF
OUR NORMAL CLINICAL PRACTICE,
WHEN WE'RE ADMITTING SOMEONE, WE
DO CHECK THE CURES DATABASE. IN
DOING SO, WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
SEE PRIOR TO US DISPENSING OUR
FIRST DOSE OF METHADONE FROM AN
OTP, WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE IN
THAT MOMENT IF THE PERSON DID
RECEIVE 72 HOURS OF METHADONE
PRIOR TO REACHING OUR PRACTICE.
SO AS A CLINICIAN, IF I AM
SITTING IN FRONT OF A PERSON WHO
IS NEW TO MY PRACTICE, I CAN
LOOK AT THE CURES DATABASE AND
SAY, OH, THEY RECEIVED 72 HOURS
OF METHADONE PRIOR TO ME
DISPENSING THAT FIRST DOSE FROM
AN OTP. WHAT REPORT DO I. SO I'M
NOT A HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. I
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ANY OF
THESE SYSTEMS. NEVER WILL. DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO ANYBODY'S MEDICAL
RECORDS. SHOULDN'T WHAT REPORT
DO I PULL OFF THE SHELF TO FIND
OUT HOW EFFECTIVE THIS METHADONE
PROGRAM IS IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE INTO TREATMENT AND
SUCCESSFULLY THROUGH THE
PROCESS, BECAUSE I CAN'T ACCESS
CURES, I THINK ONE THING THAT I
WOULD PROBABLY RELY ON IS
PROBABLY OUR MEDICAID DATABASE,
WHEN WE KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
PATIENTS WHO ARE ON METHADONE
BELONG TO SAFETY NET SYSTEMS AND
DO HAVE MEDICAID INSURANCE, AND
SO THROUGH MEDICAID, NARCOTIC
TREATMENT PROGRAMS DO HAVE TO
BILL FOR SERVICES THROUGH THE
MEDICAID INSURANCE. AND SO WE,
AS MANY HEALTHCARE RESEARCHERS
DO, CAN TRACK MEDICAID CLAIMS
DATA OVER TIME AND SEE THAT A
PERSON HAS LINKED FROM RECEIVING
A MEDICAID SERVICE THROUGH A
HOSPITAL OF 72 HOURS OF
METHADONE AND THEN CAN ACTUALLY
SEE AT A POPULATION DATA LEVEL
THAT THEY HAVE CONTINUED TO LINK
THROUGH, THROUGH OTHER. THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY MORE COMPLICATED THAN
I'M GOING TO BE ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH IN THE FOUR WEEKS THAT I
HAVE LEFT IN THIS BUSINESS, BUT
I THANK YOU FOR TOLERATING ME.
THOSE OF YOU IN THE AUDIENCE AND
THE AUTHOR FOR TOLERATING MY
QUESTIONS, I DO THINK THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS.
WE'RE DEALING WITH SUPPORT. SO
ARE THERE ANY SUPPORTERS NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE? PLEASE? MR. CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS, PAUL YODER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND MAYOR LONDON
BREED IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. LEAH
BARROWS, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT.
VANESSA KAHINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. KATHY. SENATOR MCDONNELL
FOR THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KELLY
BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
DYLAN STAPLETON ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELENI
KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SYMPHONY BARBIE,
ON BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JEFF NEILL,
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO. ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CAROLINE MCGOWAN WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SAN MATEO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, I'M JENNIFER
ALI, I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA OPIOID
MAINTENANCE PROVIDER
ORGANIZATION. WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
CONCERNED POSITION ON THE BILL.
IF I COULD ADD A FEW COMMENTS,
PLEASE, I WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
SO FIRST OF ALL, I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
THE THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSIONS AND
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE. WE'VE MADE
A LOT OF IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
BILL SINCE IT WAS INTRODUCED.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE REALLY JUST
ROLLED UP OUR SLEEVES. YOU KNOW,
COMP FULLY SUPPORTS INCREASING
ACCESS TO, OPIOID USE DISORDER
MEDICATIONS. BUT WE HAVE HAD
SOME SAFETY AND SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BILL SPECIFICALLY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT A
BILL THAT WILL CREATE A NEW AND
UNTESTED PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S CRITICAL
TO EVALUATE THE SAFETY AND
EFFICACY OF THIS APPROACH. AS
SUCH, WE'RE REQUESTING DATA BE
REPORTED INTO EXISTING SUD
SYSTEMS THAT THE STATE ALREADY
HAS SUCH AS CAL, OMES, AND DATA
ARE, AND SPECIFICALLY THE NUMBER
OF PATIENTS RECEIVING A
MEDICATION UNDER THE PROGRAM,
THE NUMBER OF REPEAT VISITS BY
PATIENTS. SO SOMEBODY THAT
RECEIVED A 72 HOUR DOSE AND THEN
WENT BACK WAS UNSUCCESSFUL IN
ENTERING THEIR TREATMENT. THAT
MAY HAVE GONE BACK TO THE CLINIC
FOR A SECOND, 72 HOUR DOSE, THE
NUMBER OF DOSES DISPENSED TO A
PATIENT IN TOTAL SO THAT THEY GO
THREE TIMES, FOUR TIMES, FIVE
TIMES, ONCE, AND THE NUMBER OF
ADMISSIONS TO TREATMENT AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS, WE THINK
IT'S CRITICAL TO DETERMINE HOW
THIS APPROACH TO OPIOID USE
DISORDER IN THE COMMUNITY WORKS,
AND AGAIN, WE'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR THEIR
COMMENTS, AND IF WE DON'T, YOU
KNOW, IF WE CAN'T GET AN
UNDERSTANDING ON HOW EFFECTIVE,
SAFE OR UNSAFE THIS APPROACH TO
TREATMENT COULD BE, THEN WE
RECOMMEND CONSIDERING SIMPLY A
PILOT PROGRAM LIMITED TO SAN
FRANCISCO BEFORE WE GO
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
OKAY. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE. BRING IT BACK TO
THE DESK, COLLEAGUES. SENATOR
NGUYEN, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I,
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS, ONE, IS
THIS IS ONLY FOR CLINIC THAT'S
REGISTERED WITH THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY, SO IT'S NOT LIKE
ANYBODY, ANY PHYSICIANS OR ANY,
THAT CAN JUST GO OUT AND
SUBSCRIBE THESE MEDICATION. CAN
YOU HELP ME UNDERSTAND? ONE IS,
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF THESE
CLINICS ARE ALLOWED IN THE
STATE? AND SECOND IS, WHAT ARE
THE CRITERIA FOR THESE FOR FOLKS
TO OR CLINICS OR FACILITIES TO
BECOME REGISTERED WITH THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY? LIKE WHAT'S THE
CRITERIA OF THE PHARMACY WOULD
ALLOW WOULD APPROVE SUCH A
CLINIC?
THANK YOU, VICE CHAIR I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS ON HAND.
I'M HAPPY TO GET BACK TO YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS IF
WE CAN OBTAIN THEM FROM THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY. BUT YOU'RE
CORRECT THAT THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN, AB 2115, ONLY PERTAINS
TO THOSE THAT BOTH ARE LICENSED
BY THE BOARD OF PHARMACY AS WELL
AS HAVE A LICENSE FROM THE DRUG
ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATION. SO
IT IS NOT THE SORT OF THE
PICTURE OF FREESTANDING SORT OF
CLINICS THAT EXIST AND OPERATE
OUTSIDE OF HAVING A VERY
SPECIFIC LICENSE BY THOSE TWO
AGENCIES. BUT I AM SORRY, I DO
NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS. NO
WORRIES. SO IS IT SAFE TO SAY
THAT EVERY COUNTY FACILITY
SHOULD OR EVERY COUNTY THEIR
HEALTH CARE FACILITY SHOULD HAVE
A CLINIC OR TWO? I THINK, YOU
KNOW, GIVEN THAT EVERY COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AFFECTED BY
THE OVERDOSE CRISIS AND IS
SEEING ESCALATING LEVELS OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS, ESPECIALLY
THROUGH THE DOMINANCE OF
FENTANYL AND THE DRUG SUPPLY,
NOT ONLY IN OPIOIDS BUT MANY,
MANY OTHER DRUGS ARE
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING OUR
COMMUNITIES, PARTICULARLY AMONG
YOUNG ADULTS. I WOULD SAY YES.
OKAY. THEN MY NEXT QUESTION IS
THE, THE COMMENT THAT WAS JUST
MADE, IS THERE AN ISSUE? DO YOU
HAVE AN ISSUE IN BEING ABLE TO,
INCLUDE IN THE SUD SYSTEM, THE
DATA OF MAKING SURE THAT WE KNOW
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE
DOSES, HOW MANY OF THEM ARE
POTENTIAL REPEAT, HOW MANY DOSES
THAT INDIVIDUAL IS GETTING
WEEKLY, MONTHLY, ETC. SO JUST TO
CLARIFY, SO THE 72 HOUR SECTION,
ONE PART OF AB 2115, THIS IS
ONLY SUPPOSED TO BE A ONE TIME
EPISODE FROM A OR SORRY FROM A
CLINIC TO PROVIDE A LINK BEFORE
THE LINKAGE TO TREATMENT. OTHER
STATES HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
THIS RULING, INCLUDING IN STATES
LIKE MASSACHUSETTS, COLORADO,
OREGON, AND THEN ALSO
WASHINGTON, AS WELL AS, AT JOHNS
HOPKINS IN MARYLAND. AND SO MANY
RESEARCH FROM OTHER STATES HAVE
ALREADY FOUND THAT IN PLACES IN
CLINICS THAT DID IMPLEMENT 72
HOUR METHADONE, THAT HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS OF PATIENTS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO LINK OVER INTO
SUBSEQUENT MÀ, TREATMENT
SUBSTANCE USE TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
AND THEN ALSO OF THE MANY
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THAT THEY
HAVE ASSESSED, ONLY LESS THAN 5%
EVEN HAD TWO REPEAT EPISODES.
AND SO WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE
FROM OTHER STATES THAT IT'S VERY
UNLIKELY THAT PEOPLE WILL HAVE
MULTIPLE MULTIPLE EPISODES. AND
AS ALREADY DISCUSSED WITH DOCTOR
HAMM, THIS DATA IS TRACKED
THROUGH CURES. AND SO THE NUMBER
OF DOSES THE DOSAGES THAT PEOPLE
RECEIVE, THE NUMBER OF EPISODES
IS ALREADY TRACKED THROUGH THE
DATA SYSTEMS. AND TO ADD
ADDITIONAL DATA SYSTEMS THAT
WOULD ALSO TRACK. THIS MAY SEEM
REDUNDANT AND SOMEWHAT WASTEFUL.
OKAY BUT ARE WE TRACKING? I'M
NOT SAYING IDENTIFY THE
INDIVIDUAL, BUT ARE RETRACTING
WOULD CURES THAT YOU KNOW X
PATIENT HAS HAD TWO DOSES OF THE
72 HOUR OR THREE DOSES. I MEAN,
SO IT'S NOT JUST LIKE, YOU KNOW,
A THOUSAND DOSES THAT HAS BEEN
GIVEN OR A THOUSAND PEOPLE
RECEIVED, BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY ACTUAL INDIVIDUAL. YES.
OKAY. AND, DOES THAT CAN YOU.
MR. CHAIR, CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
SURE. AUDIENCE DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTIONS, OR DO YOU HAVE
CONCERNS WITH. WELL THE CURES
DATABASE DOESN'T ALLOW FOR,
EASILY ALLOW FOR, SEARCHING
BASED ON A COUNTY OR A CITY TO
DETERMINE THE IMPACT. RIGHT.
BECAUSE IT'S PHYSICIAN AND
PATIENT. SO WHEN YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT EVALUATE A PROGRAM, ITS
EFFECTIVENESS OVERALL, I DON'T
KNOW HOW THAT'S DONE THROUGH
CURES, WHICH IS VERY LIMITED ON
WHO CAN ACCESS THE DATA AND HOW
IT CAN BE, EVALUATED. RIGHT. YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. THERE'S A
VERY SPECIFIC FORM. YOU HAVE TO
BE APPROVED, RIGHT. SO IT'S JUST
NOT PART OF THE EXISTING PUBLIC
HEALTH SYSTEM THAT WE'VE BEEN
BEEN BUILDING FOR YEARS. THAT
INCLUDES NOT JUST NPS, BUT A
VARIETY OF SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROVIDERS THAT ALL
REPORT INFORMATION AS THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO, WHEN THEY RECEIVE
FEDERAL FUNDING TO, FILE THAT
INFORMATION ON THEIR PROGRAMS,
THEIR NUMBER OF PATIENTS, WHAT
THEY'RE DOING, THEIR OUTCOMES,
AND THAT TYPE OF THING, BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW HOW
PUBLIC MONEY IS SPENT. RIGHT.
AND SO IF YOU DON'T REPORT THE
DATA, THEN YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
AND SO THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM
OUTSIDE OF THIS. AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION, THE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED THIS HAVE
DONE IT THROUGH A HOSPITAL
SYSTEM, WHICH IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN A CLINIC, AND SO
IT'S JUST KIND OF THE FEDERAL,
YOU KNOW, THE 72 HOUR RULE SAYS
HOSPITALS OR PHYSICIANS. IT
DOESN'T SAY CLINICS. AND SO FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE, FROM OUR READ
ON, IT, IT IS A NEWER TYPE OF
SYSTEM THAT'S DOING IT. AND SO
THAT'S AGAIN WHY WE THINK THE
DATA IS SO CRITICAL. DON'T NOT
WANT IT TO HAPPEN. JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION MOVING FORWARD. AND
SO THAT IT'S EFFECTIVE AND SAFE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD, I DO WANT TO JUST
POINT OUT THAT THERE ARE THERE
ARE IT IS A PROCESS TO ACCESS
CURES DATA. THERE ARE SAFEGUARDS
THAT ARE BUILT IN PLACE AS
DOCTOR SWAIN IS ALSO SORT OF
ALLUDED TO. BUT I DO WANT TO
SORT OF CALL ATTENTION TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE 11165 C2 SECTION
A, WHICH DOES SAY THAT THESE
DATA CAN BE PROVIDED TO PUBLIC,
PRIVATE, PUBLIC OR PRIVATE
ENTITIES AS APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR
EDUCATIONAL, PEER REVIEW,
STATISTICAL OR RESEARCH
PURPOSES. IF PATIENT
INFORMATION, INCLUDING
INFORMATION THAT MAY IDENTIFY
THE PATIENT, IS NOT COMPROMISED.
AND THIS IS WHY CDPH, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH, HAS PUT ON THEIR
DASHBOARD THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FILLING A
PRESCRIPTION FOR BUPRENORPHINE,
THE NUMBER OF DOSES OF
BUPRENORPHINE DISPENSE FOR THE
TREATMENT OF OPIOID USE DISORDER.
THOSE DATA CAN ALSO BE AVAILABLE
TO BOTH CDPH, OTHER
DEPARTMENTAL, OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO SORT OF LOOK TO SORT
OF SEE HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS ARE
RECEIVING MORE THAN ONE
PRESCRIPTION. RESEARCHERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO HAVE DONE THIS FOR
BUPRENORPHINE AS AN EXAMPLE, YOU
KNOW, 1850 PEOPLE IN 2023
RECEIVED MORE THAN ONE
PRESCRIPTION FOR BUPRENORPHINE.
SO IF EXTENDING THIS TO INCLUDE
METHADONE WOULD BE THE SAME
PROCESS, IT IS AVAILABLE THROUGH
CURES. IT IS A PROCESS TO APPLY
FOR IT AND TO JUSTIFY THE NEED
FOR IT. BUT IT DOES EXIST IN
THAT SYSTEM. BUT AS A PUBLIC
MEMBER, CAN I GET ACCESS TO THAT
INFORMATION THROUGH CURE? ARE
YOU SAYING LIKE AS A PUBLIC
CITIZEN, LAY CITIZEN, AS
SENATOR, OR AS JANET NGUYEN, I
WANT THAT DATA. CAN I GET ACCESS
TO IT? I THINK WELL, TO SPEAK TO
DOCTOR TOM'S EXAMPLE, WE WOULD
HAVE TO CREATE THOSE REPORTING
SYSTEMS THROUGH, FOR EXAMPLE,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF, YOU
KNOW, CDPH, AND IT WOULD HAVE TO
KIND OF GO THROUGH DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
DATA IS SECURE AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACCESSING OUR YOU KNOW, THAT
THE DATA DOESN'T FALL INTO THE
WRONG HANDS. SO NØ IS YOUR
ANSWER. SO SOMEONE LIKE ME, A
PUBLIC MEMBER, WANTS TO GET
ACCESS TO THE DATA. LOOK, I
VOTED YES ON THIS IN BNP, BUT
NOW I'M QUESTIONING BECAUSE WE
ALL KNOW THESE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
HELP AND WE WANT TO BE THERE AND
WE WANT TO HELP. SO I HAVE NO
REASON WHY NOT TO TODAY. BUT I'M
HEARING CONCERNS IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE NEED THE DATA BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY US DOING THIS IS TO
HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS TO GET
INTO A PROGRAM TO GET HELP. ONCE
THEY GET HELP. AND THAT'S THAT'S
THE RESULT, RIGHT? WE WANT THEM
TO GET HELP BECAUSE THE 72 HOUR
EMERGENCY IS LITERALLY WHAT IT
IS. IT'S AN EMERGENCY. IT
SHOULDN'T BE ABUSED. IT
SHOULDN'T BE REPEATED. IT
SHOULDN'T BE SOMEONE WHO GOES,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M GOING TO GO
AGAIN BECAUSE I NEED IT, BECAUSE
I CAN'T FIND IT ON THE STREET.
RIGHT. SO WE NEED THESE DATA.
AND IF THE PUBLIC CAN'T GET THAT
DATA AND WE CAN'T EVEN GET A
DATA THAT SAYS, SAY, YOU KNOW, I
REPRESENT MAJORITY OF THE CITIES
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND THREE
CITIES IN LOS ANGELES. IF I
WANTED THE DATA IN ORANGE
COUNTY, I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO
SAY, OKAY, ORANGE COUNTY, YOU
HAVE GIVEN OUT YOU'VE GIVEN OUT
1000 DOSES THIS MONTH. AND THOSE
THOSE 1000 DOSES, THERE'S ONLY
AND THERE LITERALLY 999 OF THEM
INDIVIDUALS. SO ONE DID TWICE
THAT MONTH. AND OF THE OF THE
THOUSAND, ALL 1000 WENT INTO A
TREATMENT PROGRAM. AND I ALSO
AGREE WITH THE CHAIR. IT'S LIKE
WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM AFTER THE
TREATMENT PROGRAM? DID THEY GET
OUT OF THE TREATMENT AND
ACTUALLY HEAD INTO THE RIGHT
DIRECTION, OR DID THEY WENT BACK
INTO THE SYSTEM AGAIN? SO I
THINK DATA HELPS US. AND BY I
DON'T WANT DATA THAT HAS ANY
INDIVIDUAL'S NAMES OR ANYTHING
IDENTIFYING ANYBODY IN
PARTICULAR, I THINK, THOUGH, IS
THAT THE MORE DATA WE NEED, WE
HAVE PUBLICLY, IT GIVES US
POLICYMAKERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO FIND THE PATHWAY TO
SUCCESS AND NOT JUST A LAST, YOU
KNOW, A 72 HOUR OPTION. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU.
AND SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS GOT A
QUESTION OR COMMENT IN A SECOND.
I THINK THE ISSUE IS, AS
POLICYMAKERS, WE WANT TO WE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF THOSE WHO
ARE DISPENSING METHADONE IN A
PARTICULAR FACILITY OR GROUP OF
FACILITIES, WHAT'S YOUR TRACK
RECORD IS FOR GETTING PEOPLE
INTO SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
CURES DOESN'T REALLY PROVIDE
THAT TO ANSWER THAT, MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR NGUYEN'S
QUESTION, I'VE LOOKED AT THE
SECTION DOJ WILL MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER TO
RELEASE DATA TO THE PUBLIC OR
ENTITIES. BUT IT'S RESEARCH
EDUCATION. IT'S A IT'S A DEFINED
SET OF CATEGORIES, AND OF
COURSE, THE PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
DATA HAS TO BE REDACTED. BUT A
DEFINED SET OF CATEGORIES OF
ENTITIES THAT ARE ENTITLED TO
ACCESS CURES OTHER THAN
PHYSICIAN PROVIDERS,
PHARMACISTS, AND THE LIKE. SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT CURES IS THE
SOLUTION. OBVIOUSLY, WE DON'T
HAVE IT IN THE BILL. DOESN'T
CHANGE WHAT I'M GOING TO DO ON
THE BILL. BUT I DO THINK AT SOME
POINT, THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
GOING TO BE AROUND HERE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS, BECAUSE AS
POLICY MAKERS, WE OUGHT TO WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE PROGRAM, THE 72 HOUR
DISPENSING PROGRAM, IS EFFECTIVE
OR ARE WE JUST DISPENSING
METHADONE TO DISPENSE METHADONE?
I REALIZE YOU HAVE GOOD
INTENTIONS, BUT UNLESS THERE'S A
FOLLOW ON BY SOMEBODY, WHETHER
IT'S THE PERSON DISPENSING OR
SOMEONE ELSE ON THE HEALTH
FACILITY STAFF, I DON'T KNOW HOW
EFFECTIVE THE PROGRAM IS, BUT
LET ME TURN TO MY MUCH SMARTER,
HARDER WORKING COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR MENGIBAR. TAKE THE, I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN ASKING THE
SPONSORS ALL THESE QUESTIONS.
SOME OF THEM WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY ON YOUR
THOUGHTS REGARDING ADDING THE
DATA COLLECTION PART, ENSURING
THAT YOU YOURSELF CAN COME BACK
AND REVIEW HOW SUCCESSFUL IT'S
BEEN OR NOT. NO, ABSOLUTELY. AND
I APPRECIATE THE DIALOG AND I
THINK IT IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. AS WE HEARD, TO BE
ABLE TO ASSESS WHETHER THIS IS
EFFECTIVE OF COURSE, WHEN A
DOCTOR, A PHYSICIAN IS MAKING
THE MEDICAL DECISION TO
PRESCRIBE A MEDICATION THAT IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST A MEDICAL
DECISION THAT THEY'RE MAKING
WITH CERTAIN ETHICAL AND
PROFESSIONAL REQUIREMENTS WITH
THAT, AND THEN FROM THERE, THE
HOPE AND THE INTENTION IS THAT
PEOPLE CONTINUE THAT MEDICATION.
AND IF THEY'RE CONTINUING TO
COME BACK AND ABUSING THE SYSTEM
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
DOCTORS WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE.
THE HOSPITALS WOULD BE ABLE TO
SEE AND BECAUSE OF THAT, LIKELY
WOULD NOT CONTINUE TO DO THAT. I
THINK WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ASSESS THIS PROGRAM AND
THAT WE HAVE THE ADEQUATE LEVELS
OF DATA TO DO THAT. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING FROM TALKING TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES TO
THE STATE, TO THE DOCTORS, TO
THE HOSPITALS THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT FOR
US IS THROUGH CURES, AND THAT
CREATING AN ADDITIONAL SYSTEM OF
REPORTING ACTUALLY WOULD BE NOT
ONLY POTENTIALLY BURDENSOME, BUT
ACTUALLY LESS ACCURATE IN MANY
WAYS. AND SO THERE WAS A LOT OF
RESISTANCE TO DOING THE
AMENDMENT THAT WAS REQUESTED IN
FACT, MOST OF OUR SUPPORTERS
SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE IN
OPPOSITION IF WE TOOK THAT
AMENDMENT. SO IT PUT US IN A
VERY CHALLENGING POSITION HERE.
AND I AND I REALLY APPRECIATED
THE CHAIR FOR, FOR, FOR ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS. AND FOR LEANING
ON US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW THIS ISSUE AS THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY MOVES FORWARD, THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT HOW TO MAKE SURE
IT'S SUCCESSFUL, HOW TO MAKE
SURE THE REPORTING IS
APPROPRIATE, THAT WE FOLLOW UP
ON THIS AND THAT WE CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW BEST TO
DO THIS. I, AS YOU DID, WENT TO
THE EXPERTS AND SAID, WELL,
COULD WE DO THIS AMENDMENT ON
REPORTING THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR
AND ALL THE FOLKS WHO RUN THEIR
HOSPITALS AND OUR DOCTORS AND
EVERYTHING SAID, NO, THIS IS NOT
THE WAY TO DO IT. THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY CREATE HUGE PROBLEMS
FOR US. SO THAT'S SORT OF WHERE
WE ENDED UP WHERE WE ARE. BUT I
THINK THE INTENTION IS TO HAVE
THE RIGHT LEVEL OF REPORTING AND
DATA AND, AND ALL OF THAT, THAT
THE CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT IS SOMETHING I
FULLY SUPPORT. AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON WITH, WITH,
WITH EVERYONE INVOLVED TO, TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET RIGHT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM IS
SUCCESSFUL. WELL WELL, LET ME
JUST SAY THIS. I'M GOING TO
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT THIS. I THINK
I SUPPORTED IT BEFORE AND HAVE
CONTINUED TO, I CAN ALMOST
ASSURE YOU THAT CURES DOES NOT
PROVIDE THE DATA THAT I'M ASKING
FOR. IF I WANT TO FIND OUT
WHETHER A CLINIC OR A GROUP OF
CLINICS. WHAT'S YOUR PERCENTAGE
OF SUCCESS RATE IS AFTER AFTER
DISPENSING A 72 HOUR DOSE OF
METHADONE? IN TERMS OF GETTING
PEOPLE INTO A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY, THAT IS NOT
GOING TO CURES. IF I WERE TO
GAIN ACCESS TO CURES, I WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT
DATA GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION FROM THE
PATIENT IS REDACTED. AND UNLESS
DHS OR SOME OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCY GETS INVOLVED AND DOES
THE NUMBER CRUNCHING, AND MAYBE
A GOVERNMENT AGENCY WITH ACCESS,
FULL ACCESS TO CURES CAN DO
THAT, AND CONNECT THE DOTS,
MAYBE. BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN FOR SOMEBODY LIKE ME WITH
NO AUTHORIZED ACCESS FULLY TO
CURES. AND SO FOR THOSE WHO SAY
CURES IS THE SOLUTION, SOLUTION.
I SAY BUNK, I WON'T BE HERE TO
ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION. MY
COLLEAGUES WILL BE. I HOPE WE
HAVE A MUCH MORE ROBUST
CONVERSATION BECAUSE AS POLICY
MAKERS, WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE FOLKS THAT
ARE DISPENSING 72 HOUR DOSES OF
METHADONE AT THEIR FACILITIES
ARE EFFECTIVE IN MOVING PEOPLE
FROM THE METHADONE 72 HOUR
PROGRAM INTO A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAM. I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR SPENDING SO MUCH
TIME ON THIS. I COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
I'LL LEAVE IT TO THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE AROUND TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION, MAY I? IS THAT
YOUR CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS? THAT
IS MY CLOSE AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS, AND YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
ON IT TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT,
AND, AND I THINK YOU'VE RAISED
SOME VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
GREATLY APPRECIATE, YOUR, YOUR,
YOUR, YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
AND WITH THAT, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
IT FORWARD AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM DOWN HERE, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE'LL DO EXACTLY
THAT. THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR
SCHEDULES TO PRESENT. I
APOLOGIZE IF I, BELABORED THE
ISSUE OR BADGERED YOU WITH
QUESTIONS, BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSES. AND I, I HAVE 2893
FOR WARD. IF I'M SORRY, I. WHERE
ITEM 20. YOU MEAN YOU WANT MORE?
LET ME MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT HERE
SOMEWHERE. BOARD ITEM NUMBER 20
AB 2893. THE SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY RESIDENCY PROGRAM. AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO BE SUPPORTIVE.
GREAT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
2893, WHICH I AM A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD
AND WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT GETTING PEOPLE THE
RIGHT TYPE OF HELP THAT WILL PUT
THEM IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY
CAN RECOVER FROM ADDICTION AND
TO LIVE SAFELY IN THAT RECOVERY,
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A HOUSING FREE
HOUSING FIRST POLICY THAT IS OUT
OF STEP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S HOUSING FIRST
POLICY, SIMILAR IN SOME WAYS TO
THE BILL THAT I JUST PRESENTED.
THERE ARE MANY THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE WHO ARE
READY TO LIVE IN A DRUG FREE
RECOVERY ENVIRONMENT, A STRICTLY
SOBER ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
STAFF AND THE OTHER RESIDENTS
THERE ARE COMMITTED TO A PATH OF
SOBRIETY RIGHT NOW,
UNFORTUNATELY, CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR ANY STATE FUNDING
TO BE SPENT ON DRUG FREE
RECOVERY HOUSING. THE LACK OF
OPTIONS FORCES PEOPLE TO LIVE IN
HOUSING THAT ISN'T BEST SUITED
FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL SOBRIETY
JOURNEY, AND IT CAN PUT THEM AT
A HIGHER RISK OF OVERDOSE AND
FALLING BACK INTO HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS NOT SAYING THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE PUT INTO
THAT ENVIRONMENT. IT'S ABOUT
HAVING OPTIONS, AND THERE ARE
MANY PEOPLE WHO WANT THAT
OPTION. AND YET THE STATE IS NOT
SUPPORTING IT. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE OPTIONS FOR HARM
REDUCTION AND ALSO RESPONDS TO
OUR HOMELESSNESS AND ADDICTION
CRISIS BY ALLOWING UP TO 10% OF
STATE FUNDING TO GO TOWARDS DRUG
FREE RECOVERY HOUSING. IT ALSO
WILL ESTABLISH A STATE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS FOR
RECOVERY HOUSING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. IT IS RECEIVED BROAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS JASON RUPP. JUST, LOUIS
MERANTE FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL, THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY, SIR.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD, THOUGH. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. MY NAME IS LOUIS
MURANTE. I REPRESENT THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL ON HOUSING ISSUES,
AND I'M PROUD HERE TO BE A
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL. THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IS ONE OF ITS
SPONSORS. I'M GOING TO ABRIDGE
MY COMMENTS IN THE INTEREST OF
YOUR TIME, BUT I'M VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT WE WORKED WITH A BROAD
SWATH OF OUR MEMBERS IN THE BAY
AREA TO COME UP WITH THIS BILL,
INCLUDING THE SALVATION ARMY AND
MANY OTHER HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
SERVICES PROVIDERS. ACCORDING TO
THE US DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
URBAN DEVELOPMENT, THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY
RESIDENCES CAN AND SHOULD BE A
COMPONENT OF ANY CONTINUUM OF
CARE. CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
HOUSING FIRST LAW PROHIBITS THE
STATE FROM FUNDING SCR PROJECTS,
AND IT IS THEREFORE OUT OF
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL BEST
PRACTICES ON THE TOPIC, AB 2893
WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA INTO
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL GUIDANCE
BY ALLOWING UP TO 10% OF STATE
GRANTS WITH INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
TO SUPPORT SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY
RESIDENCE PROJECTS, AND WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ESTABLISH
CRITERIA FOR CERTIFYING
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY RESIDENTS.
FOR THESE REASONS, I STRONGLY
URGE YOUR YES VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD. NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. HELLO, SYMPHONY BARBIE,
ON BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MA'AM. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IT'S
YOUR LUCKY DAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GIVEN THE LAST TIME. WOULD YOU
LIKE, COLLEAGUES? ANY QUESTIONS?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU AGAIN, MR.
CHAIR. AND RESPECTFULLY, AT THE
RIGHT TIME, WHEN THERE'S A
QUORUM, I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AND FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS. AS WELL. WE
WILL DO JUST THAT. THANK YOU.
NICE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU.
OKAY MADAM MAJORITY LEADER, I
SEE YOU THERE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 2223 CANNABIS. OH
YEAH. THAT CANNABIS INDUSTRIAL
HEMP. PROCEED WHEN READY. OKAY
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS COMPLEX ISSUE.
I STARTED WORKING ON HEMP ISSUES
BECAUSE THE 2018 FARM BILL
UNLEASHED A LARGELY UNREGULATED
INDUSTRY. MY FIRST SUCCESSFUL
LEGISLATION WAS AB 45, WHICH WAS
THE STRICTEST HEMP LAW IN THE
COUNTRY WHEN IT WAS ENACTED IN
2021. BUT TODAY, I AM HERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT LAW CAN BE
PROPERLY ENFORCED AND
INTERPRETED AS THE HEMP MARKET
GROWS, WE'RE SEEING MORE
INTOXICATING HEMP PRODUCTS THAT
ARE SOLD OUTSIDE OF DISPENSARIES
WITHOUT A WITHOUT AGE LIMITS,
WHICH SHOULD BE ILLEGAL. THIS
BILL IS ANOTHER HUGE UNDERTAKING
THAT TAKES ON THREE ISSUES ONE,
IT EXPANDS ENFORCEMENT TO CRACK
DOWN ON ILLEGAL HEMP PRODUCTS.
IT'S CLOSING LOOPHOLES THAT WILL
ALLOW INTOXICATING HEMP PRODUCTS
AND IT'S MAKING SURE ALL
INTOXICANTS ARE IN THE CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN, MEANING FULL
REGISTRATION, FULL REGULATION
AND TAXATION. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
STATE AGENCIES AND COMMITTEES AS
WE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BEST WAY TO IMPLEMENT THESE
CHANGES. WITH ME, I HAVE AMY
JENKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND TIFFANY DEVITT
ON BEHALF OF THE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. PLEASE PROCEED.
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. FOR THE
RECORD, THOUGH. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIRMAN ROTH, AND
ESTEEMED WELL, MISSING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, BUT ESTEEMED
NONETHELESS. MY NAME IS A BUSY,
BUSY TIME. YES, THE BUILDING
INDEED, MY NAME IS TIFFANY
DEBIT. AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO IMPERIAL COUNTY'S
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE, WHICH IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN CANNABIS,
LABOR AND CANNABIS EMPLOYERS.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 2223 CENTRAL TO
THIS LEGISLATION IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE, WHICH IS
THAT MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS BELONG IN THE REGULATED
MEDICAL AND RECREATIONAL
CANNABIS MARKETPLACE, REGARDLESS
OF WHETHER THE THC WAS SOURCED
FROM CANNABIS OR HEMP. HERE'S
WHY. HEMP PRODUCTS WITH NEZIH,
AS WE KNOW, ARE VULNERABLE TO
MISUSE AND ABUSE. THE REGULATED
CANNABIS MARKET HAS COUNTLESS
MEASURES IN PLACE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS, PATIENTS AND THE
BROADER COMMUNITY. THE HEMP
MARKET, ON THE OTHER HAND, IS A
WILD WEST. IT'S CHARACTERIZED BY
FREQUENTLY ADULTERATED,
MISLABELED, HIGHLY IMPAIRING
PRODUCTS THAT ARE TRIGGERING AN
INCREASE IN YOUTH
HOSPITALIZATIONS, FULL SPECTRUM
MEDICINAL CANNABIS PRODUCTS WITH
HIGH RATIOS OF CBD TO THC HAVE
BEEN A CORNERSTONE OF THE
REGULATED CANNABIS MARKET FROM
DAY ONE, I UNDERSTAND AND HAVE
GREAT SYMPATHY FOR PATIENTS
TODAY WHO ARE USING HEMP BECAUSE
MEDICAL CANNABIS IS EXPENSIVE,
AB 2223 DOES IN FACT ADDRESS
THIS TO A DEGREE BY ALLOWING
LICENSED CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
TO USE LOWER COST CBD, HEMP
INPUTS. BUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND IS THAT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THC HEMP
PRODUCTS ARE NOT MEDICAL AND
THEY ARE NOT WELLNESS PRODUCTS.
BRANDS WITH NAMES LIKE KNOCKED
OUT SOURCED EL CHAPO EXTRACTS
AND I'LL JUST SAY, EFFED UP,
RATHER THAN DISRESPECT, THE
COMMITTEE AND SAY THAT ACTUAL
NAME, THOSE BRANDS ARE NOT
SELLING MEDICAL PRODUCTS.
THEY'RE SELLING HYPER IMPAIRING,
OFTEN SYNTHETIC CANNABIS. THAT'S
UNREGULATED, UNTAXED AND
UNTESTED. PUTTING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY IN
DANGER. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING IT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIRMAN, AMY JENKINS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION, I WANT TO
THANK THE GOOD WORK OF COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
FORWARD. I WILL TRY NOT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE, BUT JUST SIMPLY SAY
THE PROLIFERATION OF THESE
PRODUCTS HAS CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH RISK.
WE SEE A DIRECT CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE, YOU KNOW, USE OF
THESE PRODUCTS OR THE
PROLIFERATION OF THEM. AND YOUTH
ACCESS AND YOUTH
HOSPITALIZATIONS. SO THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH RISK.
I'LL ALSO NOTE, AS MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED, THE INFLUX OF
SYNTHETIC CANNABINOID PRODUCTS
IS ALSO CAUSING A LOT OF
CONCERN. THOSE PRODUCTS OFTEN
EXCEED POTENCY LEVELS FOUND IN
REGULATED CANNABIS, LEADING TO
ACUTE TOXICITY, ACUTE
INTOXICATION AND OTHER SERIOUS
SIDE EFFECTS. SO THE LACK OF
REGULATION AND OVERSIGHT HAS
ALLOWED THIS WIDESPREAD
AVAILABILITY. AND WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME SERIOUS SAFEGUARDS
PUT IN PLACE TO PRESERVE AND
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY, WHICH
IS STRUGGLING TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE SUCCESSFULLY IN THIS
STATE. WE HAVE A WELL REGULATED
SYSTEM. WE HAVE HIGH TESTING
STANDARDS, AND WE HAVE STRONG
PROTOCOLS AND WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS ESSENTIAL TO PROTECTING
THAT MARKET. AND ALSO PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. SO
I'LL JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
OUT THERE. CLAIMS ABOUT
IMPAIRMENT THRESHOLDS AND THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN CBD AND THC,
AND WE ARE BOTH COLLECTIVELY
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT MIGHT COME UP. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING GRACE COPELAND ON BEHALF
OF KIVA CONFECTIONS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION, BOTH
IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KRISTIN HEIDELBACH HERE
ON BEHALF OF UFCW WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL. PROUD CO-SPONSORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MA'AM. NEXT
PLEASE. CHAIR MEMBERS LUIS
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF WEEDMAPS IN
SUPPORT. THANKS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, JULIANA MORRIS, ON BEHALF
OF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SIR. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SAN RODRIGUEZ, ON
BEHALF OF GOOD FARMERS, GREAT
NEIGHBORS BASED IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY, AND SUPPORT. AND WE ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE GREAT WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALSO
THE AUTHOR STAFF. MARIKA, IT'S
BEEN EXEMPLARY. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING, PAM LOPEZ, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA NORML, VERY
HAPPY TO BE IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
REQUESTING AMENDMENTS FOR A TWO
YEAR PHASE IN TO ACCOMMODATE,
HIGH CBD HEMP TINCTURES. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. SHANTA
PAIKIN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, ALEX LOOMER
WITH RESOURCES LEGACY FUND AND
IN SUPPORT OF AMEND POSITION TO
INCLUDE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
PROP 64. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
AND APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
STAFF, AND WE'LL CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU. YES,
SIR. GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA RESERVE
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OF
PLACER COUNTY, AND THE POLICE
OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS OF THE
FOLLOWING CITIES ARCADIA,
BURBANK, CLAREMONT, CORONA,
CULVER CITY, FULLERTON,
MURRIETA, NEWPORT BEACH, NOVATO,
PALOS VERDES, POMONA, RIVERSIDE,
SANTA ANA, UPLAND, THE LÀ
SCHOOL, POLICE ASSOCIATION, LÀ
SCHOOL, POLICE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION, AND CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS, ALL IN SUPPORT OF
AB 223 TO PROTECT OUR CONSUMERS
AND OUR YOUTH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS? OKAY, LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION FIRST. LEAD
OPPOSITION. JOIN US AT THE TABLE
IF YOU'D LIKE, AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE THE REST. YOU KNOW THE
DRILL. IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD AND FIRE WHEN READY.
I KNOW IT WELL, MR. CHAIR, RAND
MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF THE US HEMP
ROUNDTABLE, I WANT TO START OFF
BY SAYING THAT WE AGREE WITH THE
OBJECTIVES THAT THE AUTHOR IS
PURSUING IN THIS BILL, PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE OTHER
VICTIMS OF PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO
HAVE BEEN MANIPULATING THE
COMPOSITION OF SOME OF THESE
PRODUCTS TO MAKE THEM MORE
INTOXICATING. AND THE MEMBERS OF
THE US HEMP ROUNDTABLE ARE AMONG
THOSE VICTIMS. WE AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO TIGHTEN
UP THE LAW. AS YOU'VE SAID MANY
TIMES TODAY, MR. MISTER CHAIR,
IF WE HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE
LAWS, WE NEED TO COME BACK AND
FIX THEM SO WE CAN MAKE THEM AS
PERFECT AS WE POSSIBLY CAN. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEKING,
SEEKING TO DO HERE. SO THINGS
LIKE STRENGTHENED ENFORCEMENT
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. WE ALSO AGREE
WITH THE MILLIGRAM CAP. IN FACT,
AB 45, THE AUTHOR WILL WILL
RECALL, ACTUALLY HAD AUTHORITY
GIVEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ESTABLISH A
MILLIGRAM CAP. THEY CHOSE NEVER
TO EXERCISE THAT FOR REASONS
THAT REMAIN UNKNOWN. BUT WE HAVE
ALWAYS RECOGNIZED THAT A
MILLIGRAM CAP IS AN APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO. THE QUESTION HERE
IS WHAT IS THAT MILLIGRAM CAP?
AND WHETHER WE ARE GOING TO COME
UP WITH A NUMBER THAT IS GOING
TO PUT PEOPLE OUT OF BUSINESS,
OR ARE WE GOING TO COME UP WITH
A NUMBER THAT WILL KEEP THE GOOD
ACTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ACTUALLY COMPLIED WITH WITH BOTH
THE SPIRIT AND THE LETTER OF THE
LAW THAT WAS ENACTED IN AB 4045,
WHETHER WE CAN MAINTAIN THEIR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE BENEFITS TO
THE CONSUMER POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA THAT RELIES ON GOOD
HEMP CBD PRODUCTS FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT, WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED SECONDARILY WITH
THE ISSUE OF THE NUMBER OF
SERVINGS PER PACKAGE. RIGHT NOW,
THE LAW THE BILL SAYS NO MORE
THAN FIVE SERVINGS PER PACKAGE.
THAT IS A REALLY SMALL NUMBER.
WHEN YOU CONSIDER SOME OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE HEMP, CBD
PRODUCTS, FOR EXAMPLE, A VERY
POPULAR ARE TINCTURES, IF YOU
HAD FIVE SERVINGS IN A BOTTLE OF
TINCTURE, THE SIZE OF THAT
BOTTLE WOULD BE LIKE THIS, WHICH
WOULD BE ECONOMICALLY INFEASIBLE
FOR A MANUFACTURER TO PUT
TOGETHER. WE NEED A LARGER
NUMBER. MUCH LIKE THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY HAS A LARGER NUMBER OF
SERVINGS PER PACKAGE. WE
APPRECIATE THE. THE AUTHOR HAS
SAID MANY TIMES AND AGAIN IN HER
OPENING, THAT SHE INTENDS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT. WE KNOW
IT'S NOT GOING TO GET RESOLVED
TODAY, BUT WE HAVE PLENTY OF
TIME IN THE MONTH OF JULY TO
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT WHAT IS
AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL, SCIENCE
BASED LEVEL OF THC IN IN A HEMP
CBD PRODUCT THAT DOES NOT CAUSE
INTOXICATION, BUT ALSO PROVIDES
THE THERAPEUTIC BENEFIT TO THE
CONSUMERS? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU. YES, SIR. MY NAME IS
TED WHITNEY. I'M HERE WITH REX
BIOTECH. WE'RE A PRODUCER OF
NATURALLY OCCURRING THC HEMP
DERIVED, LOW DOSE DRINKS. WE
SELL THEM IN 21 STATES,
INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
CURRENTLY ON RETAIL SHELVES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE HAVE A
FIVE MILLIGRAM SODA. WE'RE
THOROUGHLY TESTED, WE COMPLY
WITH EVERYTHING IN AB 45, AND
OUR TESTING STANDARDS EXCEED
THAT WHICH WE DID WHEN WE WERE
IN THE REGULATED MARKET HERE IN
THE STATE, I'M HOPEFUL THAT,
WELL, I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION OF
TWO, TWO, TWO, THREE. AND I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN FIND
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL PROVIDE FOR
A LOW DOSE, A LOW DOSE PATH
INSIDE OF THE STATE. WE CAN
DERIVE A FANTASTIC TAX REVENUE
ON THE CATEGORY WE CAN PAY FOR
ENFORCEMENT. WE CAN CREATE A
BIFURCATED MARKET THAT WORKS OUT
GREAT FOR ALL OF OUR CONSUMERS
IN THE STATE, OFFERING HARM
REDUCTION THROUGH DRINKS THAT
PROVIDE BETTER ACCESS TO
RECREATION AND RELIEF. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS MATTER. THANK YOU SIR.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY. PLEASE TERRY MCHALE WITH
AARON READ AND ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CHEECH AND CHONG.
GLOBAL HOLDINGS, SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE. UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. SIR MICHAEL RAMIREZ I'M AN
OWNER OPERATOR OF MÁS
CONSULTING. DELTA BEVERAGE,
WHICH IS A $52 MILLION FACILITY,
THE LARGEST CANNABIS DRINK
MANUFACTURER IN THE COUNTRY OUT
OF LOS ANGELES. AND I'M ALSO A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CANNABIS
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING THE MAJORITY OF ALL
HEMP AND CANNABIS DRINKS ACROSS
THE NATION. THANK YOU ALL FOR
THE AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL. WE
BELIEVE IN REGULATION. IT NEEDS
TO BE STRONGER, BUT IT NEEDS TO
BE WISE. I THINK THERE'S THREE
MAJOR MISSING COMPONENTS, SO
WITH THAT, WE STAND OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU. KIM
CRAIG WITH ARC STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF CANON BOTTLE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. CHAD PATO WITH
SUN MED WE HAVE OVER 400
LOCATIONS THROUGH THE US, THE
LARGEST BRICK AND MORTAR. WE
HAVE 18 LOCATIONS IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE OPPOSE. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE. HELLO, NATHAN.
CHISMAR OPPOSE. UNLESS AMENDED.
WE JUST OAN TWO LOCAL STORES
OVER HERE, IN ROSEVILLE AND
LINCOLN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIR. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS. AND MY COLLEAGUE,
COLLEAGUES, ANY COLLEAGUE, ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
AND I SEE NO HAND BEING RAISED.
SO I GUESS IT BRINGS IT BACK TO
ME. YOU KNOW, IT OCCURS TO ME
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO INTEGRATE THE
CANNABIS AND THE HEMP INDUSTRIES
HERE, AS IT PERTAINS TO THC. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MEDICINAL
PRODUCTS, AND WE'RE ALSO TALKING
ABOUT SOME LOW DOSE BEVERAGES.
AND I, I DO THINK THAT THERE'S
PROBABLY A WAY TO WORK THIS OUT,
WE DO HAVE TIME OVER OUR
IN-DISTRICT BREAK IN JULY. AND
OF COURSE, WHEN WE COME BACK IN
AUGUST, I WILL BE HERE FOR A
SHORT TIME AFTER THAT. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON MAKING MYSELF AND OUR STAFF,
WHO ARE MUCH SMARTER THAN I, AM,
AVAILABLE TO HELP WITH THIS IF
WE CAN, AND LOOK FORWARD TO A
SUCCESSFUL EFFORT AND A
COMPLETED PRODUCT THAT IS AS
PERFECT AS WE CAN POSSIBLY MAKE
IT IN UNDER THE DOME AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
SO, HAVING SAID THAT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK
YOU, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
ALWAYS DONE WITH ANY OF MY BILLS
THAT I'VE RUN IN THIS BUILDING,
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
YOU'VE MADE PRIOR TO ME, IS THAT
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM? HOW DO YOU
FIX IT? BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS IS HOW DO YOU
IMPLEMENT IT? AND EVERY YEAR WE
GO BACK AND AB 45, WE THOUGHT WE
HAD REALLY HAD SOME TIGHT REINS
AROUND THAT. AND THERE'S ALWAYS
SOME LOOPHOLE THAT SOMEONE'S
GOING TO FIND. I'M GOING TO
ASSURE YOU THAT I AM NOT GOING
TO LET THIS BILL CONTINUE UNTIL
WE GET THESE THINGS IRONED OUT.
I APPRECIATE THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS AND THE OPPOSITION, BECAUSE
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO COME TO
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
WORKABLE FOR ALL OF US. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOU
ALL HAVE AN EXCELLENT AUTHOR AND
I KNOW SHE'S GOING TO WORK VERY
HARD TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN. AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL DO
JUST THAT. VOTE IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS, ITEM NUMBER 16 A
B NØ. ITEM 15 AB 2490
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM. PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. WELL GOOD AFTERNOON,
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
PLEASED TO JOIN YOU THIS MORNING
OR AFTERNOON TO PRESENT AB 2490,
WHICH WILL EXPAND AND IMPROVE
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL,
AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TODAY. FOR
MANY PREGNANT CALIFORNIANS,
EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE THE MOST AND
SOMETIMES ONLY ACCESSIBLE SOURCE
OF MEDICAL CARE DUE TO A LACK OF
HEALTH INSURANCE AND A GROWING
SHORTAGE OF PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS, OB-GYNS AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CLINICS.
UNFORTUNATELY, TOO MANY
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEIR STAFF ARE
UNDERPREPARED TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS ARE ABLE TO GET QUALITY
MISCARRIAGE, CONTRACEPTION, AND
ABORTION RELATED CARE. THE
RESULT OF ALL OF THIS IS THAT IT
PUTS SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS AT RISK. AB 2490 WILL
ESTABLISH THE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
PROGRAM IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS TO EXPAND AND
IMPROVE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
IN EMERGENCY ROOMS ACROSS THE
STATE. THE PREMISE OF THIS BILL
IS SIMPLE IT SHOULD NOT MATTER
WHERE YOU LIVE IN ORDER TO GET
GOOD, SAFE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PLEASED TO BE JOINED TODAY BY
TWO WITNESSES, LYNNE CHÁVEZ, ON
BEHALF OF TEACH AND DOCTOR
SUZANNE GOODMAN. GOODMAN THANK
YOU. WELCOME. THANKS FOR JOINING
US. PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD. BEFORE SPEAKING,
PROCEED. WHEN READY. AWESOME.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR ROTH AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY. MY NAME
IS ALENA CHÁVEZ AND I'M THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR TEACH, WHICH
STANDS FOR TRAINING AND EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. AND WE ARE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 2490. TEACH
ENSURES PHYSICIANS AND ADVANCED
PRACTICE CLINICIANS HAVE THE
SKILLS NEEDED TO PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE, INCLUDING ABORTION,
FOR EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS. THERE
IS AN OBVIOUS GAP WHERE SUCH
TRAINING HASN'T BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY OFFERED TO THEM.
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE IS
COMPLETELY WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE, AND THIS TRAINING WILL
ENSURE THAT THE STANDARD OF CARE
IS AVAILABLE TO THOSE MOST
MARGINALIZED. FURTHER, EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS CANNOT CONTINUE TO
RELY ON REFERRING PATIENTS TO
OBS GIVEN MATERNITY WARD AND
LABOR AND DELIVERY UNITS.
CLOSURES IN RURAL AREAS,
EMERGENCY ROOM PHYSICIANS WILL
INCREASINGLY BECOME A PRIMARY
SOURCE OF HEALTH CARE IN RURAL
AND MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IN CALIFORNIA,
6,067% OF ABORTIONS ARE DONE
THROUGH THE ABORTION PILL
REGIMEN, AND WE ARE WITNESSING
AN INCREASE OF PEOPLE
SELF-MANAGING THEIR OWN
ABORTIONS, ESPECIALLY WITH THE
RISE OF TELEHEALTH, PRESCRIPTION
PEOPLE USING ABORTION PILLS MAY
ONLY HAVE CONTACT WITH THE
PROVIDER IN THE ED IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS, OR FEAR OF
COMPLICATIONS. ALL IN ALL, THIS
TRAINING IS DESIRED BY EDS IN
CALIFORNIA SO THEY CAN PROVIDE
THIS ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE, AND
ALL THEY REALLY NEED ARE THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DO SO.
THAT IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY.
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 2490.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY. I AM DOCTOR SUZANNE
GOODMAN, A UCSF CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AND EMERGENCY AND
FAMILY PHYSICIAN, AS WELL AS AN
ABORTION PROVIDER AND CO-FOUNDER
OF THE TEACH PROGRAM AS AN
EMERGENCY ROOM DOCTOR, I'VE
WORKED PART TIME FOR 25 YEARS IN
A RURAL CRITICAL ACCESS
EMERGENCY ROOM THAT JUST CLOSED
THREE MONTHS AGO ON THE COAST,
LEAVING YET ANOTHER ISOLATED
RURAL COMMUNITY STRUGGLING TO
GET THE CARE THEY NEED. AS AN ER
PHYSICIAN, I'VE HAD SO MANY
PATIENTS PRESENT WITH
COMPLICATIONS OF EARLY
PREGNANCY, SUCH AS BLEEDING. I
SAW ONE YOUNG PREGNANT MOTHER OF
THREE PRESENTING WITH BLEEDING
AND A THREATENED MISCARRIAGE.
EVEN THOUGH I HAVE THE SKILLS I
WAS UNABLE TO OFFER DEFINITIVE
MANAGEMENT OPTIONS DUE TO ER
POLICIES, LACK OF TRAINED STAFF,
BASIC MEDICATIONS AND EQUIPMENT,
I COULD ONLY OFFER WATCH AND
WAIT CARE WITH A REFERRAL TO THE
COUNTY HOSPITAL, WHICH USUALLY
TAKES WEEKS AND ESSENTIALLY
LEAVES PATIENTS BLEEDING IN PAIN
AND MANY BACK IN ANOTHER
EMERGENCY ROOM, REQUIRING A
PROCEDURE THAT I COULD HAVE
READILY PROVIDED. MANY ER DOCS
ACROSS THE STATE FIND THEMSELVES
IN A SIMILAR SITUATION. THE ER
IS THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF CARE
FOR MANY OF MY PREGNANT
PATIENTS, ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
ARE LOW INCOME AND BIPOC.
GETTING THEM TO SPECIALTY
CLINICS CAUSES CARE
FRAGMENTATION, WASTED TIME,
REPEAT TESTS AND EXAMS, LACK OF
PRIVACY AND SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED COSTS TO BOTH THE
PATIENT AND THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. WORSE, PATIENTS GET
FRUSTRATED. WAITING CAN END UP
IN CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS, OR
WHAT WE THINK OF AS FAKE
CLINICS, WHERE THEY NEVER GET
DEFINITIVE MANAGEMENT.
MISCARRIAGE RELATED CARE
ACCOUNTS FOR OVER 900,000
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS IN
THE UNITED STATES STATES EACH
YEAR. OPTIONS FOR MISCARRIAGE
MANAGEMENT INCLUDE EXPECTANT
MANAGEMENT, WHICH, AS I
MENTIONED, IS WATCHFUL WAITING,
MEDICATION MANAGEMENT, AND
UTERINE ASPIRATION, ALL OF WHICH
CAN BE SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY
INITIATED IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM.
THE DOBBS SUPREME COURT DECISION
HAS GREATLY LIMITED THE
AVAILABILITY OF CARE FOR EARLY
PREGNANCY COMPLICATIONS AND
ABORTION RELATED CARE FOR MANY
US PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA. AS
YOU'VE HEARD, OVER 40 LABOR AND
DELIVERY UNITS HAVE CLOSED IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE 2012, WITH OVER
HALF IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS. THE
RURAL SHORTAGE OF PERINATAL AND
OBSTETRIC DOCS HAS WORSENED
SINCE DOBBS, AND RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENTS ERS DESPERATELY
NEED THIS TRAINING AND CAPACITY.
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL WILL
PREPARE THOSE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OPTING IN TO OBTAIN
TRAINING, MEDICATIONS AND
MATERIALS NEEDED TO MANAGE
EVIDENCE BASED TREATMENT FOR
PREGNANCY LOSS, MISCARRIAGE AND
ABORTION. I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY.
PLEASE. SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD,
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OB-GYN
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. BRANDON MARKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SIR.
GRACE GLAZER ON BEHALF OF VALOR
US PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, VANESSA
KEENAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. TIM MADDEN,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON
BEHALF OF REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
FOR ALL CALIFORNIA CO-SPONSORS
KATHY MOSSBERG, ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BETH MALINOWSKI, THE SEIU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, DYLAN STAPLETON, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
KIMBERLY ROBINSON WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT, A CO-SPONSOR IN
SUPPORT, AS WELL AS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION, ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, BRIANNA
NELSON, ON BEHALF OF TEACH,
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 2490, IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES? STERN,
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES, ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? CONCERNS? NO, I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. IT'S JUST
SO UNFORTUNATE THAT OUR ERS ARE
THE POINT OF CONTACT FOR BASIC
CARE. JUST IS A TESTAMENT TO HOW
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO WORK, TO
OFFER ACCESSIBLE CARE FOR ALL
THAT IS CONTINUAL AND A SAFETY
NET FOR ALL COMMUNITIES AND
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. THANK YOU. SO, MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I WILL
SIMPLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, SENATOR. SO AS WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
WE'LL DO JUST THAT. THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING. NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER 17 AB 2670.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHIAVO,
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN, ABORTION
SERVICES. THANK YOU FOR COMING.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE CRISIS FACING
FACING ABORTION RIGHTS. YOU WERE
JUST TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
IT, AND, WE KNOW THAT THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT CALIFORNIA
IS PLAYING TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE AND THE COUNTRY
ARE ABLE TO FIND THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. HOWEVER,
MANY CALIFORNIANS DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO ACCESS ACCURATE AND
TRUSTED INFORMATION WHERE THEY
CAN SEEK REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE WHEN THEY NEED IT. IN FACT,
THERE ARE MANY WHO ARE ACTUALLY
DECEIVING PEOPLE ACROSS OUR
STATE ABOUT WHERE THEY CAN
ACCESS MEDICALLY ACCURATE AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARE. CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS, OR OFTEN
CALLED FAKE CLINICS, ARE CENTERS
THAT USE KNOWN DECEPTIVE
PRACTICES, TARGET VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS TO DRAW THEM IN FOR
CARE BY CLAIMING THAT THEY
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
WHEN THEY OFTEN HAVE NO LICENSED
MEDICAL STAFF ON SITE AND ARE
NOT, AND MANY ARE NOT, MEDICAL
CLINICS, AS WELL AS NO CAPACITY
OR WILLINGNESS TO PROVIDE
ABORTIONS OR EVEN REFER PEOPLE
TO ABORTION CARE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, FAKE CLINICS
ACTUALLY OUTNUMBER ABORTION
CLINICS BY 20, MAKING IT MORE
LIKELY FOR PEOPLE SEEKING
ABORTION CARE TO FIND THESE
CLINICS, RATHER THAN ONES THAT
ACTUALLY PROVIDE ACCURATE
INFORMATION AND COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE, INCLUDING ABORTION
CARE. THESE FAKE CLINICS SHAME,
INTENTIONALLY MISLEAD AND LIE TO
WOMEN ABOUT THEIR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE OPTIONS IN ORDER TO
BLOCK THEM FROM ACCESSING
ABORTION CARE, AND ARE OFTEN
CONFUSING TO PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. IN THE WORST CASES,
BEING MET WITH SHAME AND FEAR
AND BEING FED MISINFORMATION
ABOUT ABORTIONS DURING THIS TIME
CAN LEAD TO HIGHER RATES OF
INFERTILITY, DEPRESSION, AND
SUICIDE. IN AN ATTEMPT TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THEY CAN
GET ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT
WHERE TO ACCESS ABORTION CARE,
AB 2670 WILL PROMPT THE LAUNCH
OF A PUBLIC AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
TO COMMUNICATE THE FACTS ABOUT
PREGNANCY CARE AND ABORTION
SERVICES THROUGH ABORTION.
CA.GOV, A WEBSITE THAT WE'VE
CREATED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WHEN
WOMEN NEED ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE, IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY GET IS
TIMELY, FACTUAL, AND PROVIDES
THE BEST AND PROVIDERS THAT HAVE
YOUR BEST INTEREST IN MIND, NOT
AN AGENDA TO DISCOURAGE YOU FROM
SEEKING ABORTION CARE. WITH AB
2670, FACTUAL INFORMATION WILL
BE DELIVERED TO THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AS WELL AS THOSE, IN THE
HEALTH CARE SPACE TO ENSURE
ANYONE SEEKING ABORTION CARE
KNOWS WHERE TO GET MEDICALLY
ACCURATE, COMPREHENSIVE AND
UNBIASED INFORMATION. WE KNOW
THIS IS ESSENTIAL. REST ASSURED,
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CONTINUE TO FACE MORE EXTREME
BANS, AND WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL REMAIN A BEACON
OF HOPE. I ACTUALLY VISITED THE
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTER IN MY
DISTRICT AND HAVE A WHOLE STACK
OF INFORMATION THAT WAS GIVEN
OUT THERE, AND ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE FLIERS THAT I TOOK AWAY WAS
THIS CONFUSED MAN LEARNING ABOUT
Dð CONDOMS MAKE SAFE SEX SAFE,
THE TRUTH IS, IT SAYS EVEN IF
YOU USE A CONDOM EVERY TIME YOU
HAVE SEX, YOU'RE STILL PUTTING
YOURSELF AT RISK. SO THIS IS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE PUTTING
OUT. AND LOTS OF CONFUSION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT USING A CONDOM IS
EFFECTIVE. JUST BASIC SEXUAL
HEALTH INFORMATION BEING
MISREPRESENTED. AND YOU CAN
IMAGINE HOW THAT WORKS WHEN IT
COMES TO PEOPLE AT A VERY
VULNERABLE MOMENT SEEKING
ABORTION CARE. SO TODAY I HAVE
SYMPHONY BABI LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
AND ALSO DOCTOR GOODMAN, DOCTOR
GOODMAN, WHO HAS TO LEAVE SOON.
SO I'M TRYING TO BE QUICK,
CURRICULUM DIRECTOR AT TEACH FOR
ABORTION AND COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN. IS
THAT ON? YES, MA'AM. GREAT
AGAIN, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY. I'M
ACTUALLY READING A STATEMENT
TODAY FROM MY COLLEAGUE, DOCTOR
KELLY PFEIFER. SO SHE SAYS I
HAVE BEEN AN ABORTION PROVIDER
FOR OVER 25 YEARS, AND I
CURRENTLY PRACTICE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA, ARIZONA AND KANSAS.
I ALSO RUN AN ABORTION, AN
INDEPENDENT ABORTION CLINIC IN
KANSAS THAT SERVES PEOPLE WHO
TRAVEL FROM BANNED STATES
SEEKING CARE EVERY DAY IN
CLINIC. I SEE PEOPLE FOR WHOM
THE NEWS OF AN UNDESIRED
PREGNANCY WAS A CATASTROPHE.
MANY PANIC, FEARFUL THAT THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO GET THE HELP
THEY NEED. MOST ARE PARENTS AND
KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO BE A
PARENT. THEY FIND THEIR WAY TO A
CLINIC THROUGH THE INTERNET, BUT
MANY TIMES THEY GET PUT ON A
DETOUR THROUGH THE MISLEADING
INFORMATION WHERE THEY FIND THAT
THEY FIND THERE. I HAVE SEEN
MANY PATIENTS HARMED BY FAKE
CLINICS WHICH DELAYED THEIR
CARE. MANY OF THESE CLINICS ARE
NOT. MEDICAL CLINICS ARE NOT
STAFFED BY LICENSED PROVIDERS,
AND THEY HAVE GIVEN FALSE
INFORMATION, INCLUDING FAKE
ULTRASOUNDS, IN ANY OTHER PART
OF MEDICINE. WHEN I GET A TEST
RESULT FROM ANOTHER CENTER, I
TRUST IT. BUT WHEN PATIENTS
BRING IN THEIR ULTRASOUND FILMS,
I HAVE TO REPEAT THEM BECAUSE
PATIENTS ARE GIVEN FALSE
RESULTS, TOLD THEY ARE TOO FAR
ALONG TO GET AN ABORTION WHEN
THEY ARE STILL EARLY, ALL IN THE
INTEREST OF PREVENTING PATIENTS
FROM GETTING THE CARE THEY SEEK.
MY PATIENTS HAVE NO IDEA THAT
THEIR PERSONAL AND PRIVATE
HEALTH INFORMATION IS NOT
PRIVATE, THAT THESE PLACES CAN
SHARE THEIR PRIVATE DATA WITH
WHOMEVER THEY AND WHATEVER THEY
WANT. ONE OF MY PATIENTS WENT TO
ONE OF THESE CLINICS FOR AN
ULTRASOUND, ASSUMING IT WAS
PRIVATE, AND THE NEXT DAY SHE
GOT A CALL ON HER CELL PHONE
FROM AN ANTI-ABORTION ACTIVIST
TRYING TO PERSUADE HER TO CHANGE
HER MIND. I SEE PATIENTS WEEPING
BECAUSE THEY FEAR THEY WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO HAVE A BABY
AGAIN. ABORTIONS DO NOT CAUSE
INFERTILITY OR CANCER OR MENTAL
ILLNESS. THESE MYTHS HAVE BEEN
REPEATEDLY DISPROVEN, BUT
PATIENTS ARE TOLD THESE LIES
WHEN THEY THINK THEY'RE GETTING
LEGITIMATE HEALTH CARE. IN FAKE
CLINICS, PEOPLE GET FALSE
INFORMATION THAT AFFECTS THEM
PROFOUNDLY, AND THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES. CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE TO BE INFORMED. THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO MEDICAL CARE
WITHOUT BEING TRICKED. PLEASE
SUPPORT AB 2670 SO PATIENTS CAN
SEARCH THE INTERNET AND GET
RESULTS THAT THEY CAN TRUST.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. YES,
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS SYMPHONY BARBIE WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES WHO OPERATE
OVER 100 HEALTH CENTERS
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE TO
PATIENTS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
WE ARE PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 26. 72 YEARS AGO,
THE SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED ROE
V WADE, STRIPPING AWAY ACCESS TO
ABORTION AND RELATED CARE FOR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. AT THE SAME TIME,
CALIFORNIA, LED BY INVESTING IN
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE, IMPROVING ACCESS TO
PRACTICAL SUPPORT, AND CREATED
ABORTION CA.GOV, A COMPREHENSIVE
RESOURCE AND WEBSITE TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEED TO ACCESS ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS RESOURCE HAS
BEEN CRITICAL IN THE YEARS
POST-DOBBS AB 2670 WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO DEVELOP AN AWARENESS CAMPAIGN
TO HELP PUBLICIZE ABORTION
CA.GOV AND HELP COMBAT
MISINFORMATION AROUND ACCESS TO
ABORTION AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE. WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
SUBSTANTIAL PROGRESS MEETING THE
NEEDS OF PATIENTS, THERE ARE
INTENTIONAL AND INTENTIONAL
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS OUT
THERE DESIGNED TO CONFUSE AND
INTENTIONALLY MISLEAD PEOPLE
WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
OPTIONS. AB 2670 PROMOTES
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION RELATED TO SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE TO
FURTHER CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT
AS A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY,
PLEASE. MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON
BEHALF OF REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. KIM ROBINSON WITH
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BRIANA NELSON ON BEHALF OF TEACH
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE? WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DESK. COLLEAGUE.
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND MAKING SURE
WE HAVE THE RIGHT INFORMATION
FOR OUR POPULATIONS,
PARTICULARLY OUR YOUTH AND OUR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. AND WITH
THAT, I AM HAPPY TO MOVE THE
VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU MA'AM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU. REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. AND, OR REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT, AND, YOU KNOW, WE
CAN SEE WHAT AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THIS IS. I WAS JUST IN AN EVENT
LAST WEEKEND TALKING ABOUT THIS
BILL TO A CROWD OF FOLKS, AND NO
ONE KNEW ABOUT ABORTION. CA.GOV.
AND THESE ARE PRETTY POLITICALLY
INVOLVED PEOPLE WHO HAD NO IDEA
ABOUT IT. SO I THINK IT'S
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE'VE CREATED THIS GREAT
RESOURCE THAT CAN MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE FACTUAL INFORMATION.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY KNOW ABOUT IT. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. RESPECTFULLY ASK. I
VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT. AS
SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL
TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL DO
JUST THAT. THANKS FOR
PRESENTING. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. OKAY. NEXT ITEM,
ITEM NUMBER 22, ASSEMBLY BILL
2975, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON I
SEE YOU HERE. OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS,
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PLAN. PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT THIS SIMPLE,
DIRECT BILL, ASSEMBLY BILL 2975.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE,
THE CHAIR, AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR HELPING. I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS, AS WAS SUGGESTED,
THIS BILL SEEKS TO IMPROVE
HOSPITAL SAFETY BY REQUIRING
WEAPONS DETECTIONS, SCREENINGS
AT SELECTED HOSPITAL ENTRANCES
TO CONDUCT TO BE CONDUCTED BY A
TRAINED PERSONNEL. HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ARE ON THE FRONT LINE ON
THE DAILY BASIS, PROVIDING
PATIENT CARE, OFTEN FACING WITH
WITH FAMILIES AS WELL AS
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN CRISIS
DEALING WITH THEIR LOVED ONES.
ACCORDING TO THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS, HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ARE FIVE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
SUFFER, TO SUFFER WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE INJURIES MORE THAN ANY
OTHER WORKERS, IN THE UNITED
STATES, AND THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
GLARING. AND IT'S ON THE UPTICK
ON A DAILY BASIS, THIS ISSUE OF
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE ADDS HEALTH
CARE WORKERS, STRESS AND
BURNOUT, AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
EVEN DURING THE PANDEMIC, A LOT
OF OUR HEALTH CARE FRONTLINE
WARRIORS, LEFT A PROFESSION, WAS
TRAUMATIZED NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
THAT, BUT ALSO SAFETY WAS AN
ISSUE AS WELL. ASSEMBLY BILL
2975 PROPOSED TO ENHANCE AND
REQUIRE SAFETY MEASURES FOR
HOSPITALS BY REQUIRING COMMON
SENSE MEASURES, SUCH AS WEAPONS
DETECTION, SCREENINGS AT
SELECTIVE ENTRANCES TO ENSURE
THAT HOSPITALS REMAIN SAFE, A
SAFE PLACE FOR HEALING, AND NOT
VIOLENCE. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES, WILL BE
MISS MONIQUE, NICOLE HERNANDEZ,
A REGISTERED NURSE AT THE
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY HOSPITALS,
AND MATT, WITH THE GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ADVOCATE FOR SEIU, WHO
ALSO SELF INTRODUCED INTRODUCE
AS WELL. THANK YOU. WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD BEFORE SPEAKING AND FIRE
WHEN READY. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MONIQUE
NICOLE HERNANDEZ AND I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AT RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. I AM ALSO
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF SEIU 1 TO
1 RN. METAL DETECTORS ARE A
BASIC SAFETY MEASURE THAT SHOULD
BE IN PLACE IN EVERY HOSPITAL,
BUT THERE IS NO STATEWIDE POLICY
OR STANDARD ON METAL DETECTORS.
SO MANY OF US IN HEALTH CARE
FEEL VERY UNSAFE AT WORK. IN
JANUARY THIS PAST YEAR, A GROUP
OF MEN ATTEMPTED TO ENTER A FOUR
BEDROOM ROOM AT MY HOSPITAL
AFTER ANOTHER NURSE HAD ALREADY
ASKED THEM TO LEAVE THE
PREMISES. I HAD TO PHYSICALLY
BLOCK THEM FROM ENTERING THE
ROOM WITH MY BODY. THE MEN SAID
THEY HAD GOTTEN LOST ON THEIR
WAY OUT THROUGH TO ONE OF THE
OTHER MAIN ENTRANCES. WHEN THEY
LEFT, THE WAY I INSTRUCTED THE
PATIENT THEY WERE AFTER CAME OUT
FROM HIDING IN THE BATHROOM. HIS
OWN WORDS AND THE PATIENT
INFORMED ME THE SHORTER ONE HAD
A GUN. APPARENTLY THE PATIENT
HAD OWED THEM MONEY AND HAD
RECEIVED A DEATH THREAT. AFTER
ARRIVING AT THE HOSPITAL, HE
KNEW TO HIDE. BUT LIKE ME AND
THE THREE OTHER PATIENTS IN THIS
ROOM AND MY COLLEAGUES, WE HAD
NO IDEA WE WERE IN DANGER AFTER
THAT INCIDENT. NOTHING CHANGED.
THE MEN HAD, AFTER ALL, ABIDED
BY ALL THE HOSPITAL'S SECURITY
POLICIES. THEY SIGNED THEMSELVES
IN. NO FURTHER MEASURES WERE
TAKEN TO PROTECT OUR PATIENTS OR
US. STORIES LIKE MINE ARE
HAPPENING ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WHERE YOU AND YOUR
LOVED ONES GO TO RECEIVE, CARE
AND HEAL BECAUSE IT'S UP TO THE
HOSPITALS TO DECIDE THE LEVEL OF
SECURITY THEY EMPLOY OR NOT.
TODAY, EVEN HOSPITALS THAT HAVE
METAL DETECTORS, THEY COULD LOSE
THEM AT ANY TIME BECAUSE KEEPING
THEM IS SOLELY UP TO THE
HOSPITALS. BEING A NURSE IS
STRESSFUL ENOUGH WITHOUT THE
FEAR OF HAVING TO DEAL WITH
VIOLENCE ON OUR MIND. OUR
PATIENTS DESERVE OUR TOTAL
ATTENTION. I WAS LUCKY TO GO
HOME THIS DAY IN JANUARY, BUT
THIS IS NOT LOST ON ME. NO ONE
SHOULD RELY ON LUCK TO MAKE IT
HOME FROM WORK, PERIOD. IT'S A
TROUBLING TREND RIGHT NOW IN
HOSPITALS WHERE HOSPITALS
COMPROMISE NURSE SAFETY. AS A
COST SAVING MEASURE. INSTEAD OF
INVESTING IN COMPREHENSIVE
SECURITY PROTOCOLS, SOME
HOSPITALS CHOOSE MINIMAL
MEASURES THAT LEAVE STAFF AND
PATIENTS VULNERABLE. ALL
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE QUALITY
HEALTH CARE, AND THEY ALSO
DESERVE A SAFE HEALTH CARE. WE
NEED. AB 2975. THE SECURE
HOSPITALS FOR ALL BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR COMING AND
FOR PRESENTING. YES, SIR. ALL
RIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON. ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, PROUD
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. AND WANT TO
THANK BOTH THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL AND THE
LABOR COMMITTEE AS WELL. THIS IS
ONE THAT WE WORKED HARD ON. SO,
YOU KNOW, FOR THIS BILL, WE DO
REALLY SEE THIS AS A STEP
FORWARD TO TRY TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY FOR OUR WORKFORCE.
UNFORTUNATELY, DURING THE
PANDEMIC, THERE WAS A RECENT
STUDY THAT WAS DONE THAT FOUND,
DESPITE THE DROP IN BOTH PATIENT
VOLUME AND VISITOR VOLUME, THE
INCIDENCE OF VIOLENCE CONTINUED,
AND SO IT'S A REALLY IT'S A
RISING ISSUE IN OUR HOSPITALS.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT THE
WORST CONSEQUENCES OF WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE, WHICH IS WHEN A KNIFE
OR ANOTHER WEAPON IS INCLUDED.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, THAT'S WHY
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE BILL, LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND OTHER OPPOSITION AS WE, YOU
KNOW, WORK TO TRY TO CRAFT
SOMETHING THAT IS BOTH WORKABLE
BUT IS ALSO GOING TO ADDRESS THE
SAFETY AND DO WANT TO APPRECIATE
THE TENOR THAT THEY BRING TO THE
CONVERSATION AROUND MAKING SURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THEY CAN DO, WHILE ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR WORKERS
ARE SAFE. SO WITH THAT, I JUST,
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK READY. THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT. OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. WE NEED TO
TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO TAKE CARE
OF US. AND WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHATEVER WE DO, AS
WITH ANYTHING ELSE WE DO UP
HERE, IS WORKABLE. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND SEIU FOR WORKING
WITH US, WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND WITH THOSE WHO WERE ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THIS ISSUE, TO
TRY TO CRAFT SOMETHING THAT IS
DOABLE WHILE WE WHILE WE PROTECT
THOSE WHO NEED PROTECTION. SO
OTHER SUPPORTERS, ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR. MEMBERS ELMER
LAZARD, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE?
HOW ABOUT OPPOSITION LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST. COME
ON DOWN. COME ON. YOU KNOW THE
RULES. NAME. IDENTIFY YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD, PLEASE. AND THEN
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD MORNING
OR GOOD AFTERNOON. CHRISTY
WEISS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND CA IS HERE TODAY IN AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
REALLY WANT TO THANK AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR, THE SPONSOR AND THE
COMMITTEE. AND YOU KNOW, THIS IS
A HARD ONE BECAUSE WE TO
CONSIDER THE GREATEST PRIORITY
TO BE THE SAFETY OF THE
EMPLOYEES AT THE HOSPITAL, THE
PATIENTS AT THE HOSPITAL, AND
EVERYONE WHO GOES IN AND OUT OF
HOSPITALS. SO WE ARE VERY
ALIGNED ON THE GOAL. THE
CHALLENGE FOR US IS, AS IS OFTEN
THE CASE, THE DEVIL IS IN THE
DETAILS HERE. WITH OVER 400
HOSPITALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF DIFFERENT SIZES AND
CONFIGURATIONS, YOU KNOW WE NEED
THE FLEXIBILITY TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE DO METAL DETECTORS GO. IS
A METAL DETECTOR THE BEST AND
MOST APPROPRIATE, YOU KNOW,
SYSTEM TO HAVE AT THAT HOSPITAL?
WE REALLY APPRECIATE, THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR RURAL HOSPITALS
AND ALLOW THEM TO USE THE TO
INCLUDE THE USE OF WANDS. WE'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT FOR ALL OF THE
HOSPITALS BECAUSE REALLY, WHAT
WE FIND IS THE CHALLENGE WITH
THE BILL IS THE LANGUAGE, AS IS,
IS TOO PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF
WHERE THE METAL DETECTORS HAVE
TO GO, YOU KNOW, KIND OF WHAT
CAN BE USED WITHIN THOSE
SYSTEMS. SO WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE ISSUES, GET TO A
PLACE WHERE THERE'S GREATER
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE HOSPITALS.
AND, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, WE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF WORKING WITH CAL
OSHA TO COME UP WITH STANDARDS.
SO WE ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
FRAMEWORK AND THAT PARADIGM. WE
JUST REALLY WANT GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN TERMS OF HOW WE
CREATE THE SYSTEMS, THE, THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE THAT NONE
OF US WANTS TO SEE IS THAT A
SYSTEM IS IN PLACE THAT CREATES
LOGJAMS OR INTO THE HOSPITALS AND
SO, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR
TO TRY TO WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, SARAH BRIDGE, ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS, REALLY
WANT TO HEAR A POST TO THE BILL.
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION? I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE WERE PLEASED TO SEE THE
COMMITTEE SUGGEST AMENDMENTS
AROUND THE RURAL HOSPITALS,
ALLOWING THEM TO USE HAND ONLY
METAL DETECTORS AGREE THAT THAT
SHOULD BE AN OPTION FOR OTHER
HOSPITALS. HOWEVER, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OUR RURAL
HOSPITALS HAVE PARTICULAR
SPATIAL AND FINANCIAL CHALLENGES
THAT OTHER HOSPITALS DO NOT. OUR
REMAINING CONCERNS ARE AROUND
POTENTIAL LIABILITY FOR THE
HOSPITALS, IN PARTICULAR
HOSPITALS ARE FEDERALLY REQUIRED
TO DELIVER CARE. WE HAVE NO
ABILITY TO TURN AWAY PATIENTS
SEEKING HOSPITAL AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO
GO THROUGH A METAL DETECTOR, SO
WANT CLEAR STANDARDS ON WHAT
CONSTITUTES A WEAPON, HOW TO
RETURN THOSE WEAPONS.
ADDITIONALLY, WE HAVE CONCERNS
AROUND STORING WEAPONS AND
ENGAGING LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
APPROPRIATE. WE ARE ENCOURAGED
BY THE DIRECTION THE BILL IS
MOVING. WE AGAIN SHARE IN THE
SENTIMENT, THE INTENT AND THE
GOAL BEHIND THE BILL TO KEEP OUR
PATIENTS AND A WORKFORCE SAFE.
HOWEVER, AT THIS TIME, WE ARE
STILL RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
UNLESS FURTHER AMENDED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION? KELLY BROOKS, I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS.
WE HAVE A CONCERNS POSITION AND
WE REMAIN, CONCERNED WITH THE
STORAGE PROVISIONS AS WELL.
THANKS ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION?
WELL, I'LL SAY THIS. THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE. WE NEED
TO HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS IN
PLACE. OBVIOUSLY, THE OSHA, I
MEAN, I USED TO DO THIS WORK,
THE OSHA STANDARDS BOARD IS
THERE FOR A REASON. NORMALLY THE
CALIFORNIA CODE OF REGULATIONS
SETS OUT WITH MORE SPECIFICITY
WHAT WE NORMALLY PUT IN STATUTE.
HOWEVER, THAT TAKES TIME. AND SO
AS YOU WORK THROUGH THIS PROCESS,
IF THE BILL PASSES OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ONTO THE FLOOR AND
OFF THE FLOOR, PERHAPS DURING
THAT PROCESS YOU CAN PROVIDE
SOME LANGUAGE THAT THE STANDARDS
BOARD COULD ISSUE, MORE SPECIFIC
RULES AND, AND DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF WHERE WE ACTUALLY PLACE
THIS EQUIPMENT IN HOSPITALS TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT VARIATIONS IN
SIZE AND, AND ALL OF THE REST.
BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE, IT
SEEMS TO ME WE NEED TO GET SOME
RULES IN PLACE AND THEN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MODIFY THEM TO MAKE
THEM WORKABLE. IF WE CAN'T DO IT
IN THE BILL ITSELF, TO HAVE
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW THE STANDARDS
BOARD TO DO IT, AND THEN MAKE
SURE WE MAKE THEM MAKE THE RULES
WORKABLE FOR HOSPITALS AT THE
SAME TIME AS WE PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS, BADLY NEEDED
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS. WE I'M
SURE YOU CAN WORK OUT ISSUES
ABOUT WHEN YOU NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND WHETHER YOU
CONFISCATE WEAPONS OR NOTIFY LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WHETHER YOU STORE
THEM IN CERTAIN CASES. YOU KNOW,
THE LAW IS PRETTY CLEAR. EVEN
THOSE WHO ARE AUTHORIZED TO
CARRY FIREARMS WITH A CCW ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE THEM ON
HOSPITAL PROPERTY. AND SO THOSE
WHO DO, HAVEN'T READ THE BOOK.
YES. THANK YOU FOR THAT,
SENATOR. AND THAT WOULD VERY
MUCH BE OUR PREFERENCE TO WORK
WITH CAL OSHA TO COME UP WITH
THE STANDARDS. THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IS SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT SHE USES, AS IS
BEING TOO PRESCRIPTIVE, IS WOULD
GO INTO THE STATUTE, AND THAT
WOULD BE THE FRAMEWORK THAT CAL
OSHA WOULD HAVE TO WORK, KIND OF
UNDERNEATH. WELL, UNLESS THE
STATUTE SAYS OTHERWISE. RIGHT
AND THOSE ARE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'RE HOPING. WELL, BUT,
YOU KNOW, AT THE, AT AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF WEAPONS DETECTION DEVICE
IN PLACE WHERE THE PUBLIC ENTERS
THE FACILITY TO SCREEN OUT
FIREARMS, TO SCREEN OUT KNIVES
THAT ARE IN VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA LAW, BECAUSE THERE'S
A RULE AGAINST THAT. AND ALL OF
THE REST BEFORE THOSE PEOPLE GET
ACCESS TO THE FACILITY, ACCESS
TO STAFF AND ACCESS TO PATIENTS.
SO AND THE PROBLEM WITH THE
STANDARDS BOARD PROCESS, IT
TAKES A WHILE. YES AND SOMETIMES
IT TAKES A LONG WHILE. AND
BETWEEN NOW AND THE LONG WHILE,
WE HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
WHO POTENTIALLY ARE AT RISK. AND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER IS IN THE BILL,
PROTECTS THEM. SO THOSE ARE MY
COMMENTS. BUT LET ME TURN IT
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES? ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? CONCERNS? NO. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. WE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION IN LABOR
COMMITTEE, AND IT'S JUST A SAD
DAY IN CALIFORNIA WHEN WE HAVE
TO PUT MEDICAL DETECTORS AT A
HOSPITAL BECAUSE OF HOW
PREVALENT WEAPONS AND GUNS ARE,
PARTICULARLY IN OUR IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND IT IS THE
BALANCING ACT OF MAKING SURE
THAT OUR WORKERS, OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS, THAT WE RELY ON SO MUCH
ARE SAFE. REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
STORY, AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT YOU
GOT HOME ON THAT DAY. BUT
BALANCING IT ALSO WITH THE
FAMILIES AND VISITORS WHO ARE
COMING INTO THE HOSPITALS, WE
KNOW WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT GETS
INVOLVED, IT CAN BE A VERY, A
VERY, CHALLENGING SITUATION
BECAUSE OF INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
AND BARRIERS AND PROFILING AND
SO, YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH LABOR COMMITTEE,
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I HAVE DEEP RESPECT FOR
THE AUTHOR, THERE'S I'M GONNA
LAY OFF THE BILL TODAY, AND THE
ONLY REASON IS, IS BECAUSE I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT, YOU
KNOW, WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION, THERE'S SEVERAL
HOSPITALS IN MY DISTRICT, AND,
YOU KNOW, GOOD SAMARITAN HAS
THREE EXITS AND THREE ENTRANCES,
I THINK DIGNITY HEALTH HAS 16,
SO, AND I THINK THAT THERE IS A
WE DO HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT EMPLOYEES AND, AND
PATIENTS ARE SAFE, BUT WE ALSO
HAVE A BALANCING ACT, AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT,
HOSPITALS HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT WHERE THE LIABILITY FALLS
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND I
KNOW YOU'RE A PERSON THAT WILL
WORK WITH OPPOSITION TO SOLVE
SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS. I'VE
WORKED WITH YOU FOR YEARS, EVEN
IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND SO I'LL
TRUST YOU TO WORK OUT THESE
ISSUES. SO I'LL RESERVE MY RIGHT
TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL IF IT
COMES TO THE FLOOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO, MEMBER GIBSON,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE VERY
BRIEFLY? I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND THANK EACH
SENATOR FOR YOUR COMMENTARY
REGARDING THIS, I WAS JUST AS
THE DIALOG ENSUED AND TOOK
PLACE, I WAS THINKING ABOUT THE
STATE CAPITOL BACK IN THE 60S
WHEN WILLIE BROWN WAS THE
SPEAKER. I REMEMBER IT VERY
VIVIDLY, IN THAT CAPITOL ACROSS
THE STREET WHERE PEOPLE BROUGHT
GUNS INTO THE CAPITOL, TODAY WE
DON'T I REMEMBER ALSO GOING BACK
IN MEMORY OF HARVEY MILK, IF IN
FACT, THERE WAS METAL DETECTORS
IN THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS,
WOULD HE STILL BE WITH US TODAY,
I EVEN COME BACK TO THE PRESENT
TIME WHERE WE'RE IN TODAY, WHERE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
NURSES, WHERE WE'VE HAD
EMPLOYEES IN HOSPITALS HAVE
DISPUTES AMONG EACH OTHER, WHERE
WEAPONS WAS ALSO BROUGHT INTO
THE WORKPLACE. I OFTEN GO BACK
TO JUST THE PRESENT TIME WHEN
WALKING IN THIS BUILDING.
THERE'S A METAL DETECTOR COMING
INTO THIS BUILDING, NOT ONLY FOR
THE THOSE PROTECTIONS OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE, BUT ALSO
FOR LAWMAKERS AS WELL. WHEN YOU
WHEN I LEAVE THIS PLACE
TOMORROW, I WILL BE GOING TO THE
AIRPORT AND THROUGH THAT AIRPORT
THERE'S TSA. I WILL BE GOING
THROUGH A DETECTIVE, A DETECTION
PROCESS, A METAL DETECTOR, NOT
ONLY THROUGH MY BAGS, BUT ALSO
ON MY PERSON TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T WHAT I'M TRYING TO SIMPLY
SAY IS WE DON'T LIVE IN A TIME
IN THE 60S. WE LIVE IN DIFFERENT
TIMES TODAY WHERE WE HAVE TO
ALSO IMPLEMENT MEASURES THAT
SPEAKS TO OUR DAY AND TIME THAT
WE'RE LIVING IN RIGHT NOW.
SAFETY IS AN ISSUE. THE
ARTICULATION FROM VICE PRESIDENT
HERNANDEZ AGAIN BRINGS HOME THE
POINT THAT WE CANNOT WAIT. WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROTECT OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS,
AND EVEN THE CHAIRMAN SAID AS
WELL, WE HAVE TO PROTECT THOSE
FRONTLINE WORKERS BECAUSE THOSE
ARE THE ONES WHO'S CARING FOR
OURSELVES, OUR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND ALIKE. AND THE BEST WAY TO
DO THAT IS IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL
WAY, COMING TOGETHER, HAVING
THIS ROBUST CONVERSATION, TRYING
TO FIND THE BALANCE WITH BOTH
SIDES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE,
PROTECT THOSE FRONT LINE WORKERS
AS WELL AS THOSE PATIENTS
SEEKING CARE. AND I HOPE WITH
THE WISDOM THAT'S ON THIS IN
THIS BODY, THAT YOU WILL RENDER
YOUR. I VOTE IN SUPPORT OF 2975.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. NICE PRESENTATION. YOU
KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY THE
HOSPITALS ARE THE PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE IN CONFLICT WIND UP. AND
WHETHER IT'S A DOMESTIC DISPUTE
OR A BUSINESS DISPUTE OR
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT QUITE
LAWFUL AND IT'S A DISPUTE, THOSE
FOLKS, SOME OF THEM WIND UP IN
THE HOSPITAL, AND SOMETIMES
PEOPLE WANT TO CONTINUE THE
DISPUTE ONCE THEY'RE IN THE
HOSPITAL. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN WE MAKE AN
ATTEMPT TO STOP THAT BEFORE IT
OCCURS. SO THANK YOU, SIR, FOR
THE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'LL BE
AVAILABLE OVER OUR DISTRICT
BREAK AND INTO AUGUST. I'M NOT
DEAD YET. I'LL BE AROUND IN
AUGUST. IF YOU NEED OUR HELP
HERE TO PUT THIS THING TOGETHER
A LITTLE BIT. BETTER TO TRY TO
ACHIEVE SOMETHING CLOSER TO
PERFECTION. WE'LL BE HERE TO DO
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ITEM
NUMBER 23 AB 3047 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY YOUTH ATHLETICS.
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. IS THIS YOUR LAST
BILL? THIS IS THE LAST BILL.
THIS IS YOUR LAST EVER HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE. WELL,
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT, BUT
I'M NOT GOING TO JINX MYSELF.
WELL, IF IT IS, CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU. YES, THIS IS A TOPIC
THAT I'M VERY COMMITTED TO,
FOCUSING ON THE HEALTH OF OUR
YOUNGEST ATHLETES IN CALIFORNIA,
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL. I GREW UP
PLAYING FOOTBALL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO IN THE HOT WEATHER,
JUST LIKE THIS SUMMER. I PLAYED
TACKLE FOOTBALL AND FLAG
FOOTBALL. AND, YOU KNOW, YEARS
LATER, NOW WE'RE LEARNING THAT,
TACKLE FOOTBALL HAS A SEVERE
IMPACT ON OUR YOUTH. WE'RE GOING
TO HEAR FROM OUR WITNESSES AND
OUR NEUROLOGY ASSOCIATION AND A
BIT, MORE AND MORE RESEARCH IS
COMING OUT, YOU KNOW, FRANKLY,
PARENTS ARE VOTING WITH THEIR
FEET. THEY'RE PICKING OTHER
OPTIONS LIKE FLAG FOOTBALL AND
SOCCER, AND NOW FLAG FOOTBALL AS
AN OLYMPIC SPORT, THE NFL PLAYS
IN THE PRO BOWL. IT'S A HIGH
SCHOOL SPORT FOR GIRLS NOW, SO
IT IS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
PROTECTING OUR YOUNGEST KIDS.
AND MORE AND MORE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT JUST LIKE SMOKING THE EARLY
YEARS START SMOKING. THE GREATER
YOUR RISK TO GET CANCER LATER IN
LIFE. AND YOU KNOW, CUMULATIVE
HITS TO THE BRAIN ARE REALLY
IMPACTFUL. AND OUR RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT KIDS THAT PLAY YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL UNDER 12 ARE 15
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO HAVE HEAD
IMPACTS THAN FLAG FOOTBALL. IT'S
NOT JUST CTE AND CONCUSSIONS.
IT'S A LITTLE SUBCONCUSSIVE HITS
OVER AND OVER WHEN YOU'RE TAKING
WHEN YOU'RE DOING A PRACTICE
LITTLE DRILLS OVER AND OVER. NOT
A BIG CONCUSSION, BUT THE LITTLE
HITS OVER AND OVER HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT. AS OUR
RESEARCHERS WILL SHOW YOU. SO
WE'RE NOT ALWAYS EXPERTS ON THIS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T FIND OUT
UNLESS THE PERSON DIES. THAT'S
WHY YOU HEAR THESE TRAGEDIES OF
KIDS THAT HAVE CTE. THEY ONE KID
HERE IN CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR PUT
HIS FAMILY ON THE PHONE, TOLD
HIM HE WAS GOING TO COMMIT
SUICIDE AND SHOT HIMSELF IN THE
HEART SO THEY COULD STUDY THE
BRAIN. ATHLETES LIKE JUNIOR SAU,
THE LEGEND SAN DIEGO CHARGER IN
OCEANSIDE, THE SAME THING. SO
THIS IS THE ONLY THING YOU FIND
WHEN SOMEBODY DIES. SO THE
IMPACTS ARE SEVERE FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS IN CALIFORNIA, WE
COULD CERTAINLY HAVE, YOU KNOW,
AN OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE BETTER, YOU KNOW, RULES
OF THE GAME FOR, FOR KIDS THAT
PLAY IN HIGH SCHOOL. THERE'S A
GREAT DEBATE AS FAR AS WHAT AN
ENTRY LEVEL SHOULD BE. ONE THING
THAT WE DECIDED THAT WE WANTED
TO DO, WE TALKED THIS A COUPLE
YEARS AGO, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ENCOURAGED US TO
WORK ON THIS AGAIN THIS YEAR, AS
OPPOSED TO SETTING A DATE FOR
WHEN YOU WOULD START PLAYING.
THIS IS TO HAVE US DO SOME MORE
RESEARCH. AND THIS WOULD DIRECT
OUR SURGEON GENERAL TO CONVENE
TO CONVENE A COMMISSION, A STUDY
OF THE RISKS AND BRAIN INJURY
IMPACTS RELATED TO YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL, WITH ME ARE TWO
DISTINGUISHED WITNESSES. I'D ASK
YOU TO LISTEN TO THEM AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SIR.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. HELLO, MY NAME IS SARAH
TOLLINTON. I'M FROM PLEASANTON,
CALIFORNIA, AND I AM HERE TODAY
AS A CHILD OF A PARENT DIAGNOSED
WITH CTE. I COME FROM A FOOTBALL
FAMILY. MY DAD PLAYED DIVISION
ONE FOOTBALL FOR THE UNIVERSITY
OF FLORIDA. MY BROTHER PLAYED
FOR OKLAHOMA STATE, AND I WAS A
DIVISION ONE ROWER AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI. WHILE I
LOVE SPORTS AND THE INVALUABLE
LESSONS THEY TEACH, FOOTBALL
ALSO TOOK MY FATHER AWAY FROM ME.
MY DAD WAS A MAN OF REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENTS. HE WAS THE FIRST
IN HIS FAMILY TO GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE, SOMETHING THAT WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE WITHOUT
FOOTBALL. HE EARNED HIS MBA AND
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO ADVANCING
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERY, SUPPORTING
THE WORK OF FOUR NOBEL
LAUREATES. YET BY THE END OF HIS
LIFE, HE COULD BARELY HOLD A
CONVERSATION AND COULDN'T KEEP A
JOB AT A LOCAL GROCERY STORE.
THE FAMILY HE WAS SO PROUD OF,
HE WAS ESTRANGED FROM MY DAD
DIED AT THE AGE OF 59, ALONE IN
HIS APARTMENT, AND THANKS TO
CTE, I LOST MY DAD YEARS BEFORE
HIS ACTUAL DEATH, BEFORE THINGS
GOT AS BAD AS THEY DID MY DAD
ASKED US TO DONATE HIS BRAIN FOR
CONCUSSION RESEARCH TO BENEFIT
OTHER ATHLETES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AS A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGY DOCTORAL STUDENT, I
HAVE DEDICATED MY DISSERTATION
TO LEARNING FROM OTHER SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS OF CTE. EVERY
SINGLE FAMILY MEMBER THERE.
THEIR STORIES ARE HAUNTINGLY
SIMILAR. THE SPORT THEY LOVED
DESTROYED THEIR LIVES. EVERY
SINGLE FAMILY MEMBER I HAVE
SPOKEN TO HAS WISHED THAT THEY
AND THEIR LOVED ONE HAD KNOWN
THE RISKS. WHILE SOME STILL
WOULD HAVE PLAYED FOOTBALL, THE
RIGHT TO MAKE THAT INFORMED
CHOICE WAS TAKEN FROM THEM. I AM
HERE TODAY TO URGE YOU TO STUDY
SAFER PRACTICES FOR FOOTBALL,
AND CONSIDER ESTABLISHING A
MINIMUM AGE FOR YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL. ADVOCATING FOR AB 3047
IS NOT ABOUT TAKING AWAY
FOOTBALL OR ITS VALUES, BUT
ABOUT ENSURING INFORMED CONSENT.
HISTORY HAS SHOWN US THE
IMPORTANCE OF REEVALUATING WHAT
WE ONCE THOUGHT WAS SAFE, LIKE
HOW CIGARETTES WERE ONCE
PHYSICIAN TESTED AND APPROVED.
THESE TRAGEDIES ARE NOT ISOLATED.
REPETITIVE HEAD IMPACTS ARE TO
BLAME. THE PAIN MY FAMILY
ENDURED WAS PREVENTABLE. CTE IS
PREVENTABLE. TACKLE FOOTBALL CAN
WAIT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US AND FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. YES, SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS STEVE KOTALIK. I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
NEUROLOGY SOCIETY AND THEIR
PRESIDENT, STELLA LEGARDA, WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY, WE'VE
PROVIDED THE, LEGISLATURE WITH
VOLUMES AND VOLUMES OF
STATISTICS AND STUDIES STARTING
BACK. WELL INTO LAST YEAR. AND
SO I'M NOT GOING TO GO RECITE
THOSE ONCE AGAIN. BUT I DO WANT
TO MENTION THAT, THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT PARENTS HAVE
NEEDS TO BE FILLED. WE WERE TOLD
THAT WITH THE ORIGINAL VERSION
OF THIS BILL. AND SO THE CURRENT
VERSION IS GOING TO FULFILL THAT
TASK. IT'S SO IMPORTANT. AND I
CAN ONLY, TALK TO MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. AND SIMILAR TO
SARAH'S, MY FATHER PLAYED
FOOTBALL AT CAL IN THE 30S, AND
HE PLAYED RUGBY. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE HELMETS. AND UNFORTUNATELY
IN THE EARLY 1980S, HE WAS ONE
OF THE VERY FIRST BRAINS THAT
WAS, ANALYZED BECAUSE HE DIED OF
DEMENTIA. MY MOM DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO. HIS BROTHERS WERE
BRUTAL ON HIM BECAUSE OF HIS
LOSS OF FACULTIES. THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT. NOBODY DID. AND
IF WE CAN DO ANYTHING TO KEEP
THAT FROM HAPPENING. AND THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT FOOTBALL NEEDS
TO BE OUTLAWED AND NONE OF THAT.
BUT IF WE CAN DO IT BETTER AND
WE CAN KNOW MORE ABOUT IT, WE
SHOULD. AND THIS BILL WILL TAKE
US A LONG WAY TOWARDS THAT. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NAME,
AFFILIATION, POSITION ON THE
MEASURE, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
VANESSA KEENAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION, SIR. COME ON DOWN.
WOULD HAVE SAID GOOD MORNING,
BUT IT'S CLEARLY AFTERNOON NOW.
SO I SAY THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE. I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
A REALLY BUSY AGENDA, AND YOU'LL
PROBABLY APPRECIATE THAT. I WILL
KEEP MY REMARKS BRIEF, AS IT'S A
LONG DAY AND I RESPECT THE WORK
YOU'RE DOING UP HERE. GREAT.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS RON WHITE,
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL
ALLIANCE, REPRESENTING THOUSANDS
OF YOUTH FOOTBALL PARTICIPANTS
STATEWIDE. WE RESPECTFULLY COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY IN STAUNCH
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
3047. AS WRITTEN FOR THE PAST
SIX YEARS. AND I SAID HELLO TO
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY IN THE WAY
IN, BECAUSE WE'VE HAD CONSTANT
CONVERSATION, WE HAVE TRAVELED
TO THE CAPITOL FROM ALL CORNERS
OF THE STATE TO STAND UP FOR THE
RIGHTS OF PARENTS, PLAYERS AND
COMMUNITIES AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THIS TESTIMONY DURING THAT
TIME, WE'VE ALSO PLAYED A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ESTABLISHING
THE MOST COMPREHENSIVE YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL SAFETY
LEGISLATION IN THE COUNTRY, THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL ACT,
TO DATE, IT IS THE ONLY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OF ITS KIND IN THE
NATION AND WILL SOON BE MODELED
IN OTHER STATES. I THINK THAT'S
REALLY KEY FOR THIS CONVERSATION.
WE OPPOSE AB 3047 AS IT FOCUSES
SOLELY ON A SINGLE YOUTH SPORT
IN CALIFORNIA, YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL AND DOES NOT MENTION
NOR REFERENCE COUNTLESS OTHER
CONTACT SPORTS OR ACTIVITIES
STATEWIDE, SUCH AS SOCCER,
WRESTLING, BASKETBALL, JUNIOR
BOXING, MMA, RUGBY, FLAG
FOOTBALL, LACROSSE, MOTOCROSS,
AND MANY OTHER SPORTS NOT LISTED
DURING TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS. YOU
MAY HEAR MEDICAL OPINIONS
OFFERED BY THE AUTHOR AND THOSE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
3047. IT IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THOSE OPINIONS ARE
NOT SHARED UNILATERALLY BY THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY, AS IS CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED IN MULTIPLE STUDIES,
INCLUDING A STUDY RELEASED JUST
IN THE PAST 30 DAYS BY THE
HARVARD UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH, WHICH FOUND, AND
I QUOTE, NO SIGNIFICANT
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN FIRST
PLAYING TACKLE FOOTBALL BEFORE
THE AGE OF 12 AND ADVERSE
OUTCOMES LATER IN LIFE. WE HAVE
PROVIDED COUNTLESS COMPREHENSIVE
STUDIES IN THIS AREA, INCLUDING
RESEARCH LISTED IN THE LANCET
AND OTHER PEER REVIEWED, EXCUSE
ME, PEER REVIEWED PUBLICATIONS
DEMONSTRATING SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFERENT OUTCOMES AS YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL AND SCIENCE ARE
CONSTANTLY EVOLVING AS WRITTEN
AB 3047, IN ITS CURRENT STATE
SEEKS VIA PROPOSED STUDY TO
ESTABLISH A MINIMUM AGE OF PLAY
FOR YOUTH, TACKLE FOOTBALL,
KNOWING THERE IS NO SUCH
LEGISLATIVE NOR CLINICAL
PRECEDENT IN THIS AREA FOR YOUTH
SPORTS AND OR ACTIVITIES OF ANY
KIND IN CALIFORNIA, IT WAS
STATED IN A RECENT INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BY PROPONENTS OF THIS
BILL THAT, QUOTE, SCIENCE CANNOT
TELL US THE RIGHT AGE TO PLAY OR
NOT TO PLAY YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL. WE, ALONG WITH MANY
MEDICAL EXCUSE ME, MEDICAL
EXPERTS AGREE AS CAUSATION IS
NOT CORRELATION IN THE BILL'S
ANALYSIS, THE AUTHOR IS QUOTED
SAYING THERE IS NO REAL WAY TO
SAFELY PLAY YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL. WE ADAMANTLY DISAGREE
AS THE CURRENT VERSION OF YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL BEING PLAYED
TODAY, IT IS THE SAFEST VERSION
IN THIS COUNTRY'S HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOW. AND I SAY
THIS PROUDLY NOW LEADING THE
NATION THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH FOOTBALL ACT, IT IS VITAL
WHEN INFORMING PUBLIC POLICY
WITH SIGNIFICANT RISK OF
NEGATIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WE EXAMINED THIS
PROCESS WITH CLINICAL CLARITY.
AB 3047 ALIENATES CONSTITUENTS
AND ATTEMPTS TO UNRAVEL THE WORK
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
VIA ASSEMBLY BILL ONE. EXCUSE
ME, AB ONE AND WE DO NOT SEE AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR THIS AB
3047 AS A COMPANION BILL TO THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL ACT.
NOT AT ALL. AS CALIFORNIANS, WE
HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
EDUCATE AND INFORM THE PUBLIC
VIA AB ONE, THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
FOOTBALL ACT AND RESPECTFULLY.
RESOURCES SHOULD BE ALLOCATED IN
THAT DIRECTION AND NOT ON A
DISCRIMINATORY SINGLE SPORT
STUDY BILL THAT IS IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY. WITH ALL THAT BEING
SAID, FOR THOSE REASONS
OUTLINED, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON AB 3047. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, I'LL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS SENATOR
MENGIBAR, THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
I DON'T KNOW IF THE SPONSORS OR
THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO, ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS, THE ANALYSIS BY
THIS COMMITTEE HAD REALLY,
CONFLICTING INFORMATION
REGARDING THE NEED. I MEAN,
THERE'S VARIOUS STUDIES THAT
SHOW THAT THERE IS NO
CORRELATION. FOR REGARDLESS OF
WHAT AGE YOU START PLAYING
TACKLE FOOTBALL, I MEAN, THERE'S
MIXED REVIEWS WITH PROFESSIONAL
NFL PLAYERS AND THEN I ALSO
THINK ABOUT THIS ON THE ON FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. RIGHT.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR KIDS
TO BE ACTIVE. TO STAY OUT OF
DRUGS OR BE AT PROMISED RISK
YOUTH. SO I FEEL LIKE IN PUSHING
THIS AND I'M OKAY WITH THE
COMMISSION PART, BUT THE PART
THAT IT'S ASKING TO COME UP WITH
A MINIMUM AGE TO PLAY A TACKLE,
SPORTS THAT REQUIRES A PARENT OR
A GUARDIAN TO APPROVE, I THINK
GOES A LITTLE FAR, IN MY
OPINION. SO I'M JUST WONDERING,
SINCE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
OUTSTANDING STUDIES, THE NEED
FOR BRINGING FORWARD A
COMMISSION THAT IS GOING TO COME
UP WITH A MINIMUM AGE. SO PLEASE.
YEAH, THOSE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS.
AND THE QUESTIONS WE GET ASKED
ALL THE TIME. LET ME ASK THE
ANSWER. THE SECOND ONE FIRST.
YOU WEREN'T HERE WHEN I STARTED,
BUT I GREW UP IN THIS HOT AREA
OF SACRAMENTO AND PLAYED TACKLE
FOOTBALL AND POP WARNER AND
SOCCER AS A KID. AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT POP WARNER IS WAY MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN FLAG FOOTBALL AND
SOCCER. SO THEY'RE ALL OUR
ALTERNATIVES. IF YOU IF YOU
GOOGLE RIGHT NOW FOOTBALL
OPPORTUNITIES, THERE ARE WAY
MORE FLAG FOOTBALL OPPORTUNITIES
THAN THERE ARE TACKLE. SO THERE
ARE WAYS FOR KIDS TO GET
INVOLVED AT A SAFER AGE. I MEAN,
PARENTS ARE VOTING WITH THEIR
FEET. THERE ARE WAY MORE FLAG
OPPORTUNITIES NOW. NOW BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, FLAG IS A HIGH SCHOOL
SPORT FOR GIRLS, AN OLYMPIC
SPORT. THE NFL IS DOING FLAG FOR
A REASON BECAUSE THERE'S
INHERENT RISKS, YOU KNOW, NFL
PLAYERS IN DROVES ARE SAYING WE
SHOULD WAIT. YOU KNOW TOM BRADY
THE YOU KNOW THE BEST EVER
DIDN'T PLAY HIGH SCHOOL, DIDN'T
PLAY FOOTBALL TEAMS IN HIGH
SCHOOL, WE HAVE ONE MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATURE WHO PLAYED IN
THE NFL NOT ME, AVELLINO,
VALENCIA. AND HE IS A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS, SO HE BELIEVES
THAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON THIS
BECAUSE THERE ARE INHERENT RISKS
AND YOU CAN WAIT. THERE ARE
OTHER OPTIONS, BUT YOUR BIGGER
QUESTION, THERE IS NO SMOKING
GUN EVIDENCE TO THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS A DISEASE. YOU DON'T
FIND OUT UNTIL SOMEONE'S DEAD.
FIND OUT UNTIL SOMEONE IS DEAD
TO THEIR BRAIN. IT'S NOT LIKE
TOBACCO RESEARCH. 40 YEARS AGO
WHEN YOU KNOW, IT WAS A CRYSTAL
CLEAR POINT IN TIME, SAYS, OKAY,
THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR OUR
YOUNGEST KIDS. WHAT? WE SAID,
YOU WAIT TILL YOU'RE 18. SO WHAT
WE'RE DOING ISN'T MAKING A
DECISION. THERE WAS AN IDEA. I
DID HAVE THAT WE WOULD ACTUALLY
SET A POLICY. THIS IS ASKS OUR
OUR STATE SURGEON GENERAL TO
EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
SHOULD BE A MINIMUM AGE, MAYBE
THE MINIMUM AGE SHE COMES BACK
WITH OR HE OR SHE COMES BACK
WITH SAYS IT'S FOUR YEARS OLD,
WHICH IT WOULDN'T BE A MINIMUM
AGE. SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
SETTING WHAT IT WOULD BE. IT'S
ASKING THE QUESTION, SHOULD
THERE BE ONE? AND I THINK THIS
HELPS YOU KNOW, ANSWER THE
ISSUES AS FAR AS YOU KNOW, WHAT
IS BEST FOR THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF KIDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. DO YOU WANT TO
EXPAND UPON THAT? YEAH. THANK
YOU, I WOULD I WOULD ECHO THE
ASSEMBLYMAN'S COMMENTS AND IN
FACT, THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF
THIS BILL WAS A LITTLE DRACONIAN
IN IN THE SENSE THAT IT DID TRY
TO DRAW A LINE, THE REQUEST FROM
THE FOOTBALL FOLKS WAS TO
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR A
PARENT TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISION. AND IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE WAS A DEARTH OF
INFORMATION AVAILABLE. THE
SURGEON GENERAL WILL HELP US
BACKFILL THAT INFORMATION. AND
ALLOW PARENTS TO MAKE AN
INFORMED, DECISION. THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT FLAG FOOTBALL IS A
GREAT ALTERNATIVE. IT'S MUCH
LESS EXPENSIVE. SO IF YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT MAKING THINGS
AVAILABLE FOR KIDS, THAT'S
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ANSWER.
THERE'S AN AD HERE THAT PUTS
ALMOST $600 PRICE TAG ON JUST
THE EQUIPMENT ALONE, LITTLE ON
ANYTHING ELSE. AND IF YOU TAKE
THAT 600 BUCKS AND PUT IT
AGAINST A COUPLE EXTRA FIELDS
AND SOME OTHER PEOPLE THAT CAN
SUPERVISE THE ACTIVITY, I THINK
YOU COME OUT AHEAD. SO THE POINT
THAT WE NEEDED TO TRY TO MAKE
WAS WE WEREN'T TRYING TO AND
MAYBE WE CAME AT IT HAM HANDEDLY
TRYING TO DRAW A LINE. BUT BY
THE SAME TOKEN, PARENTS DO HAVE
A RIGHT AND THEY SHOULD MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION. AND I WILL
TELL YOU, AS I DID WITH MY
FATHER'S, EXPERIENCE AND YOURS
AS WELL, YOU DON'T KNOW. AND YOU
CAN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT THINGS
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW. SO THE MORE
WE KNOW, THE BETTER OFF WE'RE
GOING TO BE. PERFECT PLEASE
PROCEED. CAN YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, CAN YOU TALK TO ME
ABOUT. BECAUSE THERE ARE
CONFLICTING STUDIES, CONFLICTING
STUDIES. THE COMMISSION IS THIS
A COMMISSION? WHAT IS YOUR
INTENT HERE? WHAT WHAT STUDIES
ARE THEY GOING TO BE LOOKING AT,
GUARDRAILS THAT IT'S NOT ONE
SIDED JUST BECAUSE IT'S JUST
VERY CONFLICTING. CONFLICTING
INFORMATION. WELL, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE ACTUAL BILL ON, JUST A
SHORT BILL, TWO PAGE BILL ON
SECTION TWO, IT SAYS THE SURGEON
GENERAL SHALL CONVENE A
COMMISSION AND IT SAYS WHO
SHOULD BE ON THERE? AND IT SAYS
CONSIST OF SELECTED MEMBERS
INCLUDE NOT IT SHOULD INCLUDE
NOT BE LIMITED TO PEOPLE IN
YOUTH SPORTS, PUBLIC HEALTH,
NEUROSCIENCE, PEDIATRICIAN. SO,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE FROM ALL SIDES TO LOOK AT
THE ISSUE AND, AND, AND COME UP
WITH MORE CLARITY AND ADVICE FOR
OUR YOUTH AND FOR OUR FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. IS IT
OKAY IF I ANSWER THIS A LITTLE
BIT, IN REGARD TO THE
CONFLICTING STUDY, I AM A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGY DOCTORAL
STUDENT WRITING MY DISSERTATION,
INTERVIEWING FAMILY MEMBERS, AND
PART OF WRITING A SUCCESSFUL
DISSERTATION IS EXAMINING BOTH
SIDES. SO EVEN THOUGH I MAY WANT
TO ANSWER ONE QUESTION, I DO
NEED TO LOOK AT BOTH SIDES OF
THE COIN. AND WHILE THERE MAY BE
LIMITED, CONFLICTING DATA, I
ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT
THE FUNDING BEHIND THE DATA THAT
IS CONFLICTING. THESE STUDIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE, THEY EXIST.
AND IF THE BIG QUESTION IS, YOU
KNOW, IF THIS CONFLICTING DATA
IS OUT THERE, WHY SHOULD WE DO
THINGS? THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE'RE
CALLING FOR THIS, FOR YOU ALL TO
INVESTIGATE THIS FURTHER. SO
IT'S NOT EITHER SIDE JUST COMING
AT THIS, BUT SAYING LIKE, HEY,
HAVE AN OBJECTIVE VIEW OF THIS
BECAUSE FAMILIES ARE BEING
AFFECTED AND THIS IS A HEALTH
RISK. CAN I RESPOND TO THAT AS
WELL? I CAN WAIT, CERTAINLY.
SURE. I JUST WANT TO NOTE THE
I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL AND THE
BILL ASKS THIS PARTICULAR
COMMISSION, LED BY THE SURGEON
GENERAL, A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER,
TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THESE ARE. THIS
ISN'T RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON
THE STUDY THAT'S CONDUCTED. AND
IF IT'S NOT, AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM PREVIOUS BILLS HERE, WE
HAVE WE HAVE THE BATTLE OF
SCIENTIFIC STUDIES ALL THE TIME.
AND SOMEONE HAS TO SIT DOWN AND
TRY TO SORT THROUGH THEM AND,
AND THEN MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO WHAT SHOULD BE. AND IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE, THE LANGUAGE
TALKS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, AN
APPROPRIATE MINIMUM AGE FOR
PARTICIPATION, WHICH VERY I'M
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE RUNNING FOOTBALL
LEAGUES AND THE LIKE HAVE
MINIMUM AGES FOR PARTICIPATION.
SURE. CERTAINLY AND IT MAY VERY
WELL BE THAT THE SURGEON GENERAL
AND THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION COINCIDES
COMPLETELY WITH THE CURRENT
RECOMMENDATION WITH THE CURRENT
MINIMUM AGE THAT YOU HAVE FOR
PARTICIPATION IN YOUR LEAGUES.
WE DON'T KNOW. RIGHT. BUT THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE A COMMISSION AND A
SURGEON GENERAL. TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS. IF THE BILL HAD BEEN
PRESCRIPTIVE AND HAD SET MINIMUM
AGE OF 16, THEN I GUESS WE WOULD
BE HAVING A DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION. BUT THIS IS JUST A
SORT OF WE CALL THEM A STUDY
BILL. SURE, I'M FAMILIAR, BUT
YES, YOU MAY RESPOND. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE FAIR
RESPONSE. BUT WE HAVE TWO
CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL. AND
PRIOR TO THE CONCERNS, I WANT TO
MAKE A STATEMENT. IN 2022, A
SIMILAR BILL WAS RAN. AND
THROUGH THE WISDOM OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOM, THAT BILL WAS VETOED.
AND TWO THINGS THAT WERE CITED
IN THAT VETO WAS THE FISCAL
IMPACT. AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE AS A STATE WHERE WE'RE AT
FISCALLY NOW AND WHAT'S REALLY
BEING IGNORED IN THIS
CONVERSATION, NOT FROM YOU
FOLKS, BUT JUST OVERALL WITH THE
AUTHOR, IS THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
FOOTBALL ACT. HE CITED BOTH OF
THOSE. WE HAVE AN OFF RAMP. WE
HAVE A MECHANISM, AND IT'S THE
ONLY PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN THE
COUNTRY. AND RESOURCES,
RESPECTFULLY, SHOULD BE PUT IN
THAT CATEGORY. THE TWO ISSUES,
AND WE ARE OPPOSING THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN FOR THIS ONE REASON, IF
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED EARLY ON INSTEAD OF A
BAN BILL. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
CALL THIS, BECAUSE WHEN YOU SET
A MINIMUM AGE OR YOU ATTEMPT TO
DO THAT GOING BACK TO 2018, THEN
YOU'RE CUTTING OFF A SEGMENT OF
THE POPULATION. THAT'S THE
HISTORICAL CHRONOLOGICAL OF
THAT. SO WE'RE CONCERNED BECAUSE
THIS IS A SIX YEAR JOURNEY. IN
THIS PROCESS, THE YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL COMMUNITY WENT TO WORK,
ROLLED UP ITS SLEEVES, AND
THROUGH THE WISDOM AND HELP OF
ASSEMBLYMAN COOPER, WE DRAFTED A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT IS
GROUNDBREAKING. THAT'S NUMBER
ONE, AND IT SEEMS TO BE IGNORED
IN THIS CONVERSATION. NUMBER
TWO, OUR CONCERN IS THE LIMITED
SCOPE AND THE WAY THAT THIS
STUDY BILL IS BEING ROLLED OUT.
IF WE FELT THAT THIS WAS A FAIR
AND EQUITABLE BILL,
RESPECTFULLY, TO EVERYONE HERE,
I WOULD BE FLANKED AT THIS TABLE
WITH FOLKS FROM JUNIOR RUGBY,
BOXING, ANY CONTACT SPORT IN IN
THE STATE. WE'RE ALONE ONCE
AGAIN WITH THE MICROSCOPE ON
YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL. SCIENCE
IS UNSETTLED. AND RESPECTFULLY
TO THE FOLKS TO MY LEFT, WHAT
THEY'VE SHARED HERE IS
HEARTBREAKING. AND I WEAR A LOT
OF HATS. BUT AS A FATHER, THAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THAT I WEAR.
BUT I WOULD SAY TO THEM AND
EVERYBODY HERE THAT SPORT IS NOT
THIS SPORT. I'VE SPENT THREE AND
A HALF DECADES AS AN ADVOCATE
FOR YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL,
HELPING GROW THE SPORT, HELPING
EVOLVE THE SPORT. AND I HEARD A
MEMBER, EXCUSE ME, A COMMITTEE
MEMBER, MENJIVAR, SAY, WHAT IS
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE?
WHAT'S THE IMPACT? I CAN ALSO
TELL YOU, WHEN WE POTENTIALLY
START REMOVING PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES, THE UNINTENDED
NEGATIVE IMPACT COULD BE THROUGH
THE ROOF. AND I DON'T JUST SAY
THAT AS A FOOTBALL PERSON, I SAY
THAT AS A RETIRED STATE PEACE
OFFICER. SIR. YES, SIR. I'M
GIVING YOU TIME TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU. BUT I WANT TO INTERRUPT AND
PLEASE. RUDE. BUT REMEMBER, THIS
IS A RECOMMENDATION. IF IT COMES
BACK HERE, NOTHING HAPPENS
UNLESS THIS LEGISLATURE OR THE
FOLLOW ON LEGISLATURES THAT WILL
COME. AND SOMEBODY ELSE SITTING
IN THIS CHAIR SURELY DECIDE IT
SHOULD HAPPEN. SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE STAY FOCUSED ON
WHAT THIS BILL IS AND REMEMBER
WHAT IT IS NOT. MY COLLEAGUES
MAY CHOOSE NOT TO SUPPORT IT,
MAY CHOOSE TO VOTE NO, STAY OFF
THE BILL. THAT'S WHAT THIS
PROCESS IS ALL ABOUT. BECAUSE WE
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENCIES AND IT'S NOT WHAT
WE THINK, IT'S WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS THINK. IT MATTERS.
BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T CAUSE ALARM FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE LISTENING TO THE
HEARING, WHO MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THE BILL. AND HAVEN'T READ
IT. THANK YOU, MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE ANALYSIS AND HAVE
IT READ IT. AND THEY THINK THAT
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING HERE TO
PROVIDE TO PREVENT THEIR SON OR
DAUGHTER FROM PARTICIPATING IN A
SCHOOL FOOTBALL GAME OR A LEAGUE
FOOTBALL GAME SOMEWHERE. THAT IS
NOT THIS BILL. AND IF THERE'S
SOMEBODY HERE WHO THINKS
DIFFERENTLY, PLEASE SPEAK UP NOW.
NÓ. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT
POINT. I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOU MAKING THAT POINT, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU REFERENCED THE
WORD ALARM, BUT THERE IS SOME
ALARM, AND I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE LINING OUT WHAT THIS
BILL WILL OR WILL NOT DO. BUT I
WANT TO SAY AGAIN, FOR THE
RECORD, RESPECTFULLY, THAT IF
THIS WAS PERCEIVED, AT LEAST
FROM THE TACKLE FOOTBALL
COMMUNITY, AS A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE BILL, WE WOULD BE
FLANKED WITH MULTIPLE OTHER
SPORTS IN THIS STATE INSTEAD OF
THERE BEING A CONTINUOUS
MICROSCOPE ON YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL. AND THE IRONY OF THAT,
AND THIS IS PERTINENT TO THE
BILL, THE IRONY OF THAT FOR US
FROM OUR POSITION IS WE'RE THE
GROUP THAT'S ROLLING UP OUR
SLEEVES. WE'RE THE GROUP THAT
WENT TO WORK WITH CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS BECAUSE WE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WE CAN DO
BETTER AND WE ARE BETTER, AND WE
HAVE AN OFF RAMP AND A
MECHANISM. AND I FEEL AS IF THAT
IS A REALLY CRUCIAL PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE MISSING
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION THAT
ARE NOT REPRESENTED HERE.
RESPECTFULLY OKAY. WHERE ARE WE?
SENATOR MENGIBAR COLLEAGUES, ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? WHO?
Ó. SENATOR LIMON, PLEASE JUMP
IN. THANK YOU. AND, I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT BECAUSE I'VE
ACTUALLY WATCHED THE EVOLUTION
OF THIS SUBJECT MATTER IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WHEN, I SERVED
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY, THIS
ISSUE CAME UP AND IT WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT BILL, VERY DIFFERENT
BILL TO THE ONE THAT IS IN FRONT
OF US. THAT IS JUST A
RECOMMENDATION, AND I REMEMBER
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU
ABOUT THAT BILL. AND SO I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL
DIDN'T COME OUT OF, YOU KNOW,
ANYWHERE THAT THE FIRST VERSION
OF WHAT WAS INTRODUCED WAS VERY
DIFFERENT. AND TO GET A GROUP OF
EXPERTS TO COME TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS,
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
ORIGINAL ISSUE, THE ORIGINAL
BILL FEELS LIKE THE RIGHT STEP
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND I JUST WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS, IT'S INTERESTING AND ALSO
COMPLICATED TO ME TO HEAR SOME
OF THE SAME ARGUMENTS THAT WERE
BEING USED ON A DIFFERENT BILL,
USED TODAY, WHEN THIS BILL HAS
MADE A LOT OF CHANGES, OR THIS
TOPIC HAS MADE A LOT OF CHANGES.
AND SO I ASKED MYSELF, WILL
THERE EVER BE A TIME WHERE AS
LONG AS WE TALK ABOUT TACKLE
FOOTBALL, THESE ARGUMENTS WON'T
BE MADE? AND, YOU KNOW, I'VE
BEEN HERE EIGHT YEARS AND I HEAR
THE SAME ARGUMENTS NO MATTER
WHAT THE BILL IS. BUT THE BILL
IS ACTUALLY VERY, VERY, VERY
DIFFERENT, VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WAS INTRODUCED IN THE
LEGISLATURE, YEARS BACK BEFORE
THE 2022 BILL. SO JUST TO BE
CLEAR, BEFORE THE 2022 BILL AND,
YOU KNOW, I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL, I ALSO THINK THAT
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY TO BRING,
AND I AGREE WITH BRINGING FOLKS
TOGETHER THAT ARE EXPERTS IN
THIS SPACE TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED A RECOMMENDATION IS
NOT A LAW. AND SO I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE
AND WHEN WE HAVE QUORUM. THANK
YOU, SENATOR LIMÓN, LISTEN, I
WANT IT TO BE CLEAR. I'M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF TEAM SPORTS, YOUTH
TEAM SPORTS, TEAM SPORTS. IN
SCHOOL, I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
IN THE MILITARY. WE CALL THAT A
TEAM SPORT, SORT OF. BUT IT
REQUIRES TEAMWORK, ORGANIZATION,
FOCUS, THE ABILITY TO PLAY WELL
IN THE SANDBOX. ALL THE THINGS
THAT WHAT YOU DO AND OTHERS JUST
LIKE YOU DO, WITH YOUNG PEOPLE,
WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, IT'S AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE. I WILL NOTE THAT ONE
OF THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL IS IN ADDITION TO HAVING TO
ANALYZING SCIENTIFIC DATA AND
COMING UP WITH SOME VARIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS, IS TO ALSO
RECOMMEND RECOMMEND THE BEST
PRACTICES FOR MINIMIZING ANY
RISKS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED
THROUGH THIS PROCESS. SO THERE'S
A LOT OF GOOD THAT CAN COME OUT
OF THIS COMMISSION THAT'S GOING
TO BE PRESENTED BACK TO THOSE
WHO ARE SITTING HERE. WON'T BE
ME, TO THINK ABOUT WHAT TO DO,
IF ANYTHING. AND IT COULD VERY
WELL COME OUT ENTIRELY. THE
OUTCOME COULD BE ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT THAN THE OUTCOME THAT
YOU'RE PREDICTING. WE'LL WE'LL
JUST SEE HOW THIS PROCESS GOES.
SEEING NO OTHER HANDS UP SOME
MEMBER HAVE AT IT. YEAH. THIS IS
A, CERTAINLY A TOPIC YOU COULD
GET A LOT OF DEBATE TOMORROW AT
THE 4TH OF JULY PARADES AROUND
CALIFORNIA, TAKING AWAY
FIREWORKS OR APPLE PIE, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS THERE'S
CONFLICTING OPINIONS ON THIS,
AND YOU HAVE RESEARCH FROM FROM
PEOPLE IN ACADEMIA AND SCIENCE,
AND YOU HAVE RESEARCH THAT
SOMETIMES IS PAID BY THE
INDUSTRY. AND PEOPLE QUESTION
THAT. YOU KNOW, JUST LIKE YEARS
AGO, WE HEARD FROM THE TOBACCO
INDUSTRY THAT CIGARETTES WITH
FILTERS WILL BE SAFE. LIKE WE
REALIZE, NO, THAT WASN'T TRUE.
SO THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
KIND OF PEEL THE LAYERS OF IT
OFF AND HAVE SOME INDEPENDENT
ANALYSIS AS FAR AS WHAT'S BEST
FOR CALIFORNIA. I WILL SAY THAT,
YEAH, WE ARE IN A BUDGET
SITUATION AND I DID PROPOSE LAST
YEAR OTHER LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD HAVE HAD A POLICY FOR AN
AGE, AND THE ADMINISTRATION
ASKED US TO STEP BACK AND ASKED
US TO GO FORWARD WITH THE BILL
SO WE CAN HAVE A MORE THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSION OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
JUST NOW. SO CERTAINLY, THE
FINANCES OF CALIFORNIA WILL
DICTATE WHERE WE GO NEXT. BUT I
THINK THIS IS A FAIR APPROACH.
AND, AND YOU LAID IT OUT GREAT.
MR. CHAIRMAN, AS FAR AS BEING
OPEN TO IDEAS AND WHERE WE GO
FROM HERE. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. AS SOON AS
WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE WILL TAKE A VOTE.
I DO WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
TAKING YOUR TIME TO COME. COME
DOWN HERE AND PARTICIPATE AND
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT ON BOTH SIDES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I THINK
WE WILL BE IN RECESS FOR TEN
MINUTES. I WILL ASK THE
SERGEANTS TO CALL THE MEMBERS SO
WE CAN GET A QUORUM AND WE CAN
TAKE A VOTE. THANK YOU. CRLA
OKAY. THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL BE BACK IN
SESSION AFTER OUR RELATIVELY
SHORT RECESS. LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. SENATOR ROTH HERE. ROTH
HERE. WEN HERE. WEN HERE.
GLASER. GLASER. HERE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. HERE. GROVE HURTADO.
LIMÓN LEMON. HERE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE RUBIO. RUBIO.
PRESENT. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE. WIENER
WIENER. PRESENT WE HAVE. OKAY.
WE HAVE A QUORUM. LET'S, TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ARE
TEN ITEMS ON THE PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR. DOES ANY
MEMBER NEED ME TO READ THEM?
EVERYBODY KNOW WHAT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS? OKAY. LET'S. WE
NEED A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOVE IT. NGUYEN
SENATOR NGUYEN MOVED THE MOTION.
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH I ROTH. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WIENER I VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS NINE ZERO.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. LET'S THEN
CONTINUE WITH. WE'LL SKIP OVER
ITEM NUMBER ONE FOR THE MOMENT.
LET'S CONTINUE WITH ITEM NUMBER
TWO. AB 815. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PROVIDER CREDENTIALS THE MOTION
DO PASS AS AMENDED? WE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION BY SEN. GONZALEZ,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE ROTH. AYE. WHEN? NO.
WHEN. NO GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. LIMÓN LIMÓN. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO I.
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. WIENER.
WIENER. I VOTE 8 TO 1. WE'LL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 1577, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
LOW GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS. MOTION TO PASS
REREFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION SO MOVED, BY SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH. AYE
ROTH. AYE. WHEN NO. WHEN. NO.
GLASER. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. SORRY.
THREE. NO. GROVE NO. HURTADO
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR AYE. RUBIO. HI. RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WIENER. AYE. VOTE IS 8 TO
2. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 1895.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, PUBLIC
HEALTH MATERNITY WARD CLOSURES
MOTION DO PASS AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED LIMÓN BY
SENATOR LIMÓN. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. WHEN GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. NGUYEN. NØ.
Ó NGUYEN. CHANGES TO NGUYEN. NØ
GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO WHO
CHANGED? WHAT IS IT? 8 TO 2.
EIGHT. TWO. YES. EIGHT. 8 TO 2.
VOTE IS 8 TO 2. WILL HOLD OR
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB 2115.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY.
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES CLINICS.
MOTION Dð PASS. WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION BY SENATOR RUBIO?
YES. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
WHEN GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
HURTADO LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. VOTE IS 8 TO 0.
WE'LL HOLD THEIR OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2223 IS SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
CANNABIS INDUSTRIAL HEMP MOTION
IS DUE PASS. WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? MR. CHAIR, CAN
YOU DID SHE TAKE AMENDMENTS, NO.
IS THERE A MOTION? BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ, THERE'S A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE. WHEN
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. LIMÓN LIMON. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER.
AYE WIENER. AYE. NGUYEN AYE.
GROVE. AYE WHEN? AYE GROVE I
VOTE IS TEN ZERO. HOLD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS, NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TEN, AB 2316.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL PUPIL
NUTRITION. MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? IS THERE A
MOTION, SENATOR GONZALEZ MAKES
THE MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH, I ROTH. AYE. WHEN?
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO. JUST MAKE
SURE. SENATOR RUBIO, ARE YOU
VOTING? NOT VOTING. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WIENER WIENER. I VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 14. AB 2467.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARKAN HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE FOR MENOPAUSE
MOTION DO PASS. WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? SENATOR RUBIO
MAKES THE MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH Ã ROTH.
AYE. WHEN GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. HURTADO AYE. LIMÓN
LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR MENGIBAR.
AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER. AYE WIENER
I VOTE NINE ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROPE. AND FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 2490. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM. MOTION DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION? SO
MOVED. SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
HAD MADE THE MOTION EARLIER. SHE
JUST CONFIRMED IT DURING THE
TIME WE COULD MAKE A MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. Ã ROTH. AYE. WHEN NO.
WHEN? NO. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE.
GROVE. NO. HURTADO HURTADO. AYE.
LIMÓN. LIMON AYE. MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
VOTE IS 9 TO 2. THAT MEASURE IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER 17,
AB 2670 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SCHIAVO AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
SCHIAVO AND HOLDEN AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN. ABORTION SERVICES
MOTION DO PASS AND BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS, IS THERE A
MOTION? SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
MAKES THE MOTION. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL, SENATOR ROS I. ROTH
AYE. WHEN GLASER. GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
GROVE. NO HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE.
LIMÓN LIMON. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE WIENER. WIENER. AYE.
NGUYEN. NÓ. NGUYEN CHANGES. NO
THAT'S IT. RIGHT. YES VOTE IS 9
TO 2. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. NEXT
ITEM, ITEM NUMBER 20 A B 2893 IS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. WARDEN HANEY
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY RESIDENCY
PROGRAM. MOTION TO PASS THIS AS
AMENDED, WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION? LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, ANYONE WANTS TO MOVE
THIS LIMÓN. SEE, SENATOR LEMON
MADE THE MOTION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH I. ROTH. AYE.
WHEN GLASER. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN.
LIMÓN AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR
AYE. RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER WIENER. AYE.
THAT'S EVERYBODY. NINE ZERO. YES
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
22, AB 2975. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON. OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PLAN. MOTION
DO PASS, AS AMENDED. WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
IS THERE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR HURTADO HURTADO? EXCUSE
ME. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I. ROTH. AYE. WHEN
GLASER. GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE
MENGIBAR. YES. YES. YES I'M. I'M
SORRY. WHAT SHE SAID. AYE.
MENGIBAR I OKAY. MENGIBAR. AYE
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE SAID
EVERYBODY. EVERYBODY VOTE IS
NINE ZERO. THAT MATTER IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM, ITEM NUMBER 23 AB
3047 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
YOUTH ATHLETICS MOTION DO PASS
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. IT'S BEEN
SENATE-TV LIMON. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MOVE THIS? SENATOR LIMON
MOVES IT. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH Ã ROTH. AYE. WHEN
GLASER, GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. HURTADO AYE.
LIMÓN. LIMÓN. AYE MENGIBAR.
RUBIO RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE
WIENER. WIENER. AYE GLASER I.
GLASER. AYE 8 TO 0. THAT'S IT.
RIGHT? YEP VOTE IS 8 TO 0. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER 24.
MOVE IT. AB 3156 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. PATTERSON AND NGUYEN,
BUT MOVED BY SENATOR NGUYEN,
MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS.
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH I ROTH. AYE
WHEN I WHEN I. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. HURTADO
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN. LIMÓN AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. GIVE ME A
MINUTE. HERE SO LET'S GO TO.
WELL, MELANIE'S GOING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT TO TELL ME. LET'S.
OKAY. OKAY. WELL, LET'S TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 347 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING. HOUSEHOLD PRODUCT
SAFETY. TOXIC SUBSTANCES TESTING
AND ENFORCEMENT. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED. WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT WHAT WE WILL BE VOTING ON
WITH RESPECT TO THE MOCKUP. WE
ARE GOING TO REMOVE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE SECTION 111 673B
STARTING ON OR ABOUT JANUARY
1ST, 2026, THE DEPARTMENT SHALL
ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT SET AN
ENFORCEMENT THRESHOLD. THAT
SUBSECTION WILL BE REMOVED FROM
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON. EVERYBODY
UNDERSTAND? YES. OKAY. IS THERE
A MOTION? WITH THE AMENDMENTS
WITH AS AMENDED, SENATOR RUBIO
HAS MADE THE MOTION AS I'VE
OUTLINED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE
WHEN? GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN.
LIMÓN AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR.
AYE RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
WIENER WIENER. AYE LETS OUT. YES
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM. LET'S
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ANYBODY NEED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? READ I DON'T THINK SO.
OKAY. CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATOR GROVE, I GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO I VOTE IS
11 ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT. GOING BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB 815 ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE PROVIDER
CREDENTIALS MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED. REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 8
TO 1 CHAIR. VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR GROVE.
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE CURRENT
VOTE 9 TO 1. THAT MATTER IS OUT.
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 1577. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
LOW GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS. MOTION DO PASS. WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 8
TO 2. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. HURTADO. HURTADO.
AYE VOTE IS 9 TO 2. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1895 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. PUBLIC HEALTH
MATERNITY WARD CLOSURES. MOTION
DO PASS. REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE
8 TO 2. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. HURTADO.
HURTADO I VOTE 9 TO 2. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. AB 2115. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
CLINICS MOTION DO PASS. WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 8
TO 0. CHAIR VOTING AYE, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL WHEN GROVE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 2223.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGAR CURRY.
CANNABIS. INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CURRENT VOTE IS TEN ZERO. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. MOTION. DO PASS. WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. HURTADO HURTADO
I VOTE IS 11 ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB 2316. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL PUPIL NUTRITION. MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED. WE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
WEN GROVE. HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE
RUBIO. VOTE IS 8 TO 0. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER 14. ASSEMBLY BILL 2467 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOWER KHN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE FOR
MENOPAUSE MOTION Dð PASS. REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE 9
TO 0 CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. NGUYEN GROVE.
FINAL VOTE NINE ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER 15. THAT ONE'S OUT.
SEVENTEENS OUT 20 IS OUT. 22 IS
OUT. 23 IS OUT. AND 24 IS OUT.
AND THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY'S HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT WORK. OH MY GOD. THANK YOU
FOR SAYING THAT. I ALMOST HAD A
NERVOUS BREAKDOWN.